foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
dreams are coming true on and off the
board at the American Cup in St Louis
Colin Graham with the Make-A-Wish
foundation's dream was to meet and watch
the best chess players in the country
and they were honored to oblige beg him
toker Genova was Unstoppable winning
back-to-back games to face Nazi pakitzi
for the right to challenge the Women's
Champion Lavon aronian emerged from a
fierce playoff with Fabiano caruana and
will battle linear Dominguez in a rumble
for Redemption Champs will be chosen who
will reign supreme day six of incredible
chess coming up next
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everybody to day six of the
2023 American Cup held at the Saint
Louis chess club we started a day in the
Q boutique store if you are looking for
any chess themed merchandise well this
is the place to shop for it well we have
a fantastic event so far let's go to the
studio and start today's action with
yaser and Joe
we welcome you to Saint Louis Missouri
the capital of Chess in America this is
day six of the 2023 American cup from
the St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello
I come from the St Louis chess club
Studio I'm International Master Ivanka
houska and it's been a great pleasure to
be calling all the exciting action
alongside the one and only Grandmaster
iyasa sarawaka thank you Jovi my
goodness yesterday
wow her purpley aside it's no
exaggeration to say that was one of the
greatest matches I've ever called in my
life I of course refer to the Lavon
versus baby match it was amazing as our
defending Champion was unceremoniously
booted out of the tournament in
Armageddon it was fantastic a match for
the ages whoo I'm still in recovery uh
Jovi tell our audience where we stand in
the ladies bracket yeah definitely we
had an exciting day yesterday but in the
Champions bracket that was just a
Prelude to all the action that's
happening today it is number one Arena
crash against a 13 year old Alice Lee
who's number two today this match will
be decided and we'll find out who is
going to drop down to the elimination
bracket speaking of which what happened
in the elimination of which it was a
rather smooth passage for Nazi paikitsa
and begin talking to ran over both of
those are just absolutely kind of swept
past their opponents I have to say in
the rapid chest and in the open
Champions bracket in the Champions
bracket again we have what a lineup you
know how it's been such a great
tournament so far but it's Hikaru
Nakamura where's he so then these guys
know how to equalize and they played a
very safe draw but again they this match
will be decided today and in the
elimination bracket is where all the
excitement that I just referred to came
from yeah this is where the cool kids
hang out right
so that momentous clash between Fabiano
Carolina
was Victorious and he in turn will now
face off against Millennia Dominguez who
remember knocked him down into the
elimination bracket in the first round
absolutely and to remind our viewers our
format yes it is a two eight player
double elimination bracket tournament no
dwarf offers allowed
kind of separate its into two in the
Champions bracket it's a very sedate
very refined classical time control 90
minutes plus 30 second increment in the
elimination bracket is a bit more
Scrappy as we go into two rapid games 25
minutes plus 10 second increment and our
schedule for today yeah and we can see
we're going to have a lot of Chess
because today is the day where we're
going to see players from the
elimination leave the compensation and
we'll have players from a championship
bracket they play one game and then if
the match is tied then we're on to tie
breaks and playoffs maybe even
Armageddon and in the elimination well
everything to play for indeed and here
is our schedule for today and for
tomorrow but uh Christian is wonderful
to have you in studio the players who
are still in the event are
extraordinarily accomplished tell us
about them absolutely good to see you
guys great to be back for day six and
what a fantastic back and forth
highlight match of the day we had
yesterday between the defending Champion
Fabiano caruana and Levon aronian but to
my eyes the highlight of today's matches
is who's going to make it to the Grand
finals and we have four competitors
vying for those two spots in the Grand
Final and let's start with the latest
section we have a huge match between
Grandmaster Irina crush and Alice Lee
and as we can see the only Grandmaster
in the United States is in this
competition in the ladies section that
is Grandmaster I Rina Crush only female
Grandmaster in the United States
two-time U.S Champion when Alice Lee was
born in 1998 she won her first US Chess
Championship and she is an eighth time
U.S women's church that is just
unbelievable but she is facing an
incredible competitor and that is of
course The Prodigy that 13 years of age
born in 2009 feed a master Alice Lee she
became the U.S expert at a detender age
of eight U.S chess National Master at
age 10 and she is the three-time world
youth chess champion just an incredible
career highlight already at only 13
years of age and take a look at their
head to head I have to say Irina has
been dominant so far in their direct
matchup no wins for Alice Lee two losses
and four draws we've seen yesterday one
of those those draws and I have to say
Alice Lee really impressed me not
necessarily with her opening choice and
opening preparation station but with her
middle game understanding and this is
what I'm looking at for today's match
let's take a look at the Champions
bracket in the open section who are the
two competitors of course I'm talking
one of them is Grand Master Hikaru
Nakamura the rating favorite going into
this event she is 35 years young he
earned his Grandmaster title at the age
15 five-time U.S chess champion and he
is going into this competition the top
rated us player and he will be facing
one Wesley sword this guy is so
difficult to beat he almost feels like
he never loses In classical chess and
yesterday with the black pieces
neutralized quite easily Hikaru Nakamura
he is the 2019 Fisher random world
champion three-time U.S chess champion
two-time World Championship candidate
it's so difficult to make it to those
candidates and he is the current world
world global chess champion as well as
the 2021 Grand chest tour Champion what
an incredible career highlight this guy
has and take a look at their lifetime
head to head in classical matchup I have
to say I feel Wesley so has quite a
significant upper hand four wins one
loss and 20 draws in the rapid matchup
and perhaps we will be seeing some rapid
games today between these two Gladiators
13 wins 21 losses and 59 draws guys we
have some amazing chess coming your way
and we will be calling all the action
from St Louis yes we do we're incredibly
accomplished Players yesterday was
actually a very special day for us
Graham Colin Graham from the Make-A-Wish
Foundation is battling cancer he had
made a wish to come to St Louis
visit the chess club and meet all of his
chess Heroes including Hikaru Nakamura
the streamer who got him started and uh
yesterday we all came out for a dinner
together and uh honored Colin and his
family and on his right his best friend
Leo also came with also a chess player
Leo describes himself as a scrappy 1000.
he can throw the patties but uh for us
he honored us greatly with his lifetime
wish because we always associated with
football and basketball and baseball or
Hollywood stars never to meet the chess
nerds so this was great we were on
everybody came out it was really good it
was very humbling
and the players are playing really
really hard because they're playing for
a lot of money there is a lot at stake
well let us know break it down in the
open section first prize is a staggering
fifty thousand dollar second thirty five
thousand and third place 25
000 and take a look at all those kind of
other prizes as well as the champion
bracket bonus ten thousand nice and
break it down for the ladies and for the
women's section we have first prize of
000 second place eighteen thousand
dollars third ten thousand and once
again you do get a champion bracket
bonus five thousand dollars look at that
total price on a hundred thousand
dollars that's incredible very very
handsome thank you St Louis thank you
Rex and Genie thank you chess club as we
get ready for the start uh Colin is
going to be making the opening first
move the honorable ceremonial opening
first move that is he'll be doing it on
the Wesley so Hikaru Nakamura table yeah
what do we expect in that one guys do we
expect an aggressive Wesley maybe open
up with E4 G2 G4 okay
G4 G4 G4 come on come on get us started
if Hikaru plays the Kalashnikov again
because I guarantee Wesley did indeed
watch the broadcasting stuff
oh that's way too conventional oh come
on is that a good move
well G4
electrical that secures a quick draw no
not the E4 Berlin quick draws yes you
know I'm gonna kind of put my neck out
and say I believe that these two leave
all the fireworks for the play oh no
he's playing before yeah
yeah it is the same move
and by the way you saw the smile that
Colin was wearing after he walked away
he wore that all last night at the pizza
party he was so excited uh to be with
all of his chess Heroes C4 now we've
been seeing uh Wesley playing the
classical Knight C3 Queen C2 nimzo
Indians
um
he had an advantage against fubby he won
a pawn but somehow did didn't really
press is that what you would expect
today Christian yes I I don't believe
we're going to see a very similar line
to that one i2c3 Bishop to B4 Queen to
C2 these players have in fact played
that specific variation quite a few
times in their careers and usually it
ends up in a draw they both know their
uh Theory and their opening preparation
is just Immaculate so it's very very
difficult to create any separation
my prediction is that we're going to see
a draw and then we're going to move on
into the tie breaks into the playoff
scenario maybe we'll see another
highlight reel like I think we will I
think yesterday I think it's going to go
all the way to Armageddon yeah I mean I
really do think because these two guys I
mean they're so evenly matched they're
so well versed with each other's playing
Styles right and I mean Hikaru himself
has said you know basically when he's
playing Wesley he knows he shouldn't do
anything too special he just needs to
play chess
uh Arena and uh Alice are playing
classical chess just says Wesley and
Hikaru are playing classical chess but
as we talk uh two rapid games are going
on right now and they're going to
provide us the action so let's go to the
rapid games and let's start with uh
can we start with the ladies yes we can
vegan versus nice exactly because I mean
Knight F3 I mean it's just a good rewind
to the opening right we saw a Dutch
anyone who's ever followed my commentary
knows that I'm very scathing really okay
the Leningrad Dutch a city that no
longer exists I mean and we haven't
turned it to the Saint Petersburg Dutch
but the Leningrad Dutch the idea over
the conventional uh Dutch variation is
the bishop has
um the enchilad now this is actually a
favorite of Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru one
of the top players who have regularly
essayed the system but are you escaping
and you could do oh yeah Christian will
come to him in just a second
are you escaping as against the
Leningrad as you are against the regular
Dutch
you know my funny thing is
yeah the universe the universe promptly
and change your mind but uh I I've been
kind of I feel like it's very it's such
a such an aggressive opening and of
course you know it carries a lot of
risks I found the best best recipe for
dealing with these type of positions as
white is basically to prevent black from
growing E7 E5 okay and so here I would
like in a heartbeat D4 D4 exactly yeah
and just as you said uh Black's strategy
actually is to play the move E5 and the
move Queen E8 is the most popular move
in response as black tries to reinforce
then how are you going to start black
from getting oops excuse me not that way
yeah
it isn't
it is not how do you handle with uh
pushing the pool and warm Square Four so
you're basically saying if you try to
play the move E5 I'm willing to make an
amp a song yes in that particular case
okay well I mean uh he's back and he's
going to have to defend uh uh begum's uh
did they prepare for this oops
okay still uh he's getting still set up
with his situation I apologize
um uh Christian uh no I beg him did not
prepare for this I can tell you for sure
look I'll give you some insight
information because nothing else can
happen right now uh this information
cannot be used against her at least but
yes we didn't look at this one we did
look previously for uh different
opponents at this particular case and
I'm not 100 sure which one she's going
to choose D4 is one of the options but
it can also start with D3 because you
haven't started with D4 you started with
Knight F3 so you get this extra option
of keeping the pawn to D3 that would
mean that white is going to take a
completely different approach to the
position not the four nd5 but rather a
more timid approach or in the center and
on the king side wait for a Black's
advancement and play D3 and counter shot
on the queen side with the move B4 B5
try to take as much space on that side
as possible those are the two options
that white has will see which one she
chooses and she did choose the move D3
which I sort of expected yeah that's
keeping it in the channels of the
English and let's go to uh the uh tie
break that's going on between Lanier and
Lavon let's go to the very start and see
how they they got here well not
surprisingly linear sticking to his guns
with the Russian or Petrov defense
Bishop D3 again
an early twist just because white is not
getting
the pluses that he's hoping for against
the Petrov in the conventional mines
whoa interesting Pawn sacrifice two
Bishops
is it
really worth the pond though it's
actually been this is standard wow
standard yeah I mean it's been played I
can see Fabiano has the essay this out
against Jose Martinez okay and that
probably was a title Tuesday game yes um
but yes it has been played a few times
in Rapid chess not so much in classical
so definitely a weapon
specially designed for Rapid time
formats okay break it down for us
Christian first of all how does the
engine the engine is saying that the
position is still very very balanced in
fact zero zero zero zero really yes yes
the extra Pawn is completely outweighed
by the two Bishops the light score
Bishop in particular on the long
diagonal is so powerful and it doesn't
seem like you have a clear way to stop
it you're going to try to put a knight
on and this is what we're seeing from uh
Black Knight to D4 open up the long
diagonal this is the main source of
counter chances in the position of
compensation you're going to try to stop
the action of this bishop with the move
Knight to E4 but whenever you do that
I'm going to be able to start expanding
play the move F5 I'm going to use brute
force to open up that long diagonal
which does seem to give black enough
compensation at the same time white is
upon up white has a beautiful structure
no weaknesses so the onus is still on
black to prove the compensation for few
moves and if I manage to exchange a pair
of Rooks maybe these Knights go off the
board who knows as the closer I get to
the end game without any weaknesses any
structural weaknesses in my position the
better my chances are as white to make
use of my extra Pawn well that's exactly
what we're seeing that D4 CD4 now now
there's a weakness the pawn on C2 this
is what I'm looking at
924 by the way was a novelty which
looked very uh standard very natural
yeah very natural so all of these moves
Knight D4 Knight takes d4c Knight E4
looks very standard and after a move for
example like Queen D5 as you say you
know you want to
um
use this long diagonal now you're
threatening to move F7 F5 I'm probably
going to play F2 F3 and again it seems
like I have to yes yeah and now you can
as you say you know concentrate your
energy against the C2 Pawn by maybe
doubling up
C8 keeping this no Queen V5 just Rook C8
at once keeping it in his pocket yes
okay yeah I was gonna ask the question
you know since you guys have been like
fixated on the C2 pawn and saying
weakness weakness I mean is it possible
for white to kind of get rid of it for
instance
um okay what I'm trying to think of is
I'm trying to get a C4 book exactly yeah
but it's not it's not
it's not it is possible so it definitely
is yeah you can take it and after I can
just see I can read what yes is yeah
I am thinking about taking here and
taking on C3 yes but let's look at that
because it's not that clear right ah you
have a Saving Grace so you take I take
back with the pawn well you also
mentioned that five I mean I wanna I may
want to conserve the two Bishops for I
mean after all only the Knight
defends the pawn so if I get rid of the
Knight I can do I have the move Queen to
beat no you don't because of Bishop d54
it's some sort of a long line because
you take only four and then my Bishop
hangs but I do have D6
at the end
um I think everything just in fact
simplifies
and look at Lanier wearing that nice
shiny leather jacket here really it's
the new branding uh bikers uh Club but
he
uh he also showed us how superstition
s because because you know when when you
I think grilled him yeah and said hey
nice snazzy learn new jacket that jacket
he said oh yeah yeah you know I'm gonna
stick with it you're exactly brought him
luck yesterday uh okay we we got
actually no no uh C4 by
um
by Lavon after the move Rook C8 Lavon
voluntarily brought his Knight back and
I like this move because I think that a
nicer setup for white is to play A4 and
Knight C4 the Knight on e4 was always
vulnerable to an F7 F5 furthermore the
Knight on e4 actually
blocked or obscured the view of The Rook
so I like this move Knight D2 and I'm
beginning to warm up to why the engine
was kind of dismissive of the pawn as
long as that Rook on C8 does keep you
cramped
you know tied down to the pawn on C2
there's definitely a play and I wanted
to just quickly take a look at Arena
Crush versus Alice Lee number one seed
versus number two seed uh Bishop to G5
H6
players are pretty much getting their
their prep on the board see A3 A3 A3
that's a little bit surprising it is a
bit surprising I mean because I've
always played this type of position with
E3 exactly maybe put a rook on C1
exactly E3 Rook C1 I think E3 by far is
the most conventional C takes D5 some
adherence like that but A3 Bishop takes
C3 B take C3 castles E3 and we're up to
date Queen G6 uh I know is a move that
uh you like to play because you you stop
the easy development of the bishop and
uh just you remind white you know it's
not all fun and games and let me just
again go to this time again these two
players
um Alice and Wesley are playing
classical uh chess the elimination group
or playing Rap a chest and we do have
this queen C2
and nimzo castles E4
yeah D5 E5 sharp line Knight F3 and
boy this is where you know you you have
to really know your stuff yes I mean uh
the preparation here is really intense
um I'm most familiar with the move
c7c5 trying to break in the center as
quickly as possible we'll keep an eye on
what looks like to be a theoretical lead
difficult battle d2d3 with begum
um
I remember
I was like the 20 year old Prodigy not
the 19 year old Roger this one and The
Grandmaster Anatoly Lane complained that
I had gotten publicity as being a talent
and I played these positions as white
and I would play the move Rook B1 B4 and
B5 and oftentimes win a lot of games on
the long diagonal any in Anatoly Lane
cursed me with I don't understand why do
they call him a talent all he does is
play rugby one B for b-5 and he wins I
mean what's so talented about that
d2d3 is this the English line uh
something that begum really likes well
I'm not sure if she likes it but we did
look at it and we did train and we did
uh understand more or less what the
plans are for both sides
um black played the move H6 I think this
is the last move that we currently E5
the board and A3 yes keep going yeah A3
and there you go with the B4 Action Now
H6 is the last move that we have on the
board and it makes a lot of sense white
has a lot of space on the queen side
black will have to counteract on the
king side and this is exactly what she's
doing she Place H6 follow it with G5 get
the Knight that went all the way from a
B8 probably to G6 that's the final
square and at the right moment you're
going to have to break you're going to
have to go F4 or G4 and H5 H4 you will
have to find a way to break in uh of in
response to that white is going to try
to attack on the queen side then is B5
on the board yes is is that uh an
updated board right now and I believe it
might be yes H7 H6 B4 B5 on the board
expecting just as you prescribed
Christian G5 I mean she has to play G5
and in fact through different move
orders we've actually transposed back
into the database that's very very
common uh to do that and this is these
are the types of positions where I would
continue with my queen side expansion
with moves like C4 C5 I mean fat
surprise that she hasn't played G5 yet
um she just played H6 it only makes
sense to continue
with G5 the the
funnily enough there is an argument to
be made to play for the move F4 like you
do in Grand pre-attacks and sometimes
there's a Prelude to playing the move F5
F4 you don't
there are reasons why you may not want
to play the move G5 but more or less
with great certainty you do want to play
F4 as black so most likely since I know
that you're going to play F4 and I know
that most likely I I've also set up a
little Queen B3 we have yeah I was about
to say I also set up a little trick with
Queen B3 now exactly wait a minute yeah
what like we see she's played Bishop E6
Bishop to E6 okay that softens up the B7
Square so yeah guys move start looking
at ideas of Knight to D2 later on Bishop
T E6 is on the board not the move G5 I
had a question for you Jody so you got
this uh situation the last move Queen B3
is more or less a pretty obvious threat
that like my king was a good out of that
as quickly as possible and that was the
question H7 or h8
why because because you know we're
anticipating the future we want to be
going F4 yes and the bent last enroll is
simply do not put your King on an open
diagonal
okay but wouldn't you say the the the
diagonal in this case is open there's a
friend there's a friend okay so the
conventional rule that I learned from
the Soviets at the time uh the Russian
school if you will is you put your King
on the color
opposite to the queen
so in this case since the queen is on a
light Square you don't go King H7 you go
King h8 you intuited correctly but they
actually have that rule a middle gang
rule it's a middle game rule so you
should put your King on the same color
on the opposite color to the White Queen
the opposite color to the White Queen
that's right okay intriguing I I didn't
know this rule me either I mean I I was
like 19 years old when I learned it I
had to go to the Soviet Union to find it
out well we learned it right here you
never know what you're going to learn on
the chess shows if you pay attention but
none of this happened because we had
Bishop E6 and you fell Christian that
that was actually uh making B7 uh
definitely not a mistake not a mistake
that's another plan that black has at
her disposal to try to play for D5 and
strike in the center okay and I think
this is what she's aiming with this move
Bishop to E6 Knight to D2 makes a lot of
sense right
consequences always ask yourself what is
the consequence of my opponent's last
move Bishop to E6 soft thumbs up the B7
Square so why not attack it right and
Knight to D2 makes a lot of sense in the
future anyway because all this Avalanche
of Pawns coming your way that Knight is
going to get under the rest so Knight D2
makes a lot of sense still a very
balanced middle game position in this
okay this is what I was gonna ask you
because I'm I'm not sure that many
players at home would have been playing
like Bishop E6 I think most most people
I think would seven times out of ten
would probably go G5 and to my eyes you
can that attack is frightfully scary
because you can just see it you know the
queen is going to put herself on E8 and
come to H5 F4 and it feels like you're
there's one person enjoying the game
with a white piece this I've been
collaborated a number of times people
have checkmated my king on the king side
I've won a number of games on the queen
side as well but you're absolutely right
uh nine out of 10 dentists who get this
position do you recommend G5 Knight G6
and F4 and the fact that the bishop on
C8 is actually a pretty good business
because Knight D2 is almost always in
White's
scheme and opening up this bishop so
keeping the bishop on E6 really does
have a lot to be said for it so since
you you're an expert yes in this type of
position especially with the white
pieces what is the right plan after this
move C6 how are you going to continue
trying to break through black space okay
I you you have to do it in a particular
move order in this particular case if
you do play C6 I'm almost always
captured well let's look at the first
position that we have in the game okay
692 and CC exactly how they continued
now and yeah this is kind of helpful uh
if she had done it a move later C6 takes
takes takes in this case because the
Knight is still on F3 I do have this
move C5 as a way of of uh softening
things up in Black's Camp so by
including Bishop E6 Knight D2
C7 C6 now and we're cap we're up to date
with the players we get something like
captures captures I don't have the move
C5 as I did before because you could
just bypass me and I don't have Knight
takes E5 here in this particular
position I probably play something
conventional like Queen C2
waiting for a moment when you might play
C5 so that I could quickly try to like
D5 pardon me so I could quickly try to
jump to the C5 square at the moment I
think the positions rather balance I
don't she played Queen B3 so she didn't
take on C6 she played directly Queen to
B3 okay Queen B3 Fair
um the reason why it might be a little
bit no I guess it's okay
97 looking to play Knight C5 could
potentially it's on the board Bishop A3
which P3 Knight C5 how is
how is that change in the structure who
this one favors well the double Pawns
um again I'm I'm thinking I'm going to
drop back with my queen and just defend
upon him okay no just jump in A4 I
didn't like the looks of this oh
I didn't like them
yeah Green A5 might you know like chill
you out you know not so enthusiastic
anymore are we
um yeah but I kind of felt the queen
actually belonged on C2 rather than B3
Knight D7 looks like a pretty decent
move by Naji let me go back to the other
um game between Levon Lanier again they
are playing Rapids and
did we let me do a quick uh refresh yeah
we do have oh not that many moves after
Knight D2 rookie eight
Lanier is such a classical player bring
the pieces into the center
f3h6 Bishop G3 okay that move I find a
little bit surprising I thought it was
time to play A4
and prepare a roost or a nest an outpost
on C4 Bishop to G3
that move looks strange to my eyes
the reason I say it looks a little
strange is Bishop G5 Bishop E3
so you can uh still continue with your
plan
can I Knight C4 yeah Knight C4 and then
munch
lunch
I guess B5 I do have Knight D6 right
yeah
but they're still there's still
something to
no because the bishop in B7 is hanging
so yeah yeah we're looking at Bishop
Shack and Rook takes C2 uh kind of
things I guess so okay uh Bishop G5 can
and should be bent by Knight C4
beginning to feel like
black is more than okay though because
those Bishops and again I'm my extra
Pawn on C2 I'm with you uh Jovi if the
extra Pawn was on C4 I'd be more
inclined to favor white and I'm also
wondering but then he's just Bishop G3
because I I mean it was okay I thought
the bishop was okay on F4 I think it
might be going
even yeah
well on a good day yeah
chess is an easy game right I mean take
the pawn bishop G3 okay we'll keep an
eye on this one one thing that concerns
me about this position is 10 years time
expenditure right now 13 minutes he's on
only 13 minutes and it seems like Levon
is speeding up the process 18 minutes on
his clock so he's building up a very
nice differential
um I understand Bishop G3 it makes some
sense because you don't want to attack
and Target that pawn on D4 right it
seems a bit lonely it doesn't have a
body next to him defending it on C5 from
C5 or from E5 so Bishop F2 makes a lot
of sense it's also close to the king
defends the king quite nicely okay and
what was the weakness that he just
created when you played the move F3 the
square E3 from F2 I will be able to both
defend my king and defend that square E3
as well as attack the pawn on for so
it's
it's a slow game so far and I think this
is where Levon seems to be excelling I
have to say in this competition I once
had a game versus Anatoly karpov where I
literally didn't know what to do and I
purposely made a weakness
so that I could defend them I played the
move F3 making the week the making the
square E3 work week so I now had a plan
of Defending my week Square genius it
was great to face it defensive yes
seizing the defensive so F3 makes a
weakness which you now can defend from
the F2 yeah clever but you know what the
rule that I have like although there are
more rules more rules that I have you
know when you're struggling for a plan
first of all
just improve the worst place piece
correct and then secondly you know if
the position is wild and the center is
relatively stable
fish H4 H4 expansion
well well that's first of all I like the
first rule uh look to improve your worst
place peace and that was where the
conventional move for me would have been
the move A4 in my mind my worst place
piece is the night on D2 I would love to
place it on C4 without facing the
consequence of the immediate boot get
out of here B5 so A4 put the Knight on
C4 then look to play H4 yeah
interactive but yeah improve your worst
place piece so guys I want to ask you
yes a question now we see Levon and
maybe we can uh check the bird's eye
view as well we see Levon walking around
in a rapid game with only 18 minutes on
his clock he's letting his opponent stew
in his uh thought what do you guys
usually do whenever your opponent is
getting lower on the clock down to his
or her's last five ten minutes and
you're in a rapid game in general my
coach is what they told me is to sit at
the board and try to calculate on your
opponent's time what do you guys usually
prefer I'm with your coach 100 and I
can't recall literally in my rapid games
and or Blitz Games ever getting up from
me neither I mean I mean I'm like
there's not enough time to walk around
and I always fear that if I do walk
around I'm gonna bump into something
interesting like what happens if I I'm
walking around in one of the most
spectacular games ever played is
suddenly in front of you you're going to
stop and you're going to start
calculating right yeah I don't want to
be distracted by any I see I see where
you're coming from right but I'm I'm
actually team Lavon on this one get up
and get up yeah walk around and the
reason why I do this I mean I'm just I
think levonne is entitled to do this
because of his clock time 18 minutes so
like the kind of adrenaline hasn't
settled in right also there's a lot of
nervous energy sure and I I often find
that if I'm stewing at the board
thinking about what my parent is going
to do I get so into the thing that I
kind of missed the whole wood for the
trees I mean I I miss so many things and
I'm actually I actually should just take
a breather just walk and therefore
release the energy release the emotions
and just kind of talk to myself a little
bit and then I can come in and see it
afresh wow
oh he's not all he needs to get back
down there yes yeah well there he get he
returned uh but I like the other or what
what Christians coach said
ex really do your best to calculate
Fantastical variations fantasy variation
calculate calculate calculate because
after all it is your opponent uh
thinking so in this position uh what I
would be trying to do wow uh linear is
thinking is to try get the gases move
what would I do if he played Bishop B4
what would I do if he played Bishop f8
oh pardon me is I think it's Bishop G3
yes yeah what would I do if you played
Bishop B4 what would I do if you played
Bishop f8 if he played B5 would I be
ready to play A4 AO Tempo so I'm I'm
starting to guess all the moves and my
immediate counter what would I do if you
played Queen D5 and sometimes
it turns out that I guess not just
correctly once twice Thrice but
a lot so my opponent plays this move
Queen D5 I instantly respond with a move
that I'm ready for and it kind of shakes
up my opponent a little right so like
like for example let's say in this
position just a moment I say my
opponent's going to make and I always
think of my parent playing a really
stupid move
like I I'm playing an idiot
so my opponent's gonna play a stupid
move
so what's a stupid move I go Queen D5
what why is that a stupid move because I
got this Rook on E1 that's doing nothing
yeah and you're making you're allowing
me to go with the tempo so I go rookie
five right like yeah you know and like
what's another stupid move and I go okay
well let's say he goes Queen C6 and I'd
be ready for another really great
response right and that
gave me confidence interesting I I I I I
built myself up like
he did play a stupid movie oh my God he
played another yeah no this is this is
very interesting because
um I was reading a book yep uh it was
actually a good start a good start it's
a great story also a great story it's
actually a book written by uh Philip
Hurtado and uh Michael Adams and there
they start talking about the word that
the grand Masters in the the series of
tests is a test book and uh how they
approach the test puzzles and actually
so say for instance Queen D5 rookie five
that was the first instinct what they
are looking for is they're looking why
is rookie five a bad mood okay and they
immediately go into this kind of like
negative thing what could be what could
be wrong with this move and they look at
ways to refute it if there's no
refutation then they're like
hey let's play the move right let's do
it so they're looking for the well bad
side the dark side yeah the dark side
yeah exactly and if you can't as you
can't do it find the dark the reason and
your move fits in with a kind of
positive framework of it improving the
pieces or having a plan or something
then they're like okay I will play it
let's go for it yeah uh is this move
Queen D5 by linear Christian good or bad
yeah yeah it's a perfectly playable
movie is it and and it does not
encourage the move rookie five I I don't
think it was but right now I'm looking
at that please
come on here things are really exploding
okay well let's do it take a look at
what happened in this one so we've seen
Knight wave four keeping these two pawns
on the board the B5 and the B7 uh pawns
on the board what's the reason for that
you remember Queen to A5 was a big
problem right the problem with Queen to
A5 attacking both Knights right now is
that at this point on B5 is still here
and that cancels your defense of the
Pawn on 75 Knight takes C5 would just be
winning for white you can take on D2 I
take only six and that's going to give
me a winning position so you cannot
defend the pawn on C5 with the move
Queen to A5 should play the move Queen
to D6 take a look at this rook fd1 and
now we have the move Rook to A5 wow a
very enterprising move by Nazi by kids
and after B takes C6 this is the idea
behind it you don't recapture back on C6
you go B5 take a look at this Edge you
cannot take with the queen because
obviously the queen uh well actually you
can take with a queen and that's the
best move in the position sacrificing
the queen excuse me for that you can
take with the pawn but that's going to
lose the queen but you can take with the
queen sacrifice it and create these two
passers whoa this is wild if she goes
for this queen sacrifice for only a rook
well that's not a lot but I do have this
powerful Pawn and b60 is coming B7 is
coming big big moment right after this
move B5 you don't want to go backwards
why not because of B4 you don't have
Knight to B5 because your Rook takes B5
and that's a big big problem in the
position where do you put the Knight if
you go to E2 then I have Rook A3 coming
uh the pawn on D3 will be hanging I
don't have any weaknesses anymore in the
position as black we remember the pawn
on B7 was a bit of a backwards Pawn in
the position and that was the weakness
no more with the opponent B4 supporting
the Avalanche of black species on the
queen side so critical moment Queen
takes B5 is a very enterprising move
that could pretty much set the board on
fire I was gonna say would you do it
would you do it the first move I would
be calculating is actually the Lord the
natural alternative Knight C3 and if I
saw that after B4 Knight D5 is not
necessarily working and I'm like oh oh
you have to go for it you have to go for
it then and that means yeah you're
thinking that 95 Knight takes C6
so I would say like okay rewind rewind
this doesn't work so therefore let's I
I'm not sure it's necessarily a dead end
I mean for example Rook A1 Rook A8 Rook
takes she retreated Rook takes and I'm
gonna go Queen C2 and Knight B3 I don't
necessarily think it's a dead end for
white but on the other hand
yeah my question is is do I really think
the compensation is great now I do have
a pawn and a rook but I have two awesome
looking
passers and I do have Knight C4 so I
would definitely be calculating
something here and then eventually I
realized I can't calculate this to a
finish I can only go on my intuition and
my intuition says
I think it's playable the way that I
once had a very similar situation where
I had to give up the queen for some
minor pieces and the way that I found it
really handy to judge that kind of
position was to look at the harmony of
your pieces true and you know if they
are all working really well so for
instance here yeah they the white pieces
are in great Harmony yes this bishop
this Rook you one of them together yeah
these pawns
um having said all of this what was the
engine's valuation Christian zero zero
yeah
[Laughter]
this was the critical move I think yes
and I'm sure she would have Nazi that is
she would have spotted it after Queen B5
Rook B5 C takes B5 you do want to play
with the white pieces night to see for
it right let's make a bad move okay ba
Knight to C4 Bishop takes E4 D takes C4
if you get this complex of Pawns and The
Invasion coming on the D file with the
Rook coming to D7 this is just pretty
much game over I'm going to go C7 B6 B7
I'm going to get a queen beautiful but
the problem is you can stop that as
black with the move Rook fd8 now Knight
C4 I will take take and after Queen
takes D1 it is black who is winning this
position so
after Rook to d8 you have to make this
type of timid moves Rook B to C1 to stay
in the game it's not looking as easy
especially from afar especially with
little time on the clock which is
happening right now for beg him so she
decided to take
I wouldn't call it necessarily practical
but with so little time on the clock and
not being able to assess the position
clearly she decided to go for this
Knight to B2 which allows B4 Rook to A1
Rook F A8 and there's going to be an
invasion on the a file Rook 2 A3 is
coming this Pawn on D3 is going uh to be
a weakness you have to get ready for
that and how do you get ready for that
probably take take and then Queen drops
back to C to get this Knight to B3 and
try to just like stay there like this
it's not an easy position for white I
have to say black Nazi by kids right now
has a golden opportunity to potentially
strike early on and get the early lead
in this matchup but I couldn't agree
with you more but I'm looking at that
night on B2 and I'm saying oh my gosh it
is not an All-Star and yet a moment ago
we were looking at the positions after
Knight C3
be for Knight to D5 in this case I would
say yes you've got a protected past Pawn
yes I like your position but at least
the Knight on D5 is lording in the
middle of the board as opposed to
shivering and quaking quaking on the B2
Square which is the current position and
I'm just stunned that begum would have
played uh the Knight to B2 and not
having the Knight on the centralized D5
Square absolutely yes and and not a good
a very nice assessment of what's
happening right now the night on D5
would have given white a lot more
compensation strategical compensation
because of such a strong presence in the
center oops night on B2 not looking good
and Naji is definitely enjoying her
position can I quickly please ask you
before things get really wild in the
rapid games I would like to kind of
visit Wesley so against Hikaru Nakamura
let's do it yes Hikaru seems to have
come to the game
guns blazing okay and I mean it is still
very much in the Realms of theory but I
mean when I take a look at the clock
times okay I see that Hikaru is like C5
okay so all of this is like really the
standard stuff and it's amazing how
pardon me uh how well uh theory is
developed over time from G5 all of this
has been played many times before
I won't go deeply into the
but uh
which moment we well we I just wanted to
kind of evaluate this opening choice I
mean are they because again you know it
looks very wild it does but I mean these
days you've got to be always careful
though has been worked out as you
mentioned right so the most popular move
and and this position has been reached
let's say uh two dozen times Queen D1
and the games that I see have all ended
in a draw like Queen takes D1 Rook takes
D1 I'm seeing some names Anish giri
Fabiana karijuana played Fabi played
this position with black and they
achieved a draw in all the games
thus far
Christian of all did white win anything
yeah
one game between
schmeliov and uh
yeah I don't even know okay excuse me
you know you're in trouble when when
Christian says I don't know how to
pronounce it everything at the elite
level has finished in a draw uh Queen to
D1 take on D1 take only one Bishop takes
C3 Bishop to F5 everything gets swiped
off the board and we're going to end
into some sort of one equal but my
question is yeah yeah I'm not disputing
what's happening on the board but I mean
take a look at the clock times and
you'll see that Wesley is just over one
hour Hikaru playing at Tempo but for
Wesley this seems to be a pattern right
uh he likes to take his time and
whenever he comes back and gives us the
interview he's like yeah I knew this
line I was just trying to figure out
exactly which specific line or a sub
line of this variation I want to employ
because I I know a lot of them right and
I know they're all leading to a very
complex and balanced positions and
perhaps this is what he's doing right
now Queen to D1 has been played pretty
much exclusively in the position I don't
think he's going to deviate okay so I'm
sorry I apologize
let's uh let's can we race over to
Livonia she Ronin against lenia
Dominguez because lenya you know he's on
his last five and a half minutes and he
says hey this is a position that needs
immediate action and just take a look at
what he's done I mean he's a man after
my own heart yeah when I see these guys
on the board I think you you had
mentioned H4 uh improve your worst piece
I think I'm trying to quote you improve
your worst weight by the way I'm not a
big fan of the move rookie too how to
again I I'm looking at A4 I'm looking at
Rook E5 rookie
rookie two what rookie two rookie two
Bishop f8 change change Knight B3 okay
he is saying you got a tender
uh Pawn G5 intending Bishop G7 yeah very
good h3h
I'm looking at this and I'm thinking
this is dangerous action action uh not
not hanging about just going straight
for the G4 and Blasting open the
diagonal
excuse me isn't that kind of like
lifting the kimono there and exposing
your own King uh I will defend G2 I'm
inviting you to that's why he played oh
sorry yes it's on the board and now okay
before let's keep going and now it's G4
I mean I don't have this idea of if you
do open up the wrong diagonal I have
Bishop H6 at the end isn't that
dangerous I I I don't doubt it for a
moment I wasn't uh intending uh shall I
say about like that to open the diagonal
I just wanted to bring my Rook which by
the way is is not even developed I mean
shame on me right that The Rook isn't in
and now is in the game but to your point
uh Christian if I did you can get a
little bit uh greedy I would be walking
into a real smack
because there is a mate on G2 so that's
why I can't open up that long diagonal
and I'll play Rook F1 for the time being
whose King is more exposed
yours or mine
that's the that's the question yes that
is the question and what if I can take
and if you've just joined us shame on
you same one here this is where we stand
but please welcome and anyhow this is
where we stand on the Champions bracket
and the women's section it is Arena
crash against Alice Lee and they are
playing their second classical game the
match will be decided today we will find
a winner we will find out who is going
to be demoted to the elimination reckon
and when it comes to the women's
elimination bracket and we see it's a
huge matchup between Naji paikitsa and
Megan tokin Genova and both of these
women are fighting for their lives
whoever loses will be sent home
eliminated and in the Open Championship
bracket and in the Open Championship
brackets look looky there look who's at
the top Hikaru Nakamura and he's facing
off against Wesley so yesterday game
ended in a draw so again everything will
be decided today it might take playoffs
it might take Armageddon it doesn't
matter there will be a winner declared
and uh
[Laughter]
is facing off against Dominguez and
living Orion of course was the victor of
yesterday's epic match against Fabiana
and whoever loses this match in the
elimination bracket will be eliminated
from the competition yeah I'm sorry
sorry no no no I loved it trying to be
an oracle
uh as we pick up the action we did see
this move H5 and I was uh help me out
here do we have Queen D2 on the board
oh they're following our analysis G4 HGH
I wanted to say that I had set up this
nasty little trap and uh kind of hoping
that Lanier would go takes
takes Rook takes F3 Rook to E3 at first
blush this looks like a really nice way
of of of blasting open this diagonal
since I can't take on on E3 twice but I
can take on D4
undermining The Rook so that a nice
little puzzle Rush tactic there of
capturing the pawn so Rook E3 is not a
good move so why did you go Queen H5
Queen H5 try to support that Bishop page
six and also Kick The Rook away from the
long diagonal okay I like it it makes uh
makes a little sense it certainly does
you kick my Rook away from the long
diagonal okay I agree six and now you
want to play Bishop h
Drop The Rook with the check first yes I
am hoping for Queen B8 check I want to
warn you yeah yeah oh he played Rook we
we got the position but instead of my
Rook to F1
um Lanier has actually played
no I did play Rook F2 how about that
guys one second uh there is a big
blunder in the game between Tokyo Nova
and Naji paikidze take a look at that
let's switch over to
did you say blunderville yes and she
played it
oh oh she played D takes C5 creating
those triple pawns after the move Rook
283 very enterprising move by black Rook
to A3 targeting the queen on B3
she took on C5 thought for a long time
but after Queen takes D2 this is over
here
sacrifice and and immediately Nazi saw
that spotted the tactic there's no
coming back from this because you're
forced take back on D2 I take back on B3
and it's that pawn on C6 is not going
anywhere it is tragic that they're
triple pawns if this Pawn were anywhere
to the side they would be dangerous
maybe you'll have some compensation but
the triple pawns nope no this is this is
it and and Nazi is taking a very very
clear lead into this one a victory with
the black pieces is so hard to get we've
seen the length that Levon went to
didn't want against uh Fabiano yesterday
when he was with his back against the
wall but this one is not looking good
I'm going into hyper
Desperado Desperado yeah yeah hyper
hyper you have to but
and we're seeing uh what we think will
be a repetition in the draw in our
classical game Champions bracket between
Wesley and
um Hikaru and we're going to and should
this be a draw yeah what what happens
then well there will go on to playoffs
and this will take place at 5 30 P.M
and the playoffs will then be played at
the rapid chest yeah tempo of 25 minutes
and so on no 10 minutes 10 minutes 10
minutes plus
five seconds we've generally started at
five
um yeah yes yes
there's a half hour delay
on the broadcast
to the viewer at home it will begin at 5
30. for us here in St Louis and we'll
begin half hour earlier at 5 p.m all
right well uh again let's just go to the
Lavon game because as we see on our
bird's eye view one two three one two
three three versus three white slightly
slightly better thanks to this Knight on
F5 but uh
Hikaru certainly has that uh
uh how do you say
facial expression of like this is boring
can we go home now
what's happening in uh in the oops
excuse me in the game between
um
Lanier and uh Lavon uh linear is running
out of time right now Rook F2 Bishop H6
Bishop F4 Bishop G7 and after the move
Bishop G7 now Lavon said okay
the dream position I'm looking at a
hikaru's position the dream Square for
my knight is the F5 Square let me bring
my knight to that F5 Square which is
exactly what he's done he's made a b
line towards that square
um
okay an extra Pawn but is it meaningful
oh it definitely is I mean right now I
have a nice defense on G2 I don't think
you want to take that
you can create my own chances why don't
I go Queen two
I like it you're kind of bludgeoning the
back rank there as eyeballing F7 as well
Jovi yeah
there's a pull-up for grabs on A2 would
be the first thing that I look at oh wow
because yes you know that Queen does
defend the F7 Pawn okay is there
anything
devastating coming Black's way that's
the problem there might be but it might
be just ghosts uh in the closet nothing
rattling okay so check shall we yep the
King by the way uh let me just interrupt
myself and say Lavon believes you he
didn't want to lose the A2 Pawn he
played the move B3
and says whatever I can do queen E2
Queen EA check I can do in the future
let me just keep the pawn on tap what's
the clock times
is under well linear is under a minute
and uh levonne avonian seems to have all
the time in the world as he's under
seven minutes
it has in his match yesterday with Fabi
Levon has uh consistently had more clock
time and it's worked magic uh in his
magically in his favor Bishop F6 makes a
very very clear uh idea I want to play
Bishop H4 pinning the Knight to The Rook
what's going on in this position uh
Christian Jump Right In and tell us what
the in our engine evaluates uh this
sharp moment this one yeah so Quinto Ito
seems to have been the best move B3
Bishop to F6 now once again Queen to E2
seems to be the right move okay the
question is how do you respond to Bishop
to H4 right because this is the clear
signal that linear is sending with the
move Bishop to F6 I want to get to H6 I
want to open up the G file and put
pressure on E2 now you would give a
check right King H7 and now Queen to f8
but this is a very very difficult called
move to C you're just giving up the the
Knight on G3 but the pawn on F7 is going
to be problematic for black so you
cannot take on G3 Rook takes F7 finishes
the game right this is not easy this
whole idea of Queen to E2 Queen 28 Queen
to f8 and just try to Target the king
from behind this is not especially human
uh from a human's perspective it's not
an easy thing to cease and I have to say
I look at the engine plus 1.3 but from a
practical perspective it just feels like
black species are slowly slowly coming
into play and if you don't find the
exact configuration for white then you
might end up in trouble yeah I was going
to ask how narrow is the path to the
advantage so Queen to E2 seems to be the
only move to maintain a pretty
significant lead Bishop to H4 and still
Queen to E8 and queen to f8 to maintain
that lead we can also go Rook to F3 but
after Rook to F3 I have Rook to G8
not that easy I I don't see this one as
being easy to find for Levon but uh to
my eyes uh Bishop to E5 instead of Rook
F3 they're uh also looked tempting
because I'm eyeballing E5 you're already
worse after the move f56 because I
wanted to go queen h8 and I wanted to go
to Rook F7 but the move F6 stalled me
and that was why I understood Queen F A
you cannot take back on F6 because FG I
made it on G2 so yeah quite problematic
let's see what they're going to do let's
see what Levon is going to choose but
once again we see Levon with a
significant lead on the clock we've seen
that in his match uh at least in the
first few games against Fabian caruana
as well uh the point I just again I just
make was that after Queen e h Queen E2
Bishop H4 Queen EA check King H7 like if
you just gave me this position and said
okay it's a puzzle Rush yes or go ahead
and kill it uh the first move I would
look at is the move Bishop E5 because
I'm thinking ooh Rook takes F7 queen
Queen H
well he played Bishop a C6 not
page four which gives me an extra Tempo
so Queenie said Queenie to Bishop to C6
to prevent the queen from coming in
which means uh I I was attracted Queen
E8 I was going to point out why queen f8
queen E8 and queen f8 was the Right
Moves Queen H5 on the board and a trade
and again uh Lanier's clock time again
sorry well he is desperate times now
because he's 40 seconds over 40 seconds
that's not too much versus a six minutes
or five minutes it's burnt down to four
and a half minutes H4 uh tickling The
Rook
G3 kind of leaving the Knight a little
bit
sidetracked yeah sidelined
okay but the problem from White's point
of view is the desirable rookie too
might allow Bishop to F3 which is why
Lavon shows G3 and again that clock is
ticking fast 20 seconds
it's a it's a five second bonus right
and this one is a 10 seconds 10 seconds
you can actually feel very nice green
right
somebody's on this on the show look look
at those Graphics guys hey a big shout
out to our graphic uh artist there for
making uh 25 plus 10.
very nice thank you will uh G3 Bishop
went back to E7 take it away Jovi who's
doing well
he's doing well I think white is doing
well this is Bishop E5 The Right Move
Bishop I mean I I would be more tempted
to
Knight F6 check he did play rookie two
by the way yeah that's on the board King
f8 and now Bishop F3 maybe a threat I
mean white kind of obviously bail out
with Rook H2 so it's not going to be I
could I would I would try to stop that
threat with King F2 myself but because I
would I take those things seriously
don't want to Bishop on my doorstep well
that's very practical because you don't
have that much time I mean why go into
that whole you know bog of complications
when you don't need to play practical
simple chess okay F2 King F2 I like it
uh
um pardon me Lavon burning clock at this
moment in the ladies uh elimination game
we left it uh Naji had won a piece oh
nazri is just about to win that okay
okay she's she she's well on her way
there's
pushed upon
yes there's no Escape okay so we expect
uh that to to go in naji's favor uh King
f8 rookie two we're expecting King F2 in
the game of uh Lavon and Lanier
I know we have a bird's eye view of
Vegas game because
at the moment
black is just ready to promote her Pawn
isn't she Paul she's she's a piece up
and she doesn't have any worries in the
world because that c Pawn is not going
anywhere true
by the way can you
just want to make sure the seat Pawn
isn't going anywhere uh the move Bishop
uh C7 really isn't it
indication of that she was trying to get
to E5 on the long diagonal defend the
pawn on B2 and after that move the Rook
can she not start with Rook takes D1
yes Rook takes D1 Knight takes D5
oh she can definitely do that yeah yeah
she can I was also looking at Knight
takes C6
Knight takes C6 I love that too just to
clarify everything but it isn't there
knee oh this is nice no need for all the
complications all the nice things when
this is just going to put the boot in
yeah that was so crafty right you play
Bishop C7 you force white to open up the
second Rank and now with this extra
option of Rook to C to after Knight
takes B2 you just simply go over to C1
that's very elegant it truly is yeah
yeah
and uh 14 seconds for beg him but the
clock is the least of her worries yeah
Queen lose Knight takes B2 Rook to C2
check and pick up a second piece and
there goes a second piece we're most
likely going to see a resignation
coming very soon by the way I think it
was Ray Robson who was playing on like
Five Pawns yeah rook in a night down
right right right
are you with us right it's a good
inspiration from that night he loves to
play chess what was that night called
there in the Monty Python oh yeah the
the Black Knight Black Knight
come back I'll bite you you've been
laboring so much to get those sea pawns
somewhere close I know I know and
they're not even close to your emotions
two pieces down but they're not going
anywhere still right oh Bishop D6 I
think the portal C6 next move I'm afraid
even G5
yeah completely helpless they end up
checkmating the white king very very
shortly as well yeah
yes
we will return to the game of linear
when we left it we left it here and let
me just refresh the board to get the
current position I was saying King F2
Levon went after a pawn
he's he spied a pawn and he went Rook H2
Bishop F3 Bishop E5 this is what he was
looking at and he slurped upon
oh
can't blame him for that can we no
definitely Cottons although the pieces
are a little uncoordinated at the moment
I must say Knight F4
okay I didn't mind and follow that by
King F2 well the problem is we're going
to end up okay there is an Intermezzo
check oh
that's exactly what I was thinking about
has won that and their congratulations
to nazia she draws first blood with the
black pieces putting her in a pole
position to get to the Grand Final
um
and not yet the Grand Final the finals
of the elimination bracket the final
yeah I said that wrong
yes thank you uh the finals of the
elimination bracket yes but boy I was
close right yeah I mean really in the
ballpark somewhere yeah no no you're
right it's it's it's the next
neighborhood stage before okay but
anything rookie six and I think they did
follow Knight F4 and there was that
Intermezzo and Rook C2 Bishops of
opposite color
I mean I gotta say Lanier's got
practical chances of of saving this is
that
I think so too yes yes and the king is
so active right yeah I mean sure if
White's King was active on G5 or
something I think he'd be winning but
with the King on the first rank Jovi 67
F6 okay
actually when it comes to these kind of
rook and Bishop
opposite color Bishops positions I mean
one thing that you have to do is
actually try to restrain The Defenders
activity even even if they give up some
material and get the pieces motoring
it's actually very difficult to hold
against you know because they have full
control over their own color complex
exactly and the fact that the white king
is kind of stuck on the first rank
um
the suggests to me that the chances of
holding are really high A4 I like this
move a lot A5 and Bishop takes A7 on
White's agenda in the meanwhile black
Lanier is saying well King takes King
here and that's a nice hakasito though
exactly I'll uh I'll remind you that
Checkmate ends the game
yeah Bishop F2 and already an indication
that okay the activity that black is
getting is a lot
uh okay King takes I would also be
tempted to actually triangulate the king
yeah
King G4 sorry King G4 and then okay he's
gone for Rook to D2 okay we're trying to
remind you that there might I might be
able to get you this way with Rook D1 no
I I'm underneath yeah I'm already
feeling like uh this is not this is not
a lot of fun for white white is a kind
of on the back foot King F1 can you take
the pawn on F4 right now whoa and Bishop
C2 says to me like Lanier's got no no
fears at all he's thinking
I'm just going to take that these pawns
off the board and I'll make a very very
comfortable draw King E1 really take C2
what is this Rook takes A7 well he one
thing he cannot go into is a rook
and okay
so you're saying avoid Rook E2 check
King takes Rook takes don't go there
instead well you have to move the bishop
24 played and by the way that King takes
rook and well grab as many pawns as you
can these Bishops of opposite color
endings are pretty simple grab all the
material you can and hope that it's
enough to win King takes f4 on the board
he's stopping the check on the nasty
threat of rookie two is stopped and by
the way the a pawn is ready
um
I'm feeling better about Love's chances
levon's chances suddenly because
I'm not sure I like that move Bishop D1
the C2 Pawn wasn't so key it wasn't so
critical in my view this one
does that invite Rook check
that's okay I think I'm going to go back
to F5 why not go forward you want to go
forward okay yeah and then then you can
threaten something
yeah I know that makes a lot of
difference very active right well yeah
that's the test he's being tested back
you know you're getting in the way okay
the team goes to F3 sorry yeah so lenya
has um he's getting an extra 10 seconds
per move but he was just now on nine
seconds now he's on 19. okay that's
scary okay
so
A5 Rook takes B3 King D2 is more or less
where I would be going thinking my a
Pawn's the most dangerous
I don't know if it's enough uh to win
but the thing is though there is an F
Pawn on the air and he's actually
defended his Pawn I would quick as a
whip it I would just go F5 F5 wow quick
as a week a whip it a whip it easy for
you go for it F5 and how about
it should be a draw yes
back on the long diagonal defend against
King D1 kind of crawling towards the
king to drive pardon me crawling towards
the Rook to drive it off the a file
makes left four now F4 then more
crawling
but therefore we already always have to
be careful about this person is actually
lights are pretty stunted yeah no no the
F Pawn is very well controlled by the
bishop looking at f2 and I want and here
we go Bishop to D3 I was about to say
want to drive that Rook away from the a
file but this move was really a good
move what about Bishop C7 King E3
his best to keep all of his pawns he
wants to play King here and he wants to
play a six
five seconds foreign
trouble uh makes a fool of all of us it
truly does and this move
I think Lanier was pretty darn close to
a draw until King E2 was played that was
the blunder uh we already have our
results of the elimination we do we have
to two decisions once again uh
nobody likes to draw in these Rapids do
they oh my God some people are in a
must-win situation so we have big game
talk in Genova and she's playing gonna
be playing with the black pieces needs
to win against Naji Pai kipsa in the
elimination bracket otherwise she's
eliminated right and then we have Lavon
aronian who just won just one so it's
lenia Dominguez playing with the white
pieces in a must win do we expect we
expect those uh uh rapid games to begin
at 3 30 and we do have the uh
uh pardon me the classical game still
going on let's join them as we say that
uh honestly white today against Serena
Crush they drew their first game from
yesterday when we left it we're still in
the opening right about here uh Castle's
E3 Queen G6 was the move uh that has
played most often D take D5 take C4 was
Marina's choice
and the players have reached
well
this position
feels pretty balanced to my eyes
it does feel it does feel very balanced
but it's real strategical game I feel
and just uh we're going to take a quick
Gander also before we take our first
break uh of the game between
um Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley said thank
you so much with the white pieces now
this one we've kind of had thought well
it was just gonna be racing to the half
points but they're still there they're
still at play and they haven't found
their three move repetition yet well I
still like white I mean white I mean
he's got the better side of it I mean
there's check on tap and King H4 well
something to play for but indeed let's
talk about our friends at Q Boutique
definitely and uh so if you want to
celebrate the 2023 American cup with a
super soft limited edition t-shirt
featuring the St Louis chess club logo
on chess and the American Club sorry
American Cup 2023 on the back and it's
available now exclusively at Q Boutique
stl.com
MSA they are very very comfortable
shirts I I got one in a swag package and
it is it's very it's very nice very soft
material is good exactly and uh well
we'll leave you on that note and see you
after the break
[Music]
it's 2023 and the grand chest tour is
back for its ninth trip around the world
inspired by former world champion Gary
Kasparov the grandchester hosts the top
players to compete for top prizes eight
of the world's best joint tournament
wild cards and travel to four different
countries to fight for a 1.4 million
dollar prize fund the tour kicks off in
Bucharest Romania for the super fat
chess classic then things speed up as we
move to Warsaw Poland and Zagreb Croatia
where the first two rapid and Blitz
events the tour then makes its way to St
Louis Missouri for the final two events
we're back in November for the St Louis
rapid and Blitz and the illustrious
sinkfield cup when points are up for
grabs the best players show up who will
be crowned the new Champion find out
when the grand chess tour returns
meet me at the beauty the beauty in
Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedies romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomes chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2 000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
and we are back and we've already seen
two decisive games in the lane in
Elimination Brackets easy for you to say
and starting off with the Champions
bracket we can see that Arena crash is
playing the second classical game
against a 13 year old Alice Lee and
they're still at it yep definitely it's
still at it but there will be a match
winner today and when it comes to the
elimination bracket well we saw that
Nazi packetsu with the black pieces took
an early lead against Bigham took him
Genova and it is begum who is now in a
must win situation with the black pieces
it's not an easy feat at all and that'll
happen about a half an hour from now and
in the opens Champions brackets and in
those brackets
we see you know headlining the event we
have Hikaru Nakamura and he is facing
off against Wesley so they are still
deep in thought against each other and
one thing I have to say is that whoever
wins that will actually awaits will be
into the Grand Final yep and the Elimina
the loser goes down into the elimination
bracket and when it comes to Elimination
Brackets well we also had his massive
game there as aronia and founded of
Dominguez attack and emerged clear
winner and uh
second game will also be starting in
around about
and by the way we invite you to join the
conversation and you can do that by
asking the commentators and we love
being stumped by your questions so Jump
Right In And as we Jump Right In I want
to go to the game between Wesley so and
icaro Nakamura because I see an
opportunity for Hikaru to fall into a
devilish trap let's put it that way so
the last move when we left it f2f4
attacking the bishop and Hikaru had just
played the move Bishop C3 when literally
I was taking my seat the moment I saw
that move I saw this geometrical pattern
that uh fell in to my eyes I'll play
Kingdom move King H4 I want to take the
pawn on H5 Jovi so you will play
I will play
well the most natural crickets
Rook to D5 right attack the Knight and
get rid of the night
yeah of course Rook to D5 which is the
Trap that I have ready to spring on you
check all the way across the board check
take the Rook tip pardon me take the
Knight take the Rook now exactly at this
moment the bishop is attacked I can't
take the bishop but the pawn on B4 is
attack I had this crafty little move A3
ooh and this is a very well wait one
second what's that the game continues
right because I can't get a bishop F6
check oh no and you might not catch
you're welcome
hosted by my own petard I hate that when
that happens this is how I lose the lose
my games only by being far too clever
Bishop 8 F6 check well
it was a great trap for black
once it did no no it was by the way you
can play A4 if you want
oh well same problems
no not not Bishop F6 because then my
knight gets back in into play ah well
thank you for that you can go Bishop D2
and
maybe I'm not happy
I I do I do get back in time to capture
your palm but after A4
sorry after A4 Bishop D2 and I think
black is the first one yeah five you go
B3 I go E6 you go B2
you're the first one I was gonna say you
know also you know my intuition is just
telling me the bishop unless you're
trapped absolutely Works 100 you don't
want to be going into a night against
the bishop because the Knight against
the bishop in an open position is simply
the bishop is going to be superior
hate that
last last Quick uh double check to make
sure I I am as clever as I hoped I would
be uh exactly in this moment again your
Bishop is actually kind of Tethered to
the pawn so imagine I play King
um uh King H3 with the idea I'm
threatening A3
so let's go Bishop B1 Bishop E1 I'm
gonna tether your uh
G3 Pawn so I can't play I feel that
black is the one that could have the
upper hand King G6 26 yeah yeah yep yep
yep yep it's it it's it's a very very
good point that uh unfortunately for me
my king can't make a b line to the B to
the
uh be Pawn without losing my Jeep on and
even if you do make the B line whenever
you get to c410 let's say I put the
bishop on E2 and that's enough right
yeah Bishop only one excuse me not only
yeah and even this oh boy this actually
uh brings us to a table based position
wow okay
um well I
I
gave it my best shot
I mean King H4 uh Wesley what what are
the times as we joined uh resume this
classical game 43 minutes for Wesley and
an hour and 17 for Hikaru and Hikaru was
the one who had been blitzing through
move 20 and even 25 I don't know it
seems like he just knew exactly what to
do and he and Wesley taking his time
could be a case of the the hair against
the tortoise yeah I see
um In This Moment uh are the engine
giving old uh triple zeros for close to
it yeah close yes close to it maybe like
a plus 0.1 0.2 but if you go along with
most of the variations it there's not
going to be much progression and uh how
about Alice and uh
that's much more interesting I have to
say in position still there's a lot of
venom from both sides especially
strategical okay when we left it we just
left it around these parts I kind of
felt the position was pretty solid for
both players Rook on a to C1 F6 oh we're
changing the character of the position
well I yeah I thought I was going to
play F6 but the way you pronounced it it
was like oh you know did did Arena miss
something well look at Alice she stopped
and pause she's
befuddled by this move F6
well I I it looks very understandable to
my eyes I'm getting rid of this powerful
night in the center of the board that's
true but on the other hand look look
what you've done to the light squares
well that's why I have a light Square
Bishop to protect all of what like sort
of weaknesses I just created
something to do and now I know what I'm
doing I'm protecting G6 uh go for it
what well Knight D3 by the way I this
one I feel I'm on the Terra Firma that
now I've got uh this this was the reason
I was actually thinking that white could
potentially go Knight C4 Knight to C4
okay and then the whole idea is you know
stuff if we trade yeah if you trade then
white also has
plan of but don't I get some extra moves
for example Knight C4 we exchange and
then I go B5 B5 why not oh spoken like a
true groom fell player yes groomfield
players love getting in those Tempo
gaining Queen side expansions and Knight
C4 on the board Yes actually gonna
backpedal but someone who can't backped
or is Arena she's actually played but
Knight C4
but isn't black that has the much more
comfortable position after take on C4 B5
hang on a second I'm uh because why is
it much more comfortable just break it
it just feels like I have more space and
you do have space on the king side but
it also feels like he overextended a
little bit doesn't it well no no
I mean I'm thinking if it's my turn I
will play so for example if you play
Bishop F7 that's a fair move no no you
take my Pawn oh apologies I I will take
your Pawn now that you put it out there
no I knocking h8 get off this annoying
diagonal and
E4
okay I'll take on D4 take take it's Max
Mac it's Max Max smack on C1 okay
lunch bag
which one Queen D6 Queen David six oh no
no no no no don't don't pause he's not
afraid
playing with confidence at all times uh
go ahead take my Pawn on D4 I will but
not yet I will take on E5 First Take on
easy what do you take back with okay the
deepon queen B6 I'll give you a check
check
with the check just don't block that
check move the king no don't go to F1
move
uh by the way why why why didn't I yeah
because of you my king ends I win back
the bishop but the pawn on A3 is
I I was hoping I was going to get into a
bishop ending where maybe maybe maybe
you're not getting there no no no no I'm
not that nice to you yes sir oh Bishop
C6
whoa are you sure you're not that nice
to me I don't think so I might be I
don't know yeah
could you
oh
okay
I'm that kind of guy
made ends the game so what if I go
to C8 no root to see it I really don't
like that the C8 wow look you're getting
close to that mate and I don't like that
okay I I may have tricked you uh for a
moment but okay these are these are
exactly the type of variations that both
players are furiously calculating
because they're trying to judge you know
is the center weak is the queen side
pawns week and if I do get to play E5 E4
E5 can I exploit the B1 diagonal uh good
stuff going on here and uh the move B5
it's funny I shied away from that move I
was trying to play Bishop F7 and not
create a queen side weakness the the
grunfell player in Christian was like
hey give me that Tempo I love to push my
majority with a Tempo your immediate
thought would you have played B5
yourself uh Jovi or would you have
I didn't consider it actually my my
first instance was to kind of huddle up
into that proverbial ball right and just
try to resolve problems with the light
squares but the funny thing is when
Christians suggested B5 I was like ah
panic and
drive the bishop Back Drag the bishop
back see space and like the things that
I was worried about is like you know if
you do go B5 yes
because I I did spy this from afar that
I could possibly inflict damage please
continue
I mean
the move that you really want to be
playing is Bishop G6 to be honest with
you but that's not gonna happen well
you're going to encourage it could
happen actually but because it's it's on
please I think
um I think E6 Pawn is on praise too
right you you mean A3 and E6 if you take
on D4 yeah this was
um what uh Christian didn't like is just
giving up the pawn on B5 like if we got
a situation like this
like this this is where you're this is
where I was at yeah and there's a check
right to uh give me the chance to rescue
my Rook as well yeah
but this might not be so bad for black
compensation that is compensation
because the bishop comes to E4 yeah
that's a that's a gorgeous Bishop that
is a beautiful bishop and
and as always our review black and white
the players are back uh in the
elimination games Jimmy yes that will be
coming up shortly at 3 30 PM your time
and we can see that linear Dominguez
will be playing with the white pieces
against Levon aronian as you can see
there it is there in black and white as
he also said lenya is in a must-win
situation and Nazi Pakistan against Bay
game talk in Genova and it is begging
playing with the black pieces who needs
to win to stay alive to remain in a
competition so definitely I love it when
the players have their backs against the
wall of course some Karma going on here
right because it wasn't uh didn't linear
not LaVon in the classical yeah and if
Lanier could return the favor knock him
out in the elimination he'll get the
last laugh because knocking out an
elimination second yeah didn't they do
this in 2020 they did exactly the same
scenaries Groundhog Day exactly the same
scenario Lanier eliminated him well
kicked him to the elimination bracket in
the classical encounter right I believe
he did deliver almost a Checkmate in a
petroff with the black pieces that was
the critical game in that match and
after that Levon came back he defeated
Ray Robson in the first uh match of the
elimination bracket after that he met
Levon and then uh won that one and went
to the finals where he met Fabiano
caruana so yes it's it's a very very
similar scenario to what happened last
year Lanier with the white pieces right
now he needs to play Fast he needs to
choose an aggressive line because he
needs to get that crucial Victory to get
back into the match speak about that how
do you win on Demand with white when
you're playing a player like
le'veoner than with black
and I know thank you Captain Obvious
thank you yes yes you got you gotta tell
me how you get an advantage against
was playing that Bishop C5 arc angel
stuff
um Levon is Mr Marshall and what he was
actually Mr Berlin yesterday right
against Fabi so yeah you have two very
unpleasant weapons whenever you try to
get an advantage against with the move 1
E4 so if I was linear I would start with
something else
D4 perhaps he has played D4 I mean it's
a recent kind of string to his bow but
it wasn't the most aggressive default
systems that he was playing he was kind
of I think they're called collie or
right yes yes yes right so it was on
London systems maybe that's a way
forward but it did but before he also
has to worry about the role goes in I
mean there's so many things that he has
to worry about
um as white so yeah difficult very very
difficult situation for linear right now
I think we will see for I think he will
stick to his guns and we'll try to do
exactly what Fabiano did just Shuffle
the pieces maybe get accept an equal
position but keep the position close do
not exchange a lot of pieces take the
game down to their last few minutes and
then try to strike I think this is the
strategy is very straightforward and uh
most likely this is what we're going to
see one weakness that Lanier has is the
fact that he goes down on time in pretty
much every single game consistently yes
yes yesterday Fabiano managed to put
pressure on his opponent's time if
Lanier doesn't manage to do that well
unfortunately he's in a world of trouble
exactly
um still it's kind of stuck in my find
this game between Hikaru Wesley white
Hikaru black and there is a way of
winning a pawn for Wesley at the moment
I'm thinking once again of the move King
H4 Wesley's been burning clock so he's
definitely on the same I want to say
page for a moment you go Rook D5 again
otherwise I'm just gonna actually
happened
and otherwise I would just go King takes
H5 and gobbled upon so I do have a rook
check last time I went Knight E7 check
the Knight versus Bishop we kind of said
nah nothing going nothing happening
there gift me the Palm Rook takes H5 now
you will go obviously to get the counter
play here right and I'm thinking can I
set up
some kind of well I want to ask you
mating patterns let's go check
okay I'm going to run to the center with
King f8 okay so I will go Rook
to F5
in the immortal words of Nikolai menev
gift me upon give I can gift you the
pawn you can I can do that but you're
not going to I'm feeling lazy and I
don't really want to calculate that much
so I'm gonna go F6 okay and I will
insist I want to take your Pawn
I insist
okay okay well if you insist let's go
for it
rick takes AIDS here okay
I'm so happy
I I don't know if I'm going to voice
myself on my own my own uh petard here
but I mean I have
granted you a very very very powerful
passer I must say but
but I I don't I the cheerleaders are not
actually the band isn't playing I think
you're trying to lose
thank you Christian
putting it bluntly you're really trying
it's a good idea
I'm taking too many risks am I am I I'm
overdoing it a bit what about King is
seven right now King E7 why not yeah but
then there's a night check King E6 King
E6
probably rather
keep Knight D5
in the pocket I I would be very afraid
of that beep on that but that's just me
again at this point it could be a race
definitely be a race right okay uh
intriguing because Wesley is burning
some clock in this exact game position
and it has to be that he's thinking
uh the minor piece ending that's that's
number one because unless you saw the
move Bishop F6 check at the end of this
uh rather clever variation
historians might call it brilliant
is this where where
I think they're the clock that he
stopped the score sheets to be signed
until the cold shower Bishop F6 uh
really hit me full uh blast uh Bishop F6
wow that's a nice move it really is it
and so I can't do that and then this was
the the the minor piece ending where
yeah you thought that this was just fine
for blackish black will have no worries
and I won't disagree yeah okay so it's
either when the pawn
take the draw with the minor piece
ending and where he seems to be reaching
for his Rook
H6 right Rook H6 yeah if he is reaching
for Rook then that's the only place
where he can go okay H6 King G8 and how
do you continue this one here well this
is
H5 right and then we went Rook to D2
yeah
let's let's go into that variation once
yeah so how do you continue right now I
went Knight H6 last time I was I would
be very happy if you found something a
little bit more convincing Knight H6 and
after King to G7
yeah and then well actually I think we
went away I think right but that allows
you to take the F7 part right I will try
to keep hold on to that pawn on F7 it
makes a lot of sense
uh these uh again I'm I was trying to
weave some now I take on it mating Nets
with the with the Rook kinda
pawn and night yes please uh I always
feel like this this uh once you allow
the 80 Pawn to drop it becomes very
risky I mean Ken white just do the
obvious which is just to in the position
go King to G five okay no no not with
the Rook saddle there in the corner just
from the original game position Rook D5
King G5 what's wrong with that there's
F6 isn't it F6 F6 wins yeah okay so this
is what you've missed uh Jovi after the
move F6
can I keep the Knight protected but
perhaps you can try to do a similar
thing but include Rook H6 first Rook
right
F6 at least you have the G6 square and
exactly that's right you're checkmating
that that's all the difference in the
world that's that's that's the
checkmating pattern that I'm dreaming of
so Rook H6 okay so it's like we're gonna
have to share scripts with one another
you like the king G5 I like The Rook H6
and here we go
what's going on here maybe this is
something let's keep going
Rook to D2 okay now what you can do is
can you
flip and go to Rook A6 I love it and
then the whole idea is this is my
sophisticated idea after Rook D5 I'm
gonna go King H6 babam
got my mating
yeah baby that's that's looking juicy
that is brilliant
I knew together
well Christian I'm sorry that you had to
suffer through that one but you did your
best
by yourself don't involve me in this one
that was a good price responsibility
guys
absolutely not it actually helped you
with King 2g5
it was a three effort of the three of us
that I always have to defend here right
go into the clinches when you need to I
like the moves Rook H6 King G5 uh
probably after King G5 instead of Rook
D2 maybe Rook comes over well that that
same idea that you had of slipping your
your your king into H6 really looked
attractive but now I have Rook A8 right
yes you do yes I defend the eighth Rank
and
perhaps this could be enough yeah I mean
I understand you take on H5 right right
right how do you continue off uh okay
but one thing I'm really feeling is that
uh Wesley is taking no risks I mean
because you've always got these prepared
ideas Perpetual check I mean to say so I
think that uh
well all things considered rather play
playing white I think he's got the draw
pretty much in hand in maybe there's
some tricks that he could still try now
one thing that
worries me about this position
um is Hikari is playing very fast right
he's not spending any time more
importantly he's not spending any energy
it feels like it Wesley on the other
hand he's really trying right he's
really trying to find something
if this one ends in the next like let's
say an hour an hour and a half but with
Wesley spending a lot of energy before
they go into the playoffs
how difficult will it be to gather and
master those and replenish those energy
levels be for what we know will be a
very taxing playoff scenario against
Hikaru Nakamura
and if that's the case why don't you
just try to pull the brakes
find a drop pull the brakes
go get ready for the playoffs repeat
your lines and come back with some I'm
just looking at the position I don't
think I've ever seen Hikaru lose this
type of positions I don't I can't
remember last time I've seen such a
simplified position and one of these
elite players getting outplayed and
Hikaru is not signaling that he's in any
sort of danger he's playing fast he's
playing confidently it just seems like
he knows what he's doing and I tend to
believe him
I
I understand
New York do you think
you know this is where Wesley has to put
the pressure on Hikaru
it's strange because for me when I'm in
these type of situations where I feel
I'm just slightly better and my opponent
is closer to the draw than I am to the
win
it's like I've always kind of this is
why I admire Magnus so so much is he's
the grind meister and he produces
victories out of positions where you
just don't see anything develop and
flower so when you are in that moment
where you feel like okay I'm better
there must be something here yeah I say
put all the energy you have into the
game don't worry about the tiebreaker if
you can win this I mean
you save yourself a world of Anguish and
I am curious about the Rook H6 and King
G5 Maneuvers to get us started uh sorry
Jeffy please yeah no I was going to kind
of also piggyback on that point as well
I don't think it's going to be a walk in
the park for Hikaru
he's making it appear as it as if it is
I'm not so sure that's kind of all
smokes and mirrors right look over here
not over here yeah exactly
um but some opportunity here and again
we have been looking at Rook H6 check
followed by Rook takes H5 giving up the
A2 bond for what looks like could
potentially be dangerous uh playing
against the black's King we've also been
looking at a pretty nifty little line
that goes Rook check King G8 King G5
sidestepping F6 check King G6 by
including the check and we've been
looking at those lines and still kind of
came out empty-handed but surely
something
ought to be there let's jump to uh
number one versus number two in the
ladies competition and that was it I I
went right by uh as Alice Lee with the
white pieces today is tied the match is
tied on uh half off and by the way uh
nice little move by arena there on her
last turn no B5 no Bishop F7 King h8
sidestepping all kinds of things and
basically saying the pawn isn't no
longer pinned I'm not worried about F5 I
can I can play E5 or
coming up next Bishop G6 something you
wanted to do
you do that very much to put the bishop
on G6 and just mobilize it and Alice
played E4 right expanding in the center
makes sense sorry please yeah no I I I
agree with that
but um
does feel that well arena is on the
defensive here well there was one thing
that um
Christian was trying to do which was to
weaken this Pawn on D4 so that he could
play a move like Queen D6 last time he
had included B5 and swapped
Rooks right this time I'll try to do it
I'm going to try to trick white in the
sense if you put your Rook here now B5
and Rook pick C1 maybe
Oops why do I have to be clever a forest
yeah
so it feels like maybe I should try to
employ a different plan yeah I've been
exchanging on D4 quite often and maybe I
don't have to do that okay let's
maintain the tension okay let's start
with B5 okay
last time we put our Bishop back on A2
right and let's keep going with A5 A5
yes I want to play B4
wow I want to open up the position in
that manner and keep the tension as well
is it okay if you just say
I don't believe you I mean we just carry
on how do we carry them we're using the
plan to go I forgot our plan
it's my plan to kind of go D5 and also
Bishop B1
uh we were playing E5 and then after a
trade we were get we were seizing this
uh nice B1 H7 diagonal so I feel like
the natural planets pops D5 okay the
problem I'm having on the D5 is
what happens after C4 then I don't
really want to take this do I no no you
just slide the queen over or The Rook to
dd1 okay give me The Rook okay
uh but I feel like I'm artificially
isolating this guy you are actually
takes oh DNA five Queen C5 check we've
been we've been out foxed
uh so I think you were starting with E5
right yes but now my plan yes devilish
yes that is is to just pass by F5 close
up this annoying diagonal that you've
been pestering me on with Bishop B1
Queen C2
he's playing well huh yeah okay so maybe
what we have to do is keep the tension
you know what you want to go B5 what is
what does the bishop want to go to A2 I
because there was a king on G8 last turn
right and I also the queen down so it
does but let's put the bishop where on
E2 yeah okay
um I'm still a little bit uh befuddled
by uh takes takes takes something that
Christian wanted to do in a different
setting
uh give me the pawn on F4 E5 was always
obviously okay give me the pawn on D4
let's see
C5
Rook C5 okay
and I'm not as bold as Christian to play
A5 and B4 uh I'll just chill A6
um and I want to play Bishop to G6 maybe
on a good day
and how is the situation
takes takes
much much okay yes yes
um
I feel three resulting I mean to be fair
I I'm not sure I I like either player
definitively either side definitively I
want to say because there are these weak
ponds around the board A3 D4 F4 there is
a weak King as well
this is where experience and judgment
are a key factor also I'm worried a bit
about Alice's time management she is E4
last move she spent close to 16 minutes
yeah and that's a lot
before on e4 yeah so wow it doesn't seem
like she see a she sees a clear plan
to take the initiative get close to the
black king because the way I see it and
you guys have been trying this for quite
a while yeah do something on the B1 H7
diagonal right but whenever you go E5 I
go F5
if you go F5 that closes you close
yourself right that B1 H7 diagonal and
if you don't have those type of plans
how do you counter my offensive on the
queen side yeah no I I hear you uh B5 A5
get the queen side going and in the
meanwhile it's not so easy for white to
advance maybe E5 can be met by F5 sorry
maybe while F5 cannot be met by E5
please maybe um I was actually thinking
maybe E4 was perhaps an inaccuracy but I
do have an idea to kind of but it needs
to be worked on
and that's the business refined
worked on
yes no so the idea is that I kind of
have in mind that just at the minute
they're just like a bit nebulous in the
air you know after f is so if you strike
with F5 then you've kind of pushed with
E5 so that's just there exactly so
and there we can see on the camera that
uh whilst the Champions players are
playing their games are cool yeah all
those players in the Elimination
Brackets are getting ready we see Levon
aronian who needs to fund off linear
Dominguez because Dominguez isn't a
must-win situation Nadi paikitsa she
likes to arrive early to the board she
is playing with the white pieces she
after taking it early lead she just has
to Simply hold on a draw is good enough
to take her to the next level exactly
exactly and I I love that feeling of
being in control of the match and having
white that's just huge
um I noticed that begum came in the
studio to ask her coach some last minute
advice and I I don't think you're giving
anything away when I say what did you
advise begum to do with the black pieces
to play for a win just stick to the plan
stick to the plan to what we discussed
before the match as well
none of the lines that we discussed were
very very passive so this is exactly
what I think she should be doing right
now and let's see where it goes just
keep the pieces on the board and play a
game I think this is the most important
the game is not going to be decided in
the opening just keep fighting yeah okay
and as we expected Catalan is now on the
board between Najee and begin
nice
um
it's funny I actually like playing the
white side of the Catalan that I am
aware that it does give the second
player lots of opportunity of winning
upon you can play D5 take C4 talking
about winning a Pawn Yeah D5 takes E4
and trying to keep the pawn with C6
exactly I mean in this particular
variation my understanding is that the
best line for black is actually you say
capture the pawn and say look at your
knight on C3 it's not going to assist in
the quest of re
capturing the yes before Pawn but now
we're back into the days of karpov and
coach now I remember Baguio City Baguio
the Philippines the world championship
match where they where they essayed and
I have seen a number of recent games uh
very very topical games it's a pawn
sacrifice for Bishops of opposite colors
where the pawn is on G3 most of the
games I must say end up drawn so
unfortunately for black this is a very
safe line for white exactly exactly
Knight C6 is not a way to play for a win
wait if play a good way of playing for
equality jump in Christian how is your
how is your pupil going well there's a
few ways right yeah a few ways to play
for equality C5 exactly is one of them
one of the topical lines in at the
position A6 perhaps just to uh keep the
game going a little bit perhaps it's an
idea in Midnight AC4 with maybe Knights
7 or 90 even to C6 things of that nature
but it's not easy I have to say this is
a very good line to play with the white
pieces if you only need a draw because
Knight to C6 which is the main topical
line it's quite dry and I think Nazi
knows that this is a difficult moment
right now for baggie well I was about to
say after Knight C3 if I'm playing for a
win as black I probably want to play the
move C7 C6 so that the idea is that
after castles now you can take I can
take and get some kind of an imbalance
where well okay something is going on
unfortunately captures night night E5
you know has made it a lot uh more
simplified I want to say now if you play
C5 and I take and we trade Queens
um
yeah you you make a safe equality with
black but no no no not more than that
right exactly and in the other game
between levonnev again Levon is in a
situation where he just needs a draw
okay but in this case Lanier has the
white pieces they're in the Berlin
ending and again they've made so many
games and advances whoa F2 F3 what a
move F3
before computers if you had said you
know to the old school what's the best
move here and you suggested F3 they
might have laughed you out of the chess
club you know take away your membership
wouldn't allow you back oh they were
cruel yeah it'd be interesting to have
that debate right between day chat right
these classical players and then have
the kind of modern day plays kind of
right completely refute I know I did
these classical principles I know they
would be laughed out of the house F3
Bishop F5 what's the what does the
topical
theoretical battle say about this
position well it doesn't seems like
we're out of theory right oh we are yes
yes Bishop to E3 H5 and F3 is uh the
first move out of their book right
they're blitzing like everybody knows
what they're doing they always do that
they really always do that do you know
when dinner with them after
after Lavon had crashed out to Lanier
and they were they were talking about
you know having studied together and
they're talking about this Berlin engage
and the Fortress I remember yes and uh
Lavon actually told me when he came to
this Fortress that he had discussed this
is this Fortress with not only Fabiana
Carolina but Lydia Dominguez as well
and ladier had forgotten
so he's like dude we had this discussion
years ago and you agreed that it was a
draw now you're sitting here studying
the position for as if it's the first
time like what's wrong with you yeah uh
how awkward that's a little embarrassing
okay Lanier needing a win sacrificed
upon to play for it right sacrifice the
pawn no get this Pawn storm going on the
king's side that bishopon H7 maybe if I
manage to defend the pawn on E5 and play
the move F5 that's going to close down
shop for the bishop on H7 right let's
start with Bishop F2
oh you you even want to trade Bishops
I'm I'm okay with trading it's all about
that Bishop on H7 and how passive it is
for wow you're going to need a lot of
moves to get it out okay let's have a
look see okay so I'm gonna give you
everything
oops sorry yeah I think I I want to get
my king closer
um Let me give my king a little
breathing room
and Rook E1 let's go rookie one sure
let's try it out doesn't the king move
up the ball to G3 or something I'm
thinking about the other Rook on E1 oh
what would you like uh sorry maybe Rook
fv1 Rook fe1 you got it I'm easy
uh let's go F5 okay so this is what I
wanted for black that's using F3 King F3
okay so normally speaking
um I'm trying to use my majority right
that's fine let's go King F4 I'm just
pushing
pushing up the board a A3 that's as far
as you're getting
it you pull it you're putting the brakes
on my my beloved a pawn no I was
thinking of starting to attack you right
now Knight D4 Knight what Knight E4
night I'm trying to get 35. I'm really
trying to focus on that Bishop of yours
okay I I hear you loud and clear
and you've chased me to Purgatory so
finally I got pretty much everything I
wanted right now in the meanwhile
uh sorry The Rook was actually headed
towards B5 you're trying to get to B5 uh
to B4 check all right let's reestablish
the material balance take on H5 okay
uh but this is just Berlin stuff I'm not
saying
um I'm not uh I'm not feeling
overwhelmed but unless you're gonna go
with some beautiful Pawn bread that's
what I'm thinking yes okay that's what
I'm thinking how is that let's say F6 F6
close you up on close close shop huh yes
uh wow
um
my goodness what a race we're going to
be it is a race yeah yeah it is a race
and I'm sure we we've made a lot of
mistakes well along the way but yeah
okay
um
this is how you're supposed to win when
you need it I mean and their overall
scores uh Christian yeah it seems like
uh
not looking good for linear five minutes
15 losses and by the way this isn't
wrapping and a 50 draws so lebanaronium
definitely having the upper hand in this
close encounter
wow 15 wins that's a three to one margin
that's pretty severe uh let me just go
back to the current position I just uh
like you said that was really a lot of I
was surprised were you surprised by his
by Christian's decision to trade off the
dark Square Bishops with Bishop F2
because that caught me a little bit off
guard uh yeah I was you had a different
approach yourself I would preserve those
Bishops I thought so too but the problem
is is he wants to play F5 and he's he
has to defend the pawn on E5 in order to
do that right but I mean one of the
things I was wondering is like how safe
is the case that we see that there has
been a movement of one has movement yeah
well that that kind of
I'm sitting there saying from Black's
point of view I don't mind that check
because now that my king is over on the
queen side all I've got to do is
Liberate the Rook right if I could just
magically play Rook on a a to the middle
of the board E7 I'm happy so I'm
thinking A5 A4 Rook lift I was thinking
please resolve the situation okay in the
middle of the board first and then carry
on with A5 A4 so I was thinking so I
don't know what kind of move white would
play
but just try to get F6 and
you so that there's no E6
pardon me you want to play F6 is black
yeah yeah okay sorry yes
so
um I well Bishop F2 again was
Christian's Choice uh so say for
instance you do use that term
takes and Christian wanted to go King
tape yes and so we just go F6
immediately immediately you know just go
you know what I respect your plan but
you're not gonna get it today here I was
a
when you when you put your Pawn on F6
this time capturing gives me a passer
and I'm pretty excited by that okay but
if we can also manipulate the move order
so that you don't get that parcel order
possible so you want you want to take so
take let's take first okay and then I
just want to see whether you can get
away with this type of
right F6 okay so we we tickle the bishop
we we now the bishop moves backwards to
G8 because okay
wherever I mean
yes and it's time to nail down a
weakness I want to play with the Knight
to E4 so
either F5 and Rook H6 or Rook H6
immediately and just like that
welcome to the the nasty world of Chess
yeah that's exactly and and but you
played the natural move right I mean
nothing and that's untoward happened and
then suddenly The Rook invaded so yeah
it's
you you got it Berlin is a strange
animal oftentimes you have to curb your
own Ambitions and not make decisions
like H5 takes G4 or F6 and that's where
this you know
prophylactic A5 keeping F6 by the way
another
um pardon me another option you often
want to play in a Berlin your F6
notwithstanding sometimes G5
or H takes G4 H takes G4 G5 uh tricky
tricky stuff tricky stuff but linear is
thinking for a very very long time and
once again falling down on the clock
severely that's the problem they started
off well
um he started off while he was blitzing
out his moves but right now after this
King to C8 came on the board of cd1 King
to C8 it does seem like Levon is still
within his book he still knows well
Lavon has more than 25 minutes so I
would say Havana certainly within his uh
linear not so much
that's another good sign
well especially after he sacrificed the
pawn on C2 once you've played into this
position you would expect that he would
have had his uh he'd be ready to Blitz
out his follow-up after all you've
sacrificed upon for a reason what was
that reason still a balanced position
nevertheless how should he play it
according to the computer then not 100
sure because I was looking at a
completely different game right now and
that is the game between Irina and Alice
Irina seems to be building a very nice
Advantage it feels like Alice has
been LED astray with her last few moves
she played the movie for spent a lot of
time on it Bishop to C6 a very crafty
decision by Irina which didn't force but
coax uh Alice to play the move E5 and
after F5 strategically it does seem like
Irina has a tremendous position that
Bishop on the long diagonal Landing only
four and you still have that huge
weakness on D4 as white I I'm not liking
this for Alice and I think she's not
comfortable in the position either is
there any way that she can kind of back
pedal and go Queen A2 you can you can
absolutely yeah and maybe that's the
right way to do it but I think I will
challenge that Bishop with Bishop D5
the problem I'm having with the position
is actually what I feel is the backward
Pawn on D4 yes
I mean it just feels like you know black
is ready to double and maybe even travel
against this pawn and you're losing the
pawn on D4 yeah you're actually just
losing the pawn on D4 it feels like uh
arena is tricked Alice with this yes it
it was very cleverly done uh Bishop C6
E5 looks a natural F5 was an alternative
rookie one was an alternative but E5 F5
the inclusion of those two moves
um convinces me that Alice has been
tricked definitely perhaps Alice thought
it wasn't possible she was just thinking
oh well one takes porn or something I
don't know but uh
and just to remind everybody if there is
well there will be a winner
there has to be a tie breaks or
otherwise and uh the winner will get a
day off tomorrow right yes because
tomorrow we play the finals in the
elimination bracket gotcha here it is
this is what our schedule Jovi and in
the Elimination Brackets they will be
playing a two-game rapid playoff and if
the match ends in a tie then of course
leave slash the time controls make it
even faster and well we'll see what
happens right and the thing goes but the
great thing about tomorrow and today is
that every match will be decided we will
know by the end of the day he's gone
through who's been sadly eliminated from
the tournament and we'll get the whole
range of emotions
true that uh yesterday again to remind
you is that this is something I I would
just if I was a coach I would take our
broadcast from yesterday most of
actually all the moves all the games
between Bobby
and Lavon and I would condense that into
a kind of a study of how you play mini
matches because I think that that was
Chess at its
highest in the sense of the many many
good moves that were played but also the
competitiveness of the two players and
whatever it is that separated them it
was it was a whisker it was a it was
such a close match if you if it had gone
the other way I I would have been elated
as well yeah I
such a clash like that and a big
Challenge and a big shout out to Fabi
too because doubtlessly he was
disappointed but he showed up at dinner
last night with Colin uh with the
Make-A-Wish Foundation and made the
young man's evening so it was all good
and in fact you know talking about it
all being good you know there was also
no hostility towards no they were just
they were the same table and they were
even discussing opening possibilities in
the game as well later on in the evening
yes it was that's chess players Life Is
Life and uh for the moment it does look
like Alice Lee is on the back foot as we
do have Advantage uh for her here and
let's jump into uh the game of bacon
from please sorry yeah no it's just just
before things get very wild in the rapid
game I mean I actually see that
Hikaru and Wesley did play did play you
know something that we were talking okay
let's take a look at that game as I
bring it up on our screen yes and I will
update my board Wesley has kind of taken
some risks he said yes I'm gonna go for
your H6 pawn and I will let you have
look at this he borrowed our ideas he
did uh King Rook H6 check followed by
King G5
no Bishop no Rook A5 or Rook D2 going
after the a pawn but Bishop G7
immediately Rook takes H5
so the inclusion of the move Bishop G4
G7 that's a bit of a surprise for me
it's a nice defense though was that
really a good wow okay so King dropped
back and he's threatening Rook to G5
that's a winning threat so Hikaru
sidestep that
and the inclusion of Bishop G7
and Bishop C3 meant that the king is not
as aggressively placed on the G4 Square
as it was a moment ago
and also the absence of the age Pawn
also means it's not so easy to hide the
King on H6 is what we're doing okay for
a second I thought Hikaru is a pawn down
I couldn't see that point on F7 I was a
bit worried for you right with that pawn
on F7 I don't think you have much
uh with the pawn on F7 we don't have
much let's see because even whenever you
get to the king with the King on H6
let's see you managed to get somehow to
H6 and threaten checkmate
I will have Rook to H2 check from the h
file it doesn't seem like Hikaru is
going for that Rook to A7 is his choice
now what does he want against King to G5
exactly the very fact that the Rook is
so beautifully placed behind the past
Pawn convinces me that that uh
initiative is still no I understand he
wants to just match that King with his
own King King to H7 and Rook 2 A7
defends the seventh rank so that you
don't have any sort of ideas with Rook
to B7 to push my King backwards yes I
think they they will go for uh some sort
of a repetition now yeah it's happening
right now
you can just from the body language of
the players yep there you go
reconciled themselves to a draw well you
said it very well that you don't see
Hikaru losing these endings
in these positions no way okay well in
that case we can now jump to our uh
rapid chess uh games and first of all
one one we've got tie Breakers coming up
okay about
I think they'll start at 5 30. they will
start at 5 30 and interesting enough
this is actually hikaru's first
so yes whereas Wesley
that's that's what he's been doing to
qualify through his matches is by tie
break playoff so welcome to the tie
breaks Hikaru how are you feeling are
you in a good shape uh begum versus
um we have C7 C6 and I take C4 and
I must say that it feels to me like like
Naji has gotten a nice version of a
Catalan uh I did right now yes yes but
Beckham did miss a big opportunity she
did one move earlier she took a bit too
much time to get ready to play this move
C5 and allow this queen to e to which uh
pretty much put the puts the kabash on
this idea of C5 because of the Pawn on
B5 being under attack you can play
however C5 in one move instead of Rook
to C8 right and that was her golden
opportunity her golden ticket
potentially a very very difficult
position for white how do you play right
now if you take on B7 we exchange that
but your king gets weak there is a lot
of tension in the center on that pawn on
D4 and we know how quickly these
positions can turn right right in an
instant after Queen to E2 Knight to B4
with Rook on C8 where is that Knight
going and it just feels like white has a
clear way to finish her development with
Bishop to D2 Rook to C1 if I manage to
get the bishop to E1 hide it away keep
the the D and C files potentially open
like that it just feels like white will
have the upper hand at the same time
there's still a lot of pieces left on
the board right and this is everything
that begin wants right she doesn't want
any sort of dry Petrov or anything of
that nature she wants as many pieces on
the board because
a loss or a draw makes no difference
right you need to win this one we saw
how many risks uh Levon took yesterday
with his modern opening Choice he was
completely losing at one point but he
managed to turn the tables by keeping it
chaotic and this is exactly what bagging
should be doing in this one I liked the
bishop D2 Rook C1 approach as you say
all I've got to do is draw and I'm
through
play solid I agree completely I mean
I've had a lot of experience on the
black side of this particular opening
and what you're looking for is just
neutralizing the whole white initiative
and I agree Bishop D2 Rook C1 I loved
Christians Bishop even one movers yeah
as well nice touch the bishop getting
out of the way of the rook and it's also
very instructive very dramatic she
played it right yeah another nice thing
from Whiteside is I think the you know
especially when you get a lot of
experience with the Catalan you you come
to realize that so much of the opening
depends on the move c65 if you get to
play it you're usually okay if you don't
you're usually much worse and I think
you know what the problem is with Knight
D5 yeah the control of the D3 it was 93
control of C5 gives white cement
I have ideas of A4
and the typical A6 defense doesn't work
very well because I take on B5 I
exchange open up the a file and now with
bishopon D2 I have Knight takes D5
followed by Bishop to A5 but you can get
away right don't don't take with the a
pawn no no yes sir C Pawn okay uh same
story okay unfortunately but uh the
brick can take on D5 if you're gonna
sell sell yourself
as possible okay fair but in any case it
is an exchange uh sacrifice A7 A6 by
Vega and begum says if you if uh I'm I'm
prepping the move Knight D5 I'll play A7
A6 I like that move I think one thing is
doing good in this game is doing well is
the fact that she plays fast and there's
some pressure on Nazi's clock right now
right right 11 minutes and counting down
against 18 minutes for Tokyo Genova by
the way once again I I find myself to be
a Catalan player again I've been talking
about the C6 C5 break if I'm in white
shoes I would shut it down I really
would I would play the movie A3 uh Drive
the Knight backwards and then play B4
and say you are not getting in C5 I
don't think you're going to get an A5
either the bishop on D2 I agree X-rays I
was also going to ask the question
please so I was tempted to actually go I
A3 okay and then after night night D5
yep I was actually thinking of going
night takes night just to kind of make
your life a little bit easier if you
take with a c Pawn bearing in mind
you're in a must win situation it's
going to be very difficult because I'm
going to challenge you honestly if you
take with the e-pawn then I'm kidding
yeah you have to do this and then I was
thinking that you could lock it down
with B
B4 and then you stop any A5 ideas that
they sometimes true whether the knights
are traded or not it's it's very clear
that the move A3 and B4 A3 on the board
and Knight E4 came also thematic I've
seen that done many occasions actually
played it myself had it done to myself
okay uh 94 again controlling uh the C5
Square can we just take oh there is a
sacrifice I was about to say Knight
takes E4 Bishop takes E4 C5 there is a
sacrifice again all I need is a
Perpetual I've got it
pocket in this case so 94 by Naji is
saying
um well this could be a little bit of a
nicer see because Knight takes night you
like it I like it okay
it takes and now you you drop back with
a knight to F6 that's a terrible against
the bishop exactly so go back and now I
can go C5
and now you go C5 and now I'm out I'm
fantastic but I don't think more than
equalizer exactly how fantastic is it I
think you've managed to make your break
and make anything let's go back to G2
instead of F3 well the reason I wanted
F3 Christian I was thinking that Bishop
takes F3 Queen takes F3 versus Bishop
takes G2 but I want to have a tactic
please Bishop to A5
and now you don't have Bishop takes F3
right so I think that wins an exchange
right take on B7 you move the rook and
then I have Knight C6 right that's
that's that's a very very nice trick
something that we should all bear in
mind Bishop A5 I've seen it before and
uh I forgot about it but nice Bishop A5
so
uh your your knight came back with the
tempo but you didn't manage to equalize
after all uh Jovi so perhaps now you
have to go A5 but then that allows B4 it
just doesn't look like a very
comfortable and if I play C5
immediately that's probably yeah the
right way to approach this position
right Chief well I don't know you could
win the two Bishops of course by just
capturing a twice on C5 and being
better yeah yeah and maybe that's the
best way
to continue yeah okay well keep an eye
on that let's jump to our other
um
uh
rapid tiebreaker and this is between the
Lanier and Lavon and well we need to
catch up with the players because uh
Lanier has sacrificed upon for this
position
and
nobody is enthused the Rooks are off the
board why isn't black just
doing great
well well well well
this I mean Black's pawns are not
marching forward just yet
they are also white just kind of has to
carry on okay 93 so we'll take yeah now
I'm no longer with all the Rooks off the
board I'm not worried about the open H
file anymore so let's get going
and then the king
E4
I'm struggling yep King E4 can you for
put the Knight on E okay night goes to e
sorry D five yep you got it and
then
yeah
your your next move to squeeze me off
the board is going to be pretty uh fun
uh is it time for do I at last get the
chance to play G6 and maybe try to take
twice on can I go night at home Waits if
you go G6 I have no idea please this is
my F6 there you go but you didn't need
to do this well I'm kind of happy still
come on thanks
well
well what is this have I not locked your
Bishop out of the game you have but in a
sense I've locked your king out of the
game right
yeah no yes no swings
you're happy me happy
whatever yeah
um
eventually I'm gonna get
my king
you know out of the way so I get to go
C6 in other words I agree with you my
Bishop is landlocked but I kind of think
that your king is
my Landmark you're not going to win
with your Bishop against my king only
yeah that's true you know you one day
you're gonna have to move
and I can't necessarily like go without
releasing my Bishop but okay
um let's jump to the engine of our uh
Christian uh what does is Lavon cruising
or is he you guessed it of course it's
zero zero zero zero zero it shows very
balanced position okay once again it's
all about the bishop on H7 how do you
solve that problem right right mistakes
H takes B5 this is what we have
currently on the board you have to
create your own counter chances sure on
the queen side pretty much distract me
from worrying about your Bishop right
and trying to get to it which is not
easy it's really really difficult to get
to your Bishop I would love to provoke
somehow this move G6 so maybe try to get
G5 in the position force you to play or
at least uh coax you to play the move G6
and after F6 that Bishop is going to be
dead but that's not going to happen so
yeah I mean I have to say Levon knew his
opening new uh the Berlin end game with
the black pieces quite well and he
doesn't seem to have too many issues in
the position remaining right now well
that game that he drew with Fabi where
he was well aware of the Fortress
that he's really really prepared the
Berlin to adapt that well dare I say is
extraordinary yeah I mean wow uh C5 C4
okay I mean very berlin-like fashion and
Lavon is saying yeah you know I've got a
I've got a four versus two majority over
there
let me put my guys to work and I can't
blame him for that
no I cannot blame him either and I was
going to say just very nice strategy and
very nice plan from Lavon and as you
guys have indicated just don't
don't mess up
or defensive formation forget about that
Bishop right well actually here this is
a question this is a testing question
should I put the bishop on C5 where it's
kind of active or do I go Bishop to d8
just what did you do against me
sure
it was fantastic
it worked that's what I'll I'm gonna go
Bishop to d8 because I'm not even sure
why I'll go Bishop to Da but it's sort
of like I mean I guess we should try
with like a very passive performance
first all I need is a draw exactly all I
need is a draw hold it and I was trying
Bishop for her because really I'm stuck
for a plan and I like something about it
unless the king
can come and the white king can come in
so maybe what I can do is instead of
Bishop before because I think you had
done a different construction with A5 so
I'm going to go Bishop C sorry it's ff2
okay so you're tickling my guy and yeah
and my guys advancing and then you just
why did you
the problem is in the backing steps
forward but hang on a second if you step
forward I can just go A3 and whoops I do
believe you are in a mating net I am in
a meeting that for just the moment
um I wasn't going forward so much as I
was I was the bishop C5 okay that was
the question maybe he was afraid of
night before
it's entirely possible that night before
uh forces the king in that in that exact
moment in an awkward uh place here by
the way if black were to if it was
Black's turn King D7 C6 driving the
night away would have uh my vote of
confidence Bishop C5 okay once again the
computers is like saying triple zeros uh
but is it easier to play white or black
I find it easier to be a pawn up I mean
personally Black's plan is very simple
right it's just to go forth and multiply
on the green side we call it coronation
but yes
yes give me a girl especially when you
have dry in the pocket yeah and I have a
lot of time on the clock as well I mean
I think it looks like it's 17 to 8 17 to
7 17-7 7 and 30 seconds counting down
it's it's difficult to create anything
with the white pieces right now because
whenever I managed to exchange that
Pawn C5 dark Square official for
the Knight and get the opposite color
Bishops on the board and I go G6 I open
up the position I even give you the pawn
so for example you go G6 you go F6 I go
G5 check right open that Bishop you can
take my G5 Pawn no problem and then I
will be able to set up uh the blockade
on the light squares exactly okay it
doesn't look like it's going anywhere by
the way I really have to give a shout
out to the house of Stockton the house
of starting is the company that makes
these pieces their works of art they're
triple weighted sets they're digitally
digital game timer enhanced so that they
work with the dgt boards and they're
just beautiful I mean you feel like a
professional when you're at the board
and the furniture is provided by a local
Furniture designer here in Missouri and
uh there you see the the pieces are just
well they're Exquisite the the green
felt and yeah
spoken as a True Wood Enthusiast I am a
chess set collector and I'm very very
proud of my and I like the stunt designs
I'm not for the fancy bone and you know
Jam encrusted no no give me the luxury
words
no but uh having said that on the house
on Staunton yeah I mean we have some in
Oslo and they're just amazing yeah and
then I I was I was thinking I must buy
this but then I went and checked the
price and I thought
but everyone really is a work of art
yeah and if you could if you have some
place in your house to display yes
you go for it you feel real good uh jump
in uh Christian and tell us how your
pupil is doing not great not great
definitely not great look and this is
why it's so difficult to play Whenever a
draw is sufficient for your opponent
because at this point after this move
Knight we for the best way to continue
would have been to take take and I'll go
C5 that was the problem Bishop takes H7
and then we get the perpetual and then
we sign the score sheets and the match
is over right you have to avoid this at
all costs which it did but you you're
also conceding a lot of things whenever
you try to avoid this type of exchanges
in the position she played A5 Knight to
G5 Rook to have faith you have to defend
the pawn on F7 E4 Knight to C7 Bishop to
E3 this is what we have right now
if you give me one more move I'm going
to go Rook to C1 put the keyboard This
C5 move you have to play C5 exactly
right we have to you you have to go for
C5 the problem is what if I just simply
take take exchange everything even this
move check this one out you cannot touch
this Knight only five after F4 your
queen is trapped in the middle of the
board that's that's a nice one that is
definitely a nice one
it's not looking good I managed to
stabilize the position all my pieces are
much better placed than yours look at
this Knight on C7 what's the Future For
That Knight on C7 not uh very bright
these beautiful Knights on E5 and G5 are
putting tremendous pressure on your
position this one is looking like Nazi
is probably going to take it home oh
cruising uh
wow okay that's and by the way C5 is on
the board
C5 is now on the board yeah and let me
remind you back him had 18 minutes at
some point against 11 minutes right now
begging me is down on time
so she lost that Advantage 10 minutes to
yeah
wow uh okay uh that was a real visual uh
Jovi uh DC Bishop C5 Bishop C5 Queen C5
Rook C1 it's not often that you know you
just hang a piece in the middle of the
board and go oh darn it
is that one of those where you go Rook
C1 and then you clutch your head yes yes
yes your opponent like what am I doing
it takes immediately on E5 and then you
five four put your watch on yeah yeah
start sipping your water yeah
right someone called an ambulance right
and then you go after Queen takes F4
right for me uh yes Queen to B6 I
understand this Knight is bad
okay but
bingham's a move or two away from
kicking the knights back but but what if
I just go Knight to D7
that kind of appeals to me especially
because you're in a must win oh Lord
on the seventh rank I understand I'm not
happy I'm not happy I'm just I'm just
dreaming of getting my pieces in better
to better squares Knight to C5 would be
a dream come true H6 when you're not oh
gosh you got Queen H5 so what if I
remember no but I'm afraid of Rook takes
C oh then there are others no it doesn't
work associate oh no Queen H5 yeah oh no
this is not looking at age six and Rook
takes F7 well well well well well well I
take on f8 and I go Queen to h8 and the
pishpoint C8
what a party pooper that was uh Rook
Rook uh uh skiers scares the bishop
there you're not gonna win this one
oh boy oh boy okay that didn't work uh
we in that case
uh Rook C1 and and now she's really in
the driver's seat in this case oh yes oh
yes yeah
look I mean that game had to play C5
right you have to kicking and scream
right now and hope for the best maybe
she will miss Rook C1 maybe she's going
to take a step back with Knight to D3
and then you will get your chances but
you have to you have to do something the
position is just impossible objectively
but uh well when you also take into
account the clock situation there is a
margin yeah
that begum looked disappointed when she
saw that move she's uh kind of faded a
little bit backwards she recognizes
these lines with Knight D7 definitely
favored Naji let me uh jump uh to the
Lavon versus
um
Dominguez
Dominguez I refreshed the board because
I thought wow for sure they had played
some moves but they really have not
played that many moves at all uh Bishop
E1 King D7 and this is what I was
thinking that you're ready to get oh
there is Bishop f8
hey
hey check that out finally okay there's
a very serious threat Bishop to F A he
went for it
what did the one could have traded on
I think Lavon was
Lavon was perhaps fearful that in this
particular case the bishop would be
stranded so C6 immediately came so
he could have played C6 but that's a
bishops of opposite color Bishop F2
Bishop f8 C6 Knight here or you know I
should
Jesus sorry to panic right you can go G6
you can go G5 I don't know panicking has
a lot to be said for so can we can now
go A5
A5 right I want to put a knight on C2 so
that then I can go G6 yeah and then G5
is going to come with tremendous
consequences okay so the G5 A5 he's
gonna go G6 and he's going to try to
lure me
uh into a blundering with F6 so he can
go G5 instead I will disappoint him
because two are playing this game thank
you very much thank you very much
how will I annoy him
not easy uh
what about A4 can you do that
with Trembling Hands no no no yeah I
kind of wanted to make another but you
can get you can use the idea of a
he has played G6 oh he didn't play A5
but I think it's coming he well the
night got uh pushed to the A6 Square so
just a second right here he could have
played A5 Knight C2 he played G6
immediately Knight went to A6 so that
you can come back with the bishop and
takes takes were up to
date with the players and Bishop C5 I
think is what's on uh Lanier's agenda
King back clever move by the way Bishop
C5 can be met with King B7 and that
Bishops of opposite color
I don't believe yeah that that looks too
dry
yeah he's he's just too close
he's just too close to finish it right
now
so Bishop to C5 right it's almost forced
well you know
is there any way of
making an incursion into the king side
where one day E6 might work if as soon
as you move your king he's played Bishop
to C5 okay I'm expecting King B7 yeah
but uh you know every time you kind of
release the guard from
D4 I'm going to put the bishop on D4
correct and then the Knight can come
back to C5 I like I love that and you
know what the problem is after a king to
B7 you take on F2 I take on A6 even if
you manage to get on F6 and take on F7
and force me to give away my Bishop yeah
all I have to do is just change one of
my pawns for the B2 Pawn exactly and
that's a draw that's that's the problem
I think it's that easy that the threat
of B4 followed by C3 and trading one
Pawn that's all you need is to get rid
of that B2 Pawn to make a draw and that
also presupposes that you're not uh
you're actually winning the bishop
you're forcing the victory of the bishop
uh by getting your king
to F7
and it's not a given that
the bishop wants uh
well won't blockade on E6 so we are in
this current position Let me refresh the
board sorry so that Bishop C5 is on the
board and we're we're considering King
B7 as perhaps the
way of securing a draw
and we were fearful that if if Devon
were to allow Bishop D4 Knight C5 kind
of constructions then linear could win
they weren't now taking a pause which is
unusual for him because he has been
blitzing out the moves
yeah he he just has shown a fantastic
familiarity with these Berlin endings I
I
I'm staggered by uh his his
understanding I mean preparation is one
thing but this is a very very
yeah he's really good in this end games
yeah Sam Shanklin was able to put
pressure against Ray Robson right Lanier
cannot touch Levon in this one no
and let's go to beg him sure versus Nazi
because that one
it's not looking good still for black
but it's probably looking the best
for the last compared to like anything
in the last 20 minutes
yeah because at least there's some
imbalance in the position oh okay so
when we left it we'd seen
um oops talk talk oh she
oh she played she didn't capture on C5
no and played Rook C1 she played Rook C1
immediately
and
now
we're in a completely different
setup
still white seems to be doing very very
well but but there's uh and by the way
H6 was not the most precise
movement that she had to stop that with
a movable E8 first yeah right because
now that Bishop coming to E4 that Bishop
is going to be very nicely placed
the black king
it's lacking Defenders exactly you mean
something like Knight takes E4 Bishop
takes E4 rookie eight Excuse Me
Maybe yeah yeah yeah I can see that
you're really you you like the
initiative I mean that you when I'm
commenting actually I really love the
initiative I like to just throw the
pieces I'm like
someone's King right but uh in reality
and over the board chess
you seize the defensive when possible
you have to take that night right now
and queen G4
and just remind everybody yeah because
uh we are at a critical stage here in
the elimination bracket najibaikitsi has
taken a lead with her first game Victory
and Turkish universe is in a must-win
situation playing with the black pieces
whoever loses the match is out is out
and the winner will go on and play the
runner-up of today's match between Alice
and Irina tomorrow exactly there won't
be any classical games tomorrow there'll
be a an elimination bracket uh
tournament going on and in the open
section yes
exactly the same situation and the two
are really mirroring each other
levonaronian has seized the advantage by
winning the first game today and Lenny
Dominguez playing with the white pieces
isn't a must win situation and is
exactly the same as yasa says whoever
wins today will now face the runner-up
of the Champions bracket of Wesley and
Hikaru as they are tied and they'll be
playing a playoff well at 5 30 I believe
our time is when that match will begin
94 on the board I Dare I ask can I take
the pawn
Knight takes D5 is there a complete is
there a horrifyingly good refutation to
that one she didn't she took on e4
um
she did take on e4 I see she took 24
Bishop takes E4 rookie eight and now we
have Queen G4 on the board and Bishop to
f8 that's a bit of a positive Queen well
she's defending H6 can't blame her for
that one yes but it allows this move B4
isn't that just really bad for uh for
black right now yes it is
yes it is that's
you're using your research the bishop fa
to defend on G7 but
now is also attacked uh that's a dream
for white I mean in fact when you think
about it uh there's a heavy amount of
concentrated white forces against C5 and
no this this is great stuff from
technology this is great clinical no
she's she's cruising here that was uh
this pin on on on this diagonal or the
A7 you know again if we just go back for
a moment you could see that rookie 8
Bishop f8 B4 was going to cost you the
game I mean sometimes you just say hey
look I we go ahead show me how I lose
and I I don't doubt that there's a
winning line here but sometimes
yeah sometimes you have to go for it but
uh because it's a difficult well because
well in this case I would actually find
it really easy to play the move Knight
D5 and lose that way because this way
oops excuse me what we see in the game
uh it's just too too easy it's just too
simple for uh Naji she's taken played
Queen G4 and played the move B4
and uh she's got a winning position with
uh no problems and she has more time on
the clock with Knight takes D5 I would
have put a little pressure on white and
said show me how you're going to get me
yeah I'm begging him down to her last
two minutes reaching for the h bar H5
uh certainly I don't have to capture and
hang the bishop
um I felt the queen back to F3 yeah
maybe Queen F4 they're I'm not too sure
if there's reasons that you might want
your queen on F4 or queen on F3
I told you about when to move the king
to the opposite color of the queen in
this case there are no rules if I hang
on a second the black king is on the
light Square move it to a light Square
and the problem with queen of four is
that Queen D6 may be coming and then you
have some problems with the bishop
E4 okay so Queen F3 uh
the training
it works for Naji it works for Jovi
everybody happy maybe Queen F3 G6 to try
to
clothes shop on that side
the pawn on C4 will drop right the
vultures will all jump on that pawn
that's okay but yeah I mean I have
enough Defenders right at least for the
moment do you I think so Knight takes C5
yeah she's done it yeah I mean what
happened
Knight takes
C5 I take it take it it didn't take it
yes yes okay so now we've
we're we're all so uh prim and proper
give me one more move yes I know I know
I'm not going to give you that move
though
um I'm just trying to go Queen D6 I'm
trying to play D6 I was trying to play
Bishop takes G6 you're trying to we've
all got our ideas we got our agendas but
yeah yeah uh but doesn't why didn't D6
work tell me something before you go D7
height Rook d8 Rook d8 I have to okay
queen size Bishop but now I have Queen
C6 which defends both E8 and gets me out
of the uh
that's so fast my young Buckaroo wow bad
position yes tactics seem to always work
from good positions the tactics flow
nicely from good positions jeez whoa
that's aggressive G6 G4 that is
aggressive wow
okay
didn't see that one no I didn't see that
when I was purely focused on the pen but
I could G4 wow it makes a lot of sense
right because that pin is so unpleasant
and it's so difficult to get rid of like
how do you get out of that pin I don't
have to take on C5 no reason for that no
reason to hurry
I like this move G4 okay but you can
just simply take the pawn that's what I
would do and after Queen takes move my I
can't go Bishop G7
him down to her last minute right now
with a very difficult position almost
unplayable position G4
well I mean there's one threat in the
position F5 right and G4 does put the
kibosh on that threat and there goes hg4
Queen takes G4
by the way I really like naji's she's
playing very very practically she's
playing quickly she's making solid good
good decisions good decisions yeah and I
don't know has she made any mistakes in
this game no no mistakes I mean you know
when you're in a must-win game and your
opponent doesn't make any mistakes
I mean what are you supposed to do
she's played very well I have to say
we've been a bit unfair to to uh beg him
because she has had her hands tied
behind her back her back right lines
that she wanted to play would have ended
in the result she can't do because she's
in a must-win situation and Rook season
recognizing she's in this predicament
where she's stuck uh this this pin of
the bishop on E3 is really really
awkward
yeah so it looks like we won't see any
playoffs in the Elimination Brackets
yeah we're just a draw she will advance
so I agree and in this position after
playing a move like G4 well I'm pretty
easy to Guess that she'd probably want
to follow it up with H4 maybe just
trying to break open Black's King with
25 seconds for vegan to defend not nice
I like the last one do I have some ideas
though Rook to C7 so yeah I have a trick
in the position if you do go H4 yep
maybe I can try to go Bishop to see it
Bishop to C8 yes okay and I have to drop
whoa now she's uh now she's clarified
matters with the move takes on
C5
oh because now D6
okay you have to take back
presumably we're going to sacrifice in
exchange a sham sacrifice it's only a
temporary one
can you exchange everything and take on
G6
would that at least make a draw that's
how that's all we want too I love that
what you just said maybe even knows
Bishop takes G6 Rook takes C3 perhaps
yes but Bishop takes C5 what you wanted
and now just take
and that's your Perpetual right there
you cannot take back you have to go king
of Faith but yeah but then you might as
well just she might be going for it guys
yeah that's the practical way out in
this position again great decision
making by inazia she's uh just securing
the job
yep and yes she's going for the rights
and it looks like it's
this is not the only game that's going
to finish and draw lenia Dominguez and
lemon aronian also looks to be headed
straight to the draw and lenia Dominguez
is in a must win situation
therefore live on a rodent will go
through
and the players are catching up to our
uh position at hand where we reckon
Bishop takes G6 which he's done she went
for it wow
I mean look sometimes you just gotta tip
your head mauji's played a very very
good
match yeah very good match very good
game right she did not give her opponent
any sort of practical chances no and
Bishop takes F7 check by the way you
know you can go King f8 but I play
Bishop takes F7 I'm pretty sure I'm
getting my Perpetual if not even more
and she's gone King f8 and I'm thinking
Bishop takes F7
uh keeps it
yeah yeah but I mean absolutely yeah
he's forcing her way through right
because if you do capture and I go check
on F5
four three two one I can just captured
and I have to check on F5 a king to E7
will walk into D6
and that's oops that's that's gone so
you have to go but this looks like oh
King d8 right
the queen on C5 is hanging oh the queen
on C5
two seconds you have to go to G5 and
this was the Perpetual that I was
thinking Queen G5
and uh no Escape
and uh wow
very good player from Nazi absolutely
just to see those sacrifices at the end
to come up with G4 ideas five four three
elimination
but it doesn't matter okay but now she
can simply go D6 D6 check
this is and you could Harbor some hopes
if you maintain the pawn on B5
but you don't even keep that by the way
we do have a result Lavon Drew there's a
queen
that's it he moves on
and our congratulations uh to uh Naji a
very very impressive uh elimination
finalist can I find it yes can I say
that properly now uh she gets herself in
uh in the next round as does Lavon uh
Lavon got knocked out in the classical
by linear and the very first I was going
to return the favor yes I know he's done
exactly the same just like in 2022. a
remarkable uh as uh
I think you had called it some time ago
Christian that all levana had to do was
give up his Bishop yep and in this
ending if he can get rid of this B2 Pawn
you can't win the game with bishop and
Apon and he did it and that was exactly
what Lavon played for all the way right
here and he knew at this moment that the
draw secured all he's got to do is put
his King into the corner and you can
never get it out when I first discovered
that this was a draw the bishop and a
bishop and pawn versus the lone King was
a draw I thought that chess was a draw
because from the opening move the
opening move isn't worth a bishop in a
pawn right and so yeah that was uh let
me me tell you something please but you
can Queen a pawn
you can you can clean the pawn from that
position we can win a lot of Bets with
that expression uh show us some brackets
and uh yeah they're still struggling I
mean my mind is
it overdrived and good we see the arena
crash and Alice Lee are playing final
game in the classical portion they're
still at work definitely and everything
to play for but it's an elimination
bracket where everything has been
clarified
will be waiting in the elimination
bracket final four the loser between
Alice Lee and Irina Crush
and in the open section there we can see
the Champions bracket and it is going to
be a playoff between Hikaru Nakamura and
Wesley so and whoever loses will fall
down to the elimination bracket and
they're waiting for them with open arm
is none other than Levon aronian exactly
he's looking very uh happily at the
playoff coming up between Wesley and
Hikaru and in the one game remaining in
the classical game uh Arena Crush as we
suspected as clarified the situation to
her own advantage and this last move
Alice Lee just played pardon me after B6
Alice had just played the move Rook to
to
um C4 hoping to activate her Rook by
Rook to C4 followed by Rook C6 or Rook
C7 Irena said no no no no you're the one
with split pawns on the queen side let
me play the move Rook C5 if I could get
if Alice were to play either Rook B3 or
C4
I suspect she's really close to losing
okay C4 she did play safe I I thought
that she might have been forced actually
to play the move Rook too
I give you a check and then you hide the
King on it and you want the counter
player by going I do uh uh I I hate
playing these rook and Pawn in games
passively myself and I'm just thinking
that if you look at the position and
evaluate you know the way the Rooks on a
scale this Rook on B4 is really
ugly versus this Rook on C5 so I'm gonna
go King King King King A5 right and
drive The Rook away but I'm going to get
my king exactly the white king is also
where's the center as well okay so let's
see let's count them
yes you can get three yes King D4 ah you
make it just in the nick of time that
you're you can release your Rook okay
then it's not that scary what about if
you Max what I would be worried about is
if I were to maximize the road because I
first of all go Rook a five and then
Rook a yep but you do have no I have C5
no I see if C5 is a yeah but how is this
end game I would rather keep the Rooks
in their current uh how do you say
standoff position maybe G5
G3 okay and then bring my king up
let's say I mash that King G2 right
okay I stay I wait
okay how do you wait King F3 let's see
okay cool I like it the last day of the
song whatever you can do I can do better
I can do everything better than you no
you can't yes I can
King H5 how do you wait
you can wait for the Rook
oh no I can get oh if I wait with a rook
just to kind of put it out if I go Rook
A4 oops A5 and that is the most
embarrassed Rook uh you've seen in a
long time don't
but while we struggle to understand
who's if Arena can win or not we have a
guess with Christian in studio lavoni
didn't have much time to think about it
after yesterday's roller coaster against
Fabiano but what was the strategy going
into today's match
um try to avoid what happened yesterday
yesterday was a bit too crazy for your
taste yeah
and tell us about the first game because
that's when you took full Reigns of this
match
yeah so I knew there is this idea with
the pawn sacrifice
but honestly today I think I spent maybe
yeah
at least two hours walking around the
park I was I thought to myself I
shouldn't really prepare I just need to
you know
so
I mean of course uh black can play like
this and there's nothing wrong with it
but white has no risk so it's type of a
play I wanted to get you know type of
technical play and then yeah I thought
this was more or less logical
uh I thought 92 was a good move because
I'm trying this Knight C4
or Knight B3 things you know because it
doesn't really belong to E4 yeah yeah it
can get kicked away with that fight yeah
things like that I mean in this type of
uh
things if you manage to restrict the the
monster on B7 then you'll be better but
uh
of course it's not that easy and that
felt like it was the battle for a very
long time right he was trying to open
things up with G5 H5
were you getting worried at this point
that this monster as you painted it
might actually get open yeah well I I
calculated here but you can never be
sure I I was I was not really sure I
thought Bishop H6 was not the right move
I thought Bishop G7 was more precise I
thought black has a full compensation
because Knight C1 rookie 6
and I has a stroke H6 I I will be forced
to play Bishop before anyway and then he
can just play Rook G6 c62 Queen H3 this
type of things you know yeah he won't
let me get out once I got all got out I
thought that I got some Chances with the
Knight on G3 yes yeah although later I
think I almost planted my knight at 95
at some point at one point uh well when
uh yeah when we did this G3 Bishop is
seven rookie two can get fate yeah my
first intention was to play something
like
I wanted to play Bishop somewhere like
Bishop E5 but then I saw Bishop F3 Rook
G5 and
yeah H2 and Rook G5 yeah yeah this would
have been horrendous
yeah and uh so I thought okay I gotta
stay focused
physician is drawish of course after
Bishop E5
uh I thought he had this rookie sixth
move
and what about wait a minute what about
negative six this move now you have
Knight F6 okay okay Knight to D7 you
cannot touch this yeah yeah this is my
chipper well prepared chipper yeah I was
actually
yeah instead of Bishop G5 I mean he was
down on time but I think he has rookie
six here
and let's see and black is oh yeah my
goodness yeah better yeah actually
blonde like this so now if you take the
problem is you take the yeah take take
and even the night is nothing so rukesh
2 was probably a blunder or
you know yeah yeah here's somewhere I
started blundering yeah I felt it
that's a difficult move to make right
yeah I knew already I've missed my
chances here but uh so Bishop E5 was
kind of I thought it's a clever idea but
then I saw rookie six my God yeah rookie
six was a big one yes I got really lucky
here and here is probably a draw
actually
I felt like it's so active he shouldn't
be losing this
but you still manage to create more and
more problems for your opponent okay he
was done on time so yeah
trying to utilize that did you feel like
this is the factor that made the most
difference just the fact that he wasn't
able to catch up on time with you
maybe maybe definitely if they had more
time he would Syracuse well during the
finals right now uh were you watching
the finals of the elimination bracket oh
yeah I mean were you watching this game
between Wesley and Hikaru and who do you
expect to join you I don't really care
I'm you know I survived yesterday so now
all of this is just a bonus yes guys
join the conversation yeah first of all
congratulations for moving on Lavon I'd
like to turn your attention to the game
between Alice Lee and Arena Crush you're
a great end game player as he throws him
a bone uh tell us uh what you feel is
the proper result in this particular
Rook ending uh Christian could you put
it on your board please so that uh Lavon
can see the current position yes okay
well it looks rather unpleasant here the
king comes to H5 and then
uh then The Rook will uh enter on the G
file I mean
I mean it's very unpleasant for white so
this should be the plan King G6 King H5
tried to keep the king to the defense of
those squares yeah because if you bring
the king to the other side I'll bring
mine to the other side yes and then I'll
get rugby three Rook H3 yeah
and then you have some problems so you
have to really quickly uh get to this uh
we should she just played King 2 G6 and
by the way Alice is only yeah with two
minutes on her clock okay so you get
your idea with King H5 yeah what happens
here
this is a big problem I cannot go work
the way before because of A5 and my root
gets pretty much trapped
um
so I stay I wait all right I give you a
check
let's see I stay close to my F Pawn all
right now I can play Rook d8 or I can
also
try to enter from yeah English for is
actually not that stupid
[Laughter]
be careful
nice okay well thank you for thank you
for that uh
I believe you're right that this whole
way I wanted to get your Insight I liked
what you're saying King H5 Rook G8 for
arena and Alice with a minute on her
clock is in trouble again Lavon thank
you very much for taking my job and
anytime we've got a warm seat now I
admire you yes sir I really admire that
you can talk I mean and make sense for
so many hours in a row I mean I cannot
do that so I would never dream of taking
your job not at all good luck in the
next uh next match it's going to be very
exciting one tomorrow and uh one minute
for Alice did I hear you say that she's
under oh
now she's at 120 but 23 minutes for and
she's played the move A4 no I I really
like Christine's approach or just
waiting with the King but it requires a
lot of goth
because you know he managed to get
active with his Rook with his very nice
idea right but if you go A4 you're just
taking away another active possibility
from the white Rook exactly so
um but okay all right in Alice's defense
if I can say that I mean she's thinking
that this Rook is ready to come over to
the G file and she's got to be ready to
play either A5 or C5 right in order to
activate her Rook if she wants to uh
stay in this game but
so it was tough it was a just the the
difficult choice but uh Christian we
have a another uh qualifier shall we say
that's right Nazi you're not pulling any
punches with your opening preparation
you try D4 C5 against Alice Lee a very
enterprising approach now you started
off with the touch how did you come up
with this idea were you trying to put as
much pressure with the black pieces
early on uh yes and actually I got lucky
again with the preparation I predicted
she was gonna play Knight F3 even though
she plays E4 D4 C4 Knight F3 like all of
them so instead of preparing for
everything I only prepared against
Knight F3 and then she played it so it
worked out uh I think I got a decent
position I'm not sure if I played it all
correctly but
even though like I guess the prep I'm
not used to playing this so I definitely
wasn't sure that
what I was doing was all correct and it
seemed like it was
pretty correct right I mean you both
were playing good moves at this point
just her expanding on the queen side you
trying to get an attack going on the
king side was that the plan or were you
trying to strike in the center I was
hoping for eventually playing G5 and F4
is
that it got pretty
pretty coincide she gave me
some tactical Chances with that B5 move
that I played yes that was a very nice
move and she did have this idea of
sacrificing the queen did you see I saw
it and I was afraid of it because
she only has a rook and a pawn or two
for it
but I couldn't evaluate this position at
all and I think if this was second game
where she needed a win she would have
definitely gone for it yes yeah
after she played this move Knight to B2
it just felt like you're getting too
much play on this after this I'm much
better
it felt pretty easy and it was this big
moment after d takes C5 nicely spotted
this queen takes D2 were you
anticipating this when you played the
move Rook to A3 uh no so her Presence at
that I spent a lot of time before I
played through K3 because when I first
calculated it after d takes C I didn't
say 22.
so I was going to play something else
and then I double checked one back to
Rook A3 and immediately spotted Queen D2
and then I thought there's no way she's
gonna take on C5 so I was expecting
Queen C2
and here I can just take Queen takes D4
and I don't know what she's gonna do
with the Knight on B2 probably go back
to A4 and I'm just much better I just
have to be careful about the C6 Pawn but
for a moment at least that promotion
square is pretty much guarded uh very
nicely by the Knight only seven and the
26. that was game one and after
that in game two it felt like you were
able to neutralize any sort of counter
play from her side it felt very smooth
how would you assess yeah I was actually
surprised by her opening choice I
thought she was gonna play something
more aggressive since she needed a win
um my guess is she may be prepared
against the game I played against Donna
where I played sixth move Queen C2 so
this time I changed it up and played
Knight C3 and I think I was never worse
and at the very end I think she just
plundered the queen or she would have
taken the tour of course yeah absolutely
Nazi congratulations you're going to be
waiting for either Irina or Alice Lee
actually let's go to that end game yes
or maybe we can pull it on your shirt
board and ask for Nazi's opinion on it
the last few moves were actually here
Rook C7 by Arena so she wanted to come
Rook Shack and invade either with a
Rooker or King so after Rook C7 A5 ba5
Rook A4 we're up to date with the
players how do you feel uh black chances
to get the victory in this one hour so
Irina is the only one pressing right and
she has a huge time Advantage yes I
would say she has a chance
and how would you go about it Rook to D7
or
maybe Rook to D7 right along with D3
because Rook D3 if I can get my king on
G4 then that's my better
right so you want to put the king all
the way to H3 yes sir it's nice yeah so
that you could get something like this
this is getting Rook takes a second
Maybe
King F1
King takes a four maybe
this does look good for black yeah yeah
yeah
no it looks like black if
she manages to take that pawn on E5 this
is not looking promising
plus with only one minute on the clock
for white definitely easy to make a
mistake absolutely well still this one
is still ongoing Alice is still fighting
for a draw Nazi congratulations we'll
see you tomorrow thank you our
congratulations as well are very very
nicely played a match and what I
especially impressed by was her control
throughout I mean both the white and
black game she seemed to be enjoying
herself I know the way you're putting it
bear in mind she she said it there in
the interview she had never really
played this Dutch defense at all she
just simply prepared it that morning
right very intensively and then she went
and inspired yeah exactly and and in
this game uh what's your we during the
interviews you and I have been been
fencing a little bit and uh how do you
how did you feel that uh our little uh
um duels we're doing do you like uh
Arenas I I I thought yes Arena
definitely has chances to push for a
victory but I feel it's very very
critical that you don't get swayed by
winning the A7 pawn and instead you go
for the E6 Pawn okay because that was
where we were at yeah that was about it
yeah this idea that after you capture
and Shaq it all looks really really good
the one thing that you can't allow
basically was King takes F4 and King
takes E5 then you're gone and it's it's
incumbent upon you to forget about the
A7 Pawn but to make absolutely sure that
you get the E6 Pawn uh after King takes
F4 right so we've got as far as this and
then yes it's still black for choice we
had to stop ourselves from from going
full hog into the position but clearly
you know black is the one one dictating
and
Alice but even then we have we'll have a
situation say if for instance white wins
the A7 Pawn black manages to win the
e-pawn and and seapoon I mean this is
uh yeah I'm not sure if we can get all
of that good stuff going but I hear you
the one thing I'd also like to just say
is like somehow with this King on F1 uh
you you might end up
you're playing for uh not not to take
the pawn on H2 pardon me
but to play for me yes precisely right
how did we get that a moment ago Rook
takes A5 Rook D3 check and you know not
this move that was the move that we were
critical of and here can we play for
mate somehow
sure yeah yeah for instance
you could give a check
yeah I'm
no I I'll tell you what I'm playing for
it takes
and now
okay
I will but I I haven't won the e-pawn
yet no you haven't yet
yes exactly and I haven't won the e-pawn
yet no that's not but I still even then
you're still using the e-pawn as a
shield yes again so say for instance you
go there yes you go E3 Rook check yes oh
but are you going to hide your King on
H3 not to F not F1 because that's the
setup that I'm playing for King to H3
and now I have to probably go back with
no this is not what I had intended when
I went for this uh
Rook takes A5 Rook take Rook B7 is I was
thinking that
if you put the King on H3 the king would
be forced to go to G2 yeah and uh okay
let me just sorry I'm going to refresh
my board
and it's all about that okay six move
right now she needs to find through k6 I
think if she does she's going to be out
of the woods that's the key moment right
there Rook takes A7 and perhaps this is
why she played Rook B3 so that she can
go rupee six is that an idea ah
okay six Rook B6 wait a minute
wait a minute this is not easy
key moment with just a minute and a half
oh Irina is tricky you know super tricky
she's laying all kinds of traps for
Alice In This Moment uh
I'm thinking Rook A6 you're thinking
Rook A6
[Music]
B6 and then Rook A4 so that whenever you
take on F4 I have C oh Rook A6 Rook B6
Rook A4 sorry and that hits the Rook on
B6 that is that is cute by the way wow
Rook A6 Alice that's some sort of like
this is not over yet
I mean well Rook A4 is an easier to move
to find than Rook A6 because every
instinct tells you grab the pawns and
Rook upon in game and that was a very
important move
uh
stop King takes F4 King takes E5 Rook A6
and by the way after Rook B6 through K4
I think Irena will have so so if I'm in
Arena shoes I'm looking at King King F4
and Rook B2 I'm also looking at check
right
and again my instinct in these endings
is to grab as many pawns as I can as
quickly as I can right I don't think
this can ever be winning though I just
go
King to F2 King the F2 so I've got my
extra Pawn to A6 Rook to A6 your Rook is
ideal at H3 if I want that all h3e I
might even give you that pawn but maybe
okay maybe I shouldn't do that that's a
bit too much you make me happy I'll go
H3 after Rook A4
Rook A4
and we do have a guaranteed playoff
coming up yep
it's coming up in around about half an
hour and we see it is Wesley so he'll
begin with the white pieces against
Hikaru Nakamura I think it's you versus
me I do believe they do
as your choice to win the event I had
Wesley exactly so I feel like I've got
real skin in the game
right beef in the fight there we go it's
getting in the game piece of the fight
okay all right
um okay uh the current position let me
go back to it as I repeat and uh
well we should get ourselves ready
geared up uh for the playoff as well we
might want to take a short break as a
great idea yeah and uh Rook B3 Rook A6
so a key moment we're gonna leave you
with as playoffs coming up and another
uh great match in store definitely I see
you on the other side
foreign
[Music]
St Louis is back with nine major
tournaments throughout the year it all
kicks off in March with the second
edition of the American cup with 16
players across two Fields fighting for a
300 thousand dollar prize fund in this
double elimination tournament with both
classical and Rapid time controls for
the first time since 2020 the Cairns cup
is Back featuring the world's best
female chess players competing for a 180
000 prize fund beginning June 3rd
seasonal Classic Events are back
starting with the spring chess Classic
on April 5th the summer chess classic
August 2nd followed up with the St Louis
Norm Invitational and the winter chess
classic wraps up the year in December
September brings back everyone's
favorite chest night on legs where some
of the world's best don't even know
what's coming and compete for a 150 000
prize fund 3
across three Fields come together in St
Louis for the U.S juniors girls and
Senior championships starting July 15th
in partnership with U.S chess the best
in the U.S fight to be the nation's best
and a four hundred thousand dollar prize
fund in October as the U.S and U.S
women's championships takes place in the
chess capital of America a year full of
action-packed Chess is just getting
started all broadcasts are available on
our St Louis chess club YouTube and
twitch.tv channels
[Music]
the muni's premier season bursting with
comedies romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
we are back and it's been a very
exciting day already on the day six of
the American Cup I eliminated we have
two eliminated players already I know we
have two eliminated players already we
know who's going to be in the finals in
the elimination bracket
one playoff game coming so far and uh
well still won Champions champions
bracket game remaining and here we see
it it's been an Almighty battle between
Arena crash and Alice Lee and they are
still playing their classical game hard
at work indeed and in the elimination an
elimination bracket it has been decided
the winner
she will be facing the loser of the
match between Arena crash and Alice Lee
and in the Champions Brett and the
Champions bracket once again this
nothing has been decided here it is a
big epic match between Hikaru Nakamura
and Wesley so but this will all be
decided in the tie breaks in roughly 20
minutes these guys are gonna start
playing two games of an accelerated
rapid which is 10 minutes plus five
seconds and whoever loses these tie
breaks well they go down and look who is
waiting the none other than Levon
aronian he will be welcoming the loser
with open arms and again ready to play
off for the Grand Final
and this one is absolutely guaranteed
the playoffs will begin at 5 30 roughly
20 minutes and they will play two games
of 10 minutes plus 5 seconds per move to
get the playoffs underway exactly and we
have to remember you know this isn't the
only tiebreaker because if the match is
still tied it goes down to Blitz or
three minutes plus two seconds yes and
then finally after all of this we get
again if the match is still tied let's
jump into the remaining uh classical
game that's going on Alice Lee she's
down to a minute but boy I've got to say
I'm not a big fan
at all of what Irina has done she's
essentially well maybe it's not that bad
after I just saw the last move she
essentially
drove Alice's King to what I thought was
a really good Square the Central Square
in the middle of the board she didn't go
for any of these lines that I was uh
playing myself Rook E4 Rook takes F4 you
know grab as many pawns and hope that
what's remaining is enough to win she
had played Rook B6 Rook A6 check and
this is what I meant by driving the king
to D4 I mean the lines we were looking
at the King was on F1 and things like
this but okay she won the pawn on F4
excuse me from Alice by the way C5 right
because if she hadn't done that black
was actually threatening to come Rook B1
and get a check I'm still like confused
if if Alice had played this Arena would
have I presumed like this check but the
king takes the pawn and then I come back
and I'm thinking the C Pawn
is huge I play but also those
are also quite huge effort are they like
I don't know they look scary to me
checking is F5 okay step back delay the
inevitable okay
and again keep going yeah
yeah but here you can even go could you
rain on White's parade and actually take
66. I mean okay aren't I threatening
rookie eight
I'm I'm I was thinking that the sea Pawn
was great but which Pawn is faster is
the question at that point
I can go F3 as one so I have the same
rank as you so F3 as well yeah I'm on a
third rank you're on the sixth rank what
kind of
the same spot
and
hmm okay didn't happen what did happen
instead I'm just again I'm seeing this
ending for the first time she did not
play this after rip she went Rook Rook
rook and she's still playing for the C6
and Rook D7 business
looks
scary what's going on that's a few moves
if you go back a few moves what you
could have done
um after C6 you had the right instinct
C6 was indeed the best move okay six
but the follow-up has to be after Rook
to C7
a rook to C4 defend that pawn on C6
right
and prepare
not yet
what I'm preparing is Rook to C1 give
you a check on F1 then you cannot take
my E5 pawn and then I run with the King
gotcha so now the only move to make a
draw in the position the only move to
make a draw for black black is worse
Black is worse wow on the brink of
defeat yes see what I was saying I
didn't like what uh Arena had done
before something would have been no the
proposition is the only way the problem
is that this is coming with a tempo as
soon as I play Rook to see F1 check
drive the king away from the e-pawn
comes with Tempo so yeah The Rook C8 was
set up to and then you have to calculate
those positions in which you sacrifice
the rook and you get two pawns and who
knows what's happening right oh my but
that didn't happen what did happen was
instead was rookie 7 Rook D6 and still
Alice is threatening the C6 kind of
stuff what's going on in this position
Christian objectively this one is a draw
object equal objectively yes but that's
because I have on the engine there's
players don't have the address okay so
let's say I go A5
which it this happened
okay now I'm threatening Rook D7 you
have to be a little bit careful right
so if I step away from I'm assuming
you're taking this Pawn well
perhaps you can still go A4 right A4
Rook D7 rookie yes but this is wow I'm
feeling this is double edged it is I
mean I can lose it with black here okay
and
on A4 A4 is on on the board how do we
continue right now
so do we go Rook to D7 or do we have
anything better I think you have to go
57 and then yeah okay seven
I've got real case
Rick A7 okay let's try it shall we
Rook check
ing out the board presumably presumably
King takes porn right and this is the
race that these are the races that we
had been looking at a moment ago which
aren't that bad for
black so who's winning that race okay I
go here you go here yes I go here you go
here I'll take the pawn check
I'm not sure if I want to bring your
king closer I think I I want to take the
pawn first right and she's played with
the D7 okay one thing that you this is
uh sorry I just wanted to say is the
current position I don't think why I
should play C7 in this particular
position okay so rookie eight
Rook A7
check I
assumed that you wanted to play King C5
oh yeah but I have a question do you
need to give the check
why can't you go Rook to C7
to C8 yes after okay seven
no you don't need to give a check that's
true okay that feels like that feels
like a winning a Tempo I agree
okay so I take only five you take on a
four wow
and who knows how this how this is this
is a race guys
is a is a very very good move uh right
here Rook C8
should I have played
not King D should I have played C7
you can place the seven if you want yeah
right maybe you would play A3 I would go
King C5 yes
yes
this is tough stuff all right let's try
things
I also have H5 well H5 H4
right but it says A3 is kind of
oh you just want to go A2 well yeah I
was using the Palm as a decoy so that I
could see yes and she's done the crucial
move Rook C8
okay let's try to put it move by move
okay you go C7 I go A3 okay you go King
C5 now you have to go King C5 I do I
do what do you start with F4 let's push
to the pawn right
this is this is the kind of key kind of
thing because sometimes you you should
be pushing with the e-born like the ones
right that's behind so king of I I
understand if you want to play King F4
and she has played C7 but let's just
keep going all the way until the end
yeah I think f-pawn looks decent yeah at
some point I would have to take but
let's assume that I go King to D7 first
okay I'm not gonna play any Waiting
Games gift me The Rook yes
and then I will play F3 oh I take
and I will play King to E4 now I go King
D6 uh my database just pardon me my
table base just popped up winning
winning for for who
for Alice
wow so this is
if you advance with it
A3 was a blunder according to the engine
oh my what did she have to play H5
[Applause]
what is this well that's what I was
saying is Arena I mean Arena's misplayed
this
the how that King got to D4 and became
an active King was
is Alice finishing the match right here
right now that would be remarkable I
mean the strangest thing about this
tournament is the whole groundhog
repetitive Deja Vu that we but this is
bouja Day none of this has ever happened
before Alice didn't win the match last
year
she was relegated to the elimination
Irina was not yes Arena could be losing
this game uh by over pressing her hand
she has she has indeed she really has
overpressed her head
wow so let's keep going let's finish
that variation then let's do it F4 King
D7 we traded F3 Rook takes King D4 or
King F4 that's King F4
and then we play where's the win
where's the wind so you went to the
right Square so King goes to oh King E4
was the losing move King F4 is
apparently a drawing move
um
okay
yeah
um and if Alice does win being told that
this would be the first time yeah we we
saw those match-up scores they were very
uh lopsided after all 13 years old of
course Arena had defeated uh Alice last
year when she was 12. so this is still
not over no King F4 is apparently the
only okay so this is the current
position yes and check this out the idea
is
right now after F4 you have to take on
A3 first which forces the king to go to
ifo First ah and then you go King D7
Rook takes A3
King E4 now it's winning that's right
King D7 Rook takes King takes and after
F3
King 26 I would assume
well apparently there's three winning
moves King D6 Rook A1 and H4 are all
winning moves she took on A3
Rook takes A3 only move
wow and so the most natural move is
actually just in in our position to say
King dd6 well it yes uh well Rook takes
A3 Alice played it with a minute and 30
on our clock and this is the problem we
have to play King E4 now all right can I
try some please King D4 King D7 King E4
King D7 yes I'm going to try to hide the
Rook go to G8 or h8 let's say G yeah
okay G8 is fine and let's say I go Queen
but now I think this is
F3 you can go Rook B3
after
the oh no hang on a second
check my bad yeah you you're gonna have
to win The Rook now or sometime so uh
okay Rook h8 Queen yep okay I take and
we recapture of course take back now I
go F3 once again and at least you don't
have King D6 I don't know if it helps me
ah but it's it's an idea exactly and now
the table base says drawn now he says
draw okay yeah so you don't you can't
capture on C7
so but can we show the losing line
please which is the loser which is the
the losing line was if you just pushed
the pawn immediately if we captured the
pawn immediately it's the losing life
yes let's let's do it takes takes F3
let's play
his natural move on the board exactly
and now f 2 F2 we have to go Rook A1
makes a lot of sense King F3 for example
or King E3 and what happens if you try
to preserve your Pawn
E5
I will go okay so only move okay
how about that how do you like them
apples King F4
and apparently this is all
the the way you're supposed to win it's
a super long line but it's a Superman
easy is it to find age for none of these
moves come easily frankly I mean and the
this the the idea that Rook takes C7 is
losing whereas Rook h8 is drawn that's
already well that kind of makes tempo
right that makes sense because you drive
the white king first C8 right
so I just
but to see that H4
is is winning yes that's difficult I
think
no question about it Rook takes A3 and
again we're we're anticipating the move
King E4 King D7 or King B7 and then this
uh crucial King F5
whoa I don't like the look of that
King F5 you were mentioning that you
liked pushing the E Pawn um but you have
to be in a kind of very smart way
because the role of the black king is
actually to kind of like shoulder away
the white King right and if you go King
F5
it doesn't feel like
shouldering to me like I understand King
D4 King D7 rook h8 and so on King F5
well let's get so one way you can try to
be smart in this position yes is with
King B7 okay and that more or less takes
away this idea of uh Rook to h8 right
why because we have Rook D3 so what yeah
you still got Rook H7 I've always got
Rook H7
but now I can start with King B6 all
right I think I'm being too smart for my
own good probably I will then in that
case go back to Rook C8 right
Rook no no this cannot be a good that
cannot be a good move oh I think Alice
is
you you said it yourself uh Jovi how
difficult are these moves and I'm saying
they're really difficult and I don't
believe that Rook A5 check is a step in
the right direction that allows E5 and
you know what I think my plan is after
E5 she's gonna step to King D6 of course
she is but then
Arena will be very happy to say your
king is on D6 my King's on F6 take my
Pawn if you like
you take my Pawn I'll take your Pawn
I think you should take on C7
Maybe
try to play for a win with a pause play
for the win not with the pawns 67 King
takes C7 F3
oh I'm the table base tells me that this
is still winning for white for white yes
ah after F2 you go Rook to A8 is that it
correct
that's the winning move you're
absolutely right you allow me to Queen
but my queen is not doing much scared
uh whereas I think in this position
King D6 what you're saying you know
you're you're being a little bit
sophisticated there and not queening
your Pawn
I can also
you know
play this and Rook takes Rook takes this
is a wildly difficult end game yeah and
I think this is just drawn and they're
both down to their last minute oh my
gosh
but I don't blame Alice for going for
The Simple Solution because it's very
difficult to calculate all those porn of
course to kind of Judge her on a minute
whether your king can catch I mean you
need hours for this kind of stuff I know
we would we would have a Germans in my
day and we were still unsure after the
endurance is is Arena considering King
G4 I think she is yeah so that after
King D King there
and
is it completely ridiculous no why why
why would it be it's all drawn by the
way after very often we were seeing that
King H3 idea oh sorry H4 idea to keep
the H Pawn alive
we can't guess any of the moves anymore
not the right direction King E4 that is
not the right direction
you can't guess any of the moves so
we're anticipating King D7 Rook h8 yes
King E4 mistake
it just felt wrong it just E5 or King G4
both felt more intuitively you why step
in front of the pawn
why not
you know especially if you can get oh
King D6
okay that should make it very simple F3
should be a draw right away why why King
B6 and not go for
that Rook with King D7 or King B7 yeah
it feels like they're wobbly here keep
in mind they've been playing for a
number of hours but King D7 really felt
like the right move King D6
again I'm not sure who's going to come
into studio and say you know I'm happy
with the draw because none of them none
of them
to better each other how much time 20
seconds now down to 25 seconds okay
Arena okay and it has to go F3 right F3
let's go there's nothing crying
come on push the pawn yeah push the baby
uh actually the more I'm thinking about
it King F3 can't be ridiculous down to
her left six seconds Arena moves
oh
she forgot about the clock she just
forgot about her clock she did it with
one second on her clock wow wow it was
going on there to see a replay of that
that's all oh my goodness F3 and by the
way she played the right move with one
second
everybody literally jumped in the studio
I think Alice Alice also had a heart
palpitations us and herself and her
opponent the heart attack
defibrillator defibrillator
well Alice now down to her last 15
seconds herself
and she has to work out the consequences
obviously she's played King D6 with the
idea of rookie five a rookie fan okay
and that just helps Black's King escort
her Pawn up the board Rook E5
King to D3 followed by F2 and her King
will get to E2 and that will be
that seems like it's an easy draw yeah
I think we might be saying B3
and we're gonna have two playoffs that
would appear after this one second jolt
okay oh just to update everyone the
men's playoffs does not start until this
game ends that's that's fair yeah we
expected it to start at 5 30 but but
obviously if they're still playing you
know you can't have a uh rapid going on
oh
that goes to playoffs yeah then they
will get half an hour just to rest
recuperate calmness down
good plan good plan well Arena down to
five seconds okay now she takes the pawn
okay
she did what she took the phone why did
she took the pie what what
I'm not sure why she did that what she
didn't even wait for King D7
nope what okay let's count right now
that is crazy
it's fine I think it's fine okay she
should have waited for the move King D7
before that is just what okay um
I think they're get I think they're very
tired as well not much has changed not
much has changed she there there's
absolutely no way for Alice to make any
any progress but yes I mean why would
you take on C7 when you can just wait
another move of course uh take take uh
you were mentioning shouldering the king
no no
you're one move short if the king would
be on F5 you'll be winning yeah the king
is not on F5 Okay so
yeah Rook to F6 King moves to E2 as CS
is highlighted yeah and and now the path
is straightforward
just don't go after Rook 36 track to F1
that would be bad
don't go through F1 don't go there or to
F3 just stay on the P6 check uh
if you step in front of the pawn Rook
takes H6 is going to ruin your day
so you better you you better play King
to D2
yep yep kingly two and that's going to
force a repetition you have to stop me
from promoting with Rook F6
keep staying
on the D file
King D3
King D2 or King D1 but no oops excuse me
uh she she put the the King on
on
D3
and D2 or D1 she found the third the
third
choice and now Rook F6 and the players
will koreatron I think arena is going to
come in here and say
I forgot about the clock I mean I nearly
I nearly choked the game with one second
she she managed to find F3 and make a
draw
yeah well Alice does that happen to you
that you just forgot the clock yeah
completely it really has yeah you
Christian as well as that is that had
have you had a tournament it must have
happened to me a few times yeah yeah
that you just you you're just zoned out
zoned out but I think I caught myself
just like she did in perhaps in the last
second yes right I've had this this
situation before
wow that was you know she was
experienced enough to
remember that hey there's a clock you
lose you lose on time if you forget
about it with one second I mean
but you know Irina I don't think is
necessarily true but in these days but I
remember in the past she was always
known for getting into time travel yes
repetition and somehow it's in your
bones right when you get into time
travel when you're used to dealing with
those kind of intense pressures to kind
of wake up and look at the clock exactly
exactly
and there you have it draw she says I'm
going to play this and it will be three
times repetition
uh oh
I'm not sure what's being discussed
there
I'm not irina's not happy about
something that happened perhaps there's
some there were some noises in the
playing Hall in those crucial moments is
is that what she's I think hinting at
yeah
she's not happy with it she's not happy
something definitely interfered with her
uh
good feelings about uh today's game
she'll have to and let's just remind our
viewers how close she came to nearly
forfeiting the game uh as we have been
counting down the clock and she's got to
play the move F4 F3 3.
2 in slow motion one
and look at that and bang
that was asking as it can get as close
as it can get
that felt like Michael Phelps winning
the 50 meter by a fraction zero zero
zero tenth of a second or a hundredth of
a second it was fast wow wow wow wow wow
okay they're going to get a 30 minute
break they are but as soon as
the championship section their playoff
bound but we can start talking about
Hikaru Wesley
um because they are tired and uh here we
go this match is soon going to begin we
have Wesley so with the white pieces and
he'll be facing off against Hikaru
Nakamura and they will play two games of
game ten plus five seconds that's right
and this is my speculation yes probably
what she was hearing the noises that she
was hearing was the players coming into
the plane call getting ready for their
respective match that's your speculation
that's my speculation okay
um
well it was It's Tricky right when the
end game is like so razor sharp and
remove counts I mean it's very
disturbing if you hear some noises going
on or maybe there was some explanation
happening or something to kind of
distract you from getting into the zone
and anyhow you'll have to get over that
because what's done is done it's in the
past now we can focus on the playoffs uh
and we will focus on the playoff but
Christian I gotta ask you in that whole
razor sharp ending there Jovi and I have
been discussing for the last hour was
there any moment that Alice Mr win yes
there were quite a few moments in fact
that Alice missed the win in this
position particularly after King to E4
this was the big one uh the big mistake
by Irina she should have played after
Rook to A5 King to G4 we were discussing
this position but either way the games
have started Wesley Silver versus
Nakamura in the playoffs and we see
Hikaru open up with the aggressive C5
maybe going for the Kalashnikov
or the rosalimo I'm expecting a Rosso
limo from osc
and yes the russellimo it is Russell
limo with E5
that's a wrinkle
we don't see very often this move in
practice
especially not at their level we're
going to need the help of a production
team to
bring up the game
yeah
24 and now this is transitioning into
what certainly looks much closer to a
really low pass levels right but the
bishop on D6 looks a little bit uh funky
right right and in fact where do you put
that Bishop do you go back to E7 or do
you go on the other diagonal to C7
because at some point you have to oh C4
completely different approach
okay oh and it just popped up as if by
Magic as if by Magic hey hey hey it's
magic
and the players are actually going
really fast as if uh this is all part of
their prep it is some sort of uh B5 so
it should be three a C4 Bishop C2 Knight
F6 I've got the position and after D4
ampazon Queen takes D3 it just does feel
well is it more of a Spanish or is it
more of a sicilian I'm not sure anymore
it's a kind of hybrid right sure I mean
I like that I think that's a good way of
describing it I think I'm I mean I'm
looking I'm staring down the barrel of
D5 and that's why I'm thinking I've got
to go Bishop to G5 I don't have time to
play Bishop to B3 and or any of that
stuff and I think
D5 is a is a big threat uh so let's go
Bishop G5 right yeah okay one or Bishop
G5
has been played before so oh okay this
has been seen in practice both games
have been drawn but uh not many games at
all yes
okay so we're really in a kind of a rare
uh line rare and recent both of those
games were played in 2021 nothing before
and nothing after wow
uh oh and uh we have to remind ourselves
there is some money at stake because the
winner of this match will get a ten
thousand dollar bonus as the winner of
the Champions bracket which makes sense
because if you've lost a life and then
you come back into the tournament and
they didn't lose a life I should get a
little bit more than whatever it is that
you're getting uh bragging rights but
it's important to have cash cash
yeah there is a big incentive to stay
within the Champions bracket yeah you
have an extra life
your opponent coming in from the
elimination bracket has to beat you
twice in the grand finals to be able to
win the title so there are some
incentives to not lose a match and of
course a cash incentive ten thousand
dollars by the way guys my birthday is
coming up so I mean Ferraris and some
serious cash is all I'm interested in
serious cash all right like type like
that these guys are winning yeah no no
no no no no I'm easy I'm easy you can
spoil me any way you like it's by the
way Bishop G5 D6 on the board shirt
yeah is that an awesome Asher is is do
we have MC Escher the Dutch artist there
I think or else it's too confusing too
confusing yeah but on the board is
better yeah Rook D1 okay uh help us out
I mean that looks like a pretty good
move if you ask me my opinion I know uh
especially cop players are not afraid of
Moves Like Bishop takes F6 but hey uh
to my mind that's a threat it's nice
isn't it it's a Well double Pond or a
Pawn sacrifice yeah and also the White
Knight it's gonna go I was just looking
long term not just the poem grabbing
ideas I was like okay then how's the
night gonna get to some good square and
I was like okay you can go to as you've
indicated night
to F1 and then to E3 it's sitting pretty
very pretty
is this uh still Theory yeah Christian
no no no no no no and how did the how
did the engines evaluate this one
um
more or less whoa Knight H5 not great
after the move Knight to H5 I was about
to say Mansion Munch right take only
seven you probably have to take back
with them the king in fact to defend
that pawn on D6
true I mean queen takes Queen takes D6
is a knight takes Queen takes D6 so King
takes and I'll look you've yeah
stuck there for a moment sure you have
rookie eight king of eight and you're
going to hide it but let me focus on the
other side now A4 try to open you up on
the other side
and in my experience what they do is
they simply they go B4 mm-hmm
bypass you but okay uh do I have a
double attack with Queen C4
if I'm really greedy
well
well it's like a good uh question
a question I'd like to ask actually
because if I can take this my knight
actually might have a sterling outpost
on D5 coming up A4 looks like one of
those things but we've seen these types
of tickles haven't we Rook B8 yeah but
are you gonna allow yeah with the open a
line I know being on E7 do you usually
the king is safely tucked away on G8 by
the time you get to Rook A7 this move
Knight H5 was a bad move full stops yes
there's no other way of describing it
that was I mean I think Hikaru uh
strangely enough right here Knight H5 is
one of the moves that had been played uh
previous to this game and so ikaru
inclusion of the moves D6 and Rook D1 I
think he just
made a mistake frankly he did he did
indeed and he spent some time on it but
right now Wesley is pondering his next
move Bishop to E7 feels like it has to
be played right of course Bishop E17
sorry I was just going to talk about the
overall strategy because I have seen
Hikaru play dubious opening variations
and it just forces his opponent to burn
time on the clock whereas Hikaru himself
is incredibly resilient and you know
I was looking at the A4 idea I mean is
that the only way that white king no
I'll get an advantage on the contrary I
was thinking that the I was not fearful
of the move Knight F4 in fact I was kind
of uh wanting to welcome that move I was
going to play our
straightforward standard Knight D2
Knight E3 idea
hmm
by the way we asked and you answered a
question for us yeah we asked you when
do you think this playoff will end and
well here we go 38 of you think that
this will be decided in the in the blitz
playoff and uh 34 just in the 10 that's
two minute sacraments test Sacrament
it's getting long 10 minutes plus two
second increments and then finally 26 in
Armageddon so I mean it's quite that's
that's why we ask a friend and I think
the viewers have got it right and with
the 38 as well I think that we will have
two draws or two one one shall we say in
this segment and I think the blitz is
going to decide it 38 and you
no I think
no I think your car is going to because
I have to back my man so I think hikara
will take it in this portion I think
he's done a very risky thing here by the
way we do have King takes E7 as well as
A4 on the move the move that Christian
was uh stumping for A4 a b a b and here
we go
um do we follow it up with knightway
three
well it's funny I I
in the especially with the cough the
night on A3 is always offsides it's like
the worst place piece that and now he
puts it there voluntarily but I noticed
in this vishnikov it does have a path to
Freedom it kind of goes to C2 D3 here
you know it has a path okay so what
you're saying is after Knight A3
attacking the pawn on B5 I actually
played Knight F4 four tickling the the
queen okay that makes sense Knight F4 I
was going to play Queen E3 okay
and uh I wanted to say that I was going
to play Bishop C2 but okay go ahead how
would it go uh Joe V well you know no
longer threatening the B5 Pawn so I
didn't have to deal with that that is
true
you enjoy your moment of freedom to make
uh you're creative yeah I need to come
up with something
oh okay so we've been told Knight A3 is
an inaccuracy but this is computer chess
I think in when you just the both
players have um
I think anything goes okay you don't
make huge blonders okay so Knight F4 is
on the board I'm expecting Wesley to
play Queen E3 but then there's no more
threat I know 803 is just offsides
that's okay that's okay I mean you you
have to come up with some development
scheme after all it's your king in the
center of the board since you put the
queen on E3 can I follow it up with
Queen to B6 how is that end game I
wasn't sure about this end game my
instinct was to go for it but then I'm
not sure because okay it was a permanent
Square let's let's wait let's wait
well let's I think we're going to find
that out because I believe Queen to B6
is Queen E3 and queen B6 are both are
around both moves are on the board
yeah so how do you follow it up right
now Rook to D2 just waiting for you to
decide if you want to trade on E3 or not
really what I was doing with my last few
moves is
bypassing he just played Knight D4
he did
oh that's a visual okay that's a visual
that chain well essentially what that's
saying is I'm sorry you can't get away
with having your king in the center of
the board and I want to keep treat
Queens on the board because I know the
Golden Rule
when your king is under is vulnerable
I'm going to keep the Queens on the
board and that's what Wesley just did
with the move Knight D4
that's asking very important questions
yes it is
okay what do you do now what do you do
well one thing you don't do is you don't
capture that night with a pawn apart
from that I think you can capture it
within
that one would just be horrible because
it's right now you're horrified to
discover that you can't even capture
this Bond because of the D6 Pawn is
hanging so I agree with you
wholeheartedly don't even think of
touching that but can we take it this
way this is
feels shaky in
96.96 I take only five there is this and
I don't
this was not exactly what I was playing
I can just move yeah queen and I should
at least have a slight Advantage if not
oh maybe even much more well he has
tonight and
he did with the Knight takes D4 he did
play so Pawn takes on the board yeah
but if I don't play 96 I'm I'm
very mindful that the maneuver Bishop B3
Knight C2 and Knight B4 are gonna
dominate the D5 Square so I have to do
something
and you can't make moves like Rook d8
yes you know to kind of get the well
ponte's Pawn is still a problem
um yup yup although The Black Keys I'm
sorry you're gonna have to capture with
the pawn and then
the queen has to move
can I click on d8 okay sorry I think
we're on different uh wavelengths I'm
thinking Bishop B3 Knight C2 you're
thinking Queen G3 Queen yeah
well Rook d8 played Rook d8 played so
okay definitely not Queen G3 no because
of 92.
you want to trade well there was it
wasn't no because I was thinking about
this queen takes Queen business and pawn
takes Pawn is still and yeah but if you
can get away with let's look at that so
take on E5 okay take on E5 take on d8
take on d8 you have to take back with
the King
so now I have ideas of going Rook D1
okay
at the moment you haven't killed me
which is kind of surprising not yet or
maybe I had to go King to E7 Sorry Seven
Queen D2 how is how is that position not
pleasant not pleasant but I'm not dead
either
we get the king to F6 yeah it's not that
easy it's not that easy but sorry guys
why are we doing any of this why are we
helping black resolve his issues
Bishop to B3 that's the question is
asking as well and Knight C2
Let's uh let's bring this guy
and he played it yep and Knight to B4
can you not just run away with a king
uh
careful am I gonna get some problems
there might be some problems for you
I'm obsessed with football
thank you Bishop takes
E6
and nothing well now now d8 is protected
by the night so if I take on Eve yeah
now I'm chilling
yeah I I I I didn't get
my dream position what did he take with
a pawn now
ponte's porn sorry
Queen takes Bishop takes B3
yeah
yes yes yes I made a blunder a blunder a
blender but you do have G3
now what is this position I'm just uh
I guess it's just
getting away with murder right I know it
I guess it's evenish uh
Knight C2 on the board King f8 on the
board two
I think Hikaru escaped
remarkable he managed to escape
incredible okay so if we chill if we if
we just stay
chill I think he played it Rook to D2
Rook to D1 I mean one day night before
could end up killing can you take on B3
and go 96
take on B3 go Knight E6 seems
logical
uh dc8 was played
sorry Rook dc8
wow
uh you're inviting d4d5 you are indeed
yeah
there's some strange looking black minor
pieces after this movement
yeah you have to step back with uh
game or yeah this Knight where is it
gonna go I'm gonna go g three I think
takes takes night before I'm looking at
Rook A7 and I'm looking at G3 it's not
going to happen it's not going to happen
no
all right G3 was played uh Bishop takes
B3 Queen takes B3 and Knight to E6 uh he
played G3 immediately and Hikaru got the
chance to trade and sidestep the D4 D5
Tempo maybe that was not a good uh a
good thing let me just refresh my board
apologies as I refresh and uh clear the
cobwebs
okay I'm sorry guys but I'm still
feeling that whites for Choice maybe not
by as much as before but
isn't I would just go ponte's porn it's
black as
it is
last move was Rook 81 well B4
wow that's a move I did not think about
it okay so takes takes Rook to the
seventh right yes give me Queen take
don't think of maneuver moving the night
no Knight C5 you're saying no let's see
right don't don't Fork me it could be
hurtful
so what if I go um
what if I fork you but I fork you with
Queen C6
okay
Queen I just wanted to show one terrible
terrible tactic that you will never
allow me to play okay the queen C6
excuse me the the okay and he's actually
played a completely different move he's
actually stepped with his game onto G2
which surprised me because
I thought that ponte's pawn made the
utmost of sense to liberate the two
Rooks King G2 how are we doing on time
guys because this is yeah okay very
important right now Wesley is under two
minutes whereas Hikaru is just under
three
and this is where we we know hikaru's
great strength is his ability to
navigate very very complicated uh
positions and gain time against this
opponent GH4 G7 G6 h2h4 by the way in in
that game in in that position that we
were looking at let's see if we can
bring it up something like this because
oh with the King on G2 it's even worse
uh well sorry I this is what I thought
um
Wesley wanted Rook on D7 Queen on F3
business he's going for it
okay good
at least I could properly guess one uh
move and that's why he played the move
H4 because there's no more Knight G5
defending that pawn on F7 after Queen F3
exactly queen of three stops Knight G5
important
okay two minutes and 15 seconds and
counting four I don't know but this is
shaking his head right now hikaru's he's
Carlos has some serious challenges to
face he missed this kind of three idea
how is he defending Queen F3 that's a
very cool I think he a good start is the
trade-off set of works okay so Rook C7
Queen F3
you trade off a set of Rooks Rook takes
D7 Rook takes D7 the maid threat is
still existent exactly and the only way
you can do that Knight d8 and then my
knight is released right but you do
cover the F6 Square
[Music]
check check this out Rook C7 queen of
three Rook takes D7 Rook takes D7 98.
oh E4 is hanging I apologize this this
was the tactic I wanted
yeah but I forgot that after E4 and you
can make a draw with King 68 so he has
played Rook C7
but I shouldn't sacrifice my after
Knight d8 I should just I just should
just maintain
the players have caught up with us and
here I played Knight E3 for Wesley again
a minute 50 for Wesley a minute 20 24.
wow
this is can I start attacking your Rook
Queen C6 Queen B6 if you go to A7 yeah I
was going away from the seven Queen C6 I
was planning to tickle the pawn
at some point I would have to sacrifice
something and just try to create I like
the way you're thinking
[Laughter]
yes
broadcast right these guys are good
these guys are good they are very good
right I was thinking Queen E6 Queen E6 I
like that move to defend Defenders
released right the night and let me be
as irritating as possible Queen C6 I
like this move because you do if you do
go to D5 with a rook then I can go to E6
or to C7 well well wait a minute if you
go to let's go to E6 E6 and I go Knight
to C4 aren't I getting like a huge
advantage
because it's looking unpleasant it's
looking checks and Rook D6
follow or Knight takes E5 aren't I
getting a huge advantage in this case
it's not looking good okay sorry so we
do have currently this position yes
Wesley under a minute we are expecting
the move Rook D5
and he played it yeah
yeah and once this game is finished the
players will swap colors and they will
do it all again and if the match is tied
then we will see a little bit playoff
and okay
E6 he's channeling his inner Christian
that's a good thing not a good thing
no no he didn't play Knights
he's attacking the night this is great
stuff good stuff yeah all right these
guys are good these guys are good and
you're right if the Knight moves to C6
Rook D6 is a painful uh retort is it
though I can I go Queen E8 after Knight
C6 Rook D6 oh I mean it's not look the
position is not pretty it is
85 seconds for Hikaru
Queen F6 Hikaru does not like what has
just taken place let's move Queen D1
upset him he did not see this move Rook
D6 96 Queen D5 Rook to D7
oh no more 96. 96 Queen D6 check will be
careful and Knight to D5 is coming
that's huge 16 was ticking down I think
it's the walls are closing in
I
okay uh it really feels like in these
last 5-10 moves that Wesley has taken
control of this game
and he's played Rook D6 and I think he's
his intention is to play Queen
D5 to dominate The Knight and stop you
from playing F6 or 96 but often moves
like um queen queen D5
Rook D7 repeating once surely
B5 but okay
surely he's not ready to go for it
95 95 he says I'm much better and he is
right he stands incredibly well
perhaps okay 10 seconds for Ricardo you
have to make a move Hikaru didn't like
Queen C6 Queen E6 invites rookie seven
as well it does indeed he has played
Queen E6
wasn't he with
me oh this Knight C7 guys Knight C7 and
98 is a check oh that could be oh that
could be massive oh you found it Queen
the B6 no
Queen C6 he's going for Little Dixie for
he's thinking that he has some sort of a
Perpetual what's the plan here Wesley
Queen D5 Queen D5
and a trade and he's threatening 96
check was that good did he give up his
Advantage with that Queen trade it sure
feels like he whoa Knight A6 Knight A6
through K8
oh this is a great move he's going to go
Knight G5
yep oh I think Hikaru missed this he's
done it maybe it's time for Hikaru to
actually chase after the very passive
approach but how do you continue right
now a D6 Rook the 16 King f8
King F3 what what king F3 I thought D6
oh King E5 whoa whoa whoa
uh the pieces are going the nervousness
E5 65 Knight C5 Knight d3. that's why he
kind of put the pawn on B3 no he takes
on take Rook takes F7 let's go he's
going for it well he's touched the Rook
he's got to move it he's only got
oh we made that move with two seconds
left on the clock no way is that true oh
oh oh is there going to be a mate Knight
takes a night takes us seven where's the
mate Knight H6 and King takes G6 mate
he takes two six I have Knight E5 you're
right you're right is there a mate
Mighty uh Hikaru playing a very nice
move Rook nice three seconds
he did it with two seconds on his claws
to the H7 Square
and he's got a Perpetual I think he's
ready to take the Perpetual but by the
way King the eight King the eight Knight
F7 King C8 where's the Perpetual well no
King C8 would lose to D6 D6 is it really
you're threatening D7
you're threatening D7 D6 I have Rook B6
with D6 on the board oh my gosh Rook
check I don't see it guys no he's run
away the b-pawn three seconds for Wesley
he needs to make a move he did
but now it's too late the oh my goodness
he's here did Hikaru just swindled
Wesley
well wait a minute King
e70 threatening B2 D7 and he can Queen
oh what a game he can give up his and
look at the clocks Knight day five oh
he's queened so you got a queen come on
let's go Queen butt faster
full
he's done it check oh no
I think this is it this is it oh what a
swim though what A Swindle by
wait a minute check let's not call it
let's not call it the game yet there's
Queen A8 check let's not call it you
don't want to allow yeah oh but the same
game is not easy now no
G8 Rook to g85 Knight F5 you have don't
go King F7 oh he missed it oh no you
can't go King F7 you missed this track
oh and by the way
what no I thought King D7 wasn't made
afterwards now you can go King C7 and
maybe just crawl your king towards the
king side White's pieces are frozen he
can't make any moves yes
22 seconds versus eight seconds
B8 must be winning now right
I'm not 100 sure
not a hundred percent sure Jovi how do
you reckon I don't know nothing about
that area I think better to keep the
Rooks on
the Rooks on nice nice move
what a move by Hikaru
Rook F4 okay so now Wesley it Lisa's
prepping king f8 king of fate and King
G7 and he's done it
I like I like keep it and then King King
stay connected to the G6 Pawn
and Hikaru goes for King to D5 G4 is not
possible oh
G4 there was a knight H6 check G4 is
never possible yeah so Rook has to go
back to oops I was about to say Rook has
to go back to F4 and just as I was
saying it he moved his Rook to B3
predictions draw or Hikaru takes him I
was going to take this first of all the
time situation has suddenly become
favorable and well pieces of peace I'm
not convinced I I don't see a good way
to make progress and Wesley cannot
capture that pawn that would have been a
nasty discover check oh he's chasing The
Rook don't go rookie three
Rook B3 seems safe
yeah he's a little bit concerned
11 seconds
count down to eight
King H7 or King to F7 I think King F7 I
I said one I agree I I don't want to get
shouldered by King E5 and King F6 and I
I don't like this King H7 I don't like
it either
he's going from the other side but this
should not be king F6 nope I was
expecting king of six Rook I think maybe
it's time to go F3 and G4 that was maybe
one second I think oh the white work is
in trouble he throws in a check that was
a good check by the way just in time
because you've got King F6 if you don't
go King E6 throw in another check
exactly you have to keep checking yeah
because the white king is in serious
trouble within five seconds throw in
another check and you've got King F6 if
the if the black king allows white to
play King of six I think the chances of
a draw just increase x 95 let's go
Knight D5 counter check check encounter
check
King H6 Rook D7 oh I like it I think
that's the right 10 seconds any Karu no
whoa where is he going he could have
played King F6 where's he going oh Rook
F4 be careful King F6 oh no now you
can't play King F6 anymore now you gotta
go King H6 yes
just just in time actually such a
complex oh my gosh what an ending Rook
F4 no King to G5
all Wesley needs to do is exchange those
last couple of Pawns yeah well we
understand the advice
yeah how do you do it is the question
Rook D4 why did he hesitate
it's just double checking his lines the
Knight is so Tricky by the way traffic
G4 no
no no I I think that was a golden
opportunity but I think it still exists
it's Hikaru it still exists I was gonna
say I think that was the that was the
the dream moment and he caught it
away from the Knight
take the pawn
do you get checkmated if you think the
pawn no you can't get checked mated take
Upon take again take the pawn and now it
draws uh
is easy yeah it's just rook and Knight
versus Rook okay and uh Wesley will know
how to draw this what a game
I don't know it had everything I want
this position I've won this position
with the Knight it's it's not that easy
especially when you have some pawns to
cover up the king the black king
this is over no yes I think so why is it
over
and just okay so I've got the table base
up and it's saying it's a drawer
no Checkmate in the air just yet give up
the pawn give up the point yeah that's
what you need to do is just give up all
the Pawns
and we know even without the pawns it's
a draw but like you say the the pawn on
H5 is kind of like don't go F5 now
okay that's it takes
F4 though he can just start checking the
black king okay so you mean check 96 and
then move the king
what was the Wednesday Wesley and now
and now you go King H7 yes that makes
sense
okay that should be a draw and go move
away from the H Pawn the H Pawn is
actually go to G8
move away from that don't don't call it
too quickly this one is still in my
estimation is still quite difficult it's
like a 50 50.
whoa okay
tonight okay so Rook A6 Rook B1 five
seconds three seconds what what
no way no no this is over what was that
sorry what was that no no okay this was
this was a a blunder an oversight by uh
Wesley
and he just resigned oh the nerves got
to him the nerves got to got to him on
the last one
wow that was terrible
guys
that was just nerves that was just
a century uh
that was a that was a game like a love a
love story with like 12 different
endings and we weren't sure who was
betrayed the betrothed and uh wow
and how about our ladies have they
started their game
and now they'll start both games
together after after
they unwind here
um
Christian when we go to the position
after move 44 here about
at this point Wesley has been having a
big Advantage for most of the game and
then suddenly the B-2 Pawn went missing
did he miss a win oh yes yes yes at what
moments if you go in keep going keep
going to be seven I think was the the
move King 65 and I just pick up the pawn
on F7 you guys recommended this Rook
takes F7 yeah not Rook to C7 first that
gives me an important Tempo and so
having to check okay keep going
yeah and I'm I'm not worried about Rook
B6 check Rook B6 Knight E6 gotcha and
then there and then we've got a nice
mating setup you're going to get
checkmated so Knight takes B2 and now
we've got the mating setup that we want
easy yes Knight takes P2 now I just go
and that is that is very very simple you
know the sad thing is about precise
minute Wesley was on the verge of
playing Rook takes after seven I think
he was and then he just kind of
overthought it for that Split Second and
the magic of Television Rook takes E6
was the move that lost the game on the
spot uh frankly uh had he just moved his
rook and kept the knight in a pin
it would have likely been a draw
and uh
final moments and Hikaru just pounces
his cheese and after King H7 King F7
um after King goes to age eight the
black king can just go to G6 exactly and
then after age seven
and eight yeah
wow wow okay
[Laughter]
this means Hikaru you know he won with
the black pieces however Scrappy it was
it was a victory it was a victory and
now is needs to draw right with a white
and by the way uh Colin uh make a wish
uh
gentlemen uh enjoying every minute his
family is just like dude you made a good
wish
nobody it's so nice you know to see that
in between these hard times you know
he's getting a lot of
jobs and action and we're getting a lot
of Joy because we are just like thinking
goodness maybe one Earth is happening I
thought Wesley played a magnificent game
I really did he was just with the rook
and the queen in the night he had just
more or less dominated the play I was a
little bit surprised by the his decision
to trade Queens with the move Queen D5 a
decision that turned out to be winning
by the way I mean as he did uh but did
he miss anything
severe at this moment no no he he did
everything perfectly including Queen D5
he really did yes going to D5 that's
fine everything is good
this end game is winning right okay and
the King to the center bring another
attacker into play get the king to take
on E5 he did everything perfectly he
just didn't take on F7 at the right
moment as he should have yeah whoo
are we gonna take a break and catch our
breaths and uh just take a very short
break all righty and uh we'll see you
time for game two
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
thank you
[Music]
foreign
we are back and we have two players
lining up for game two of the playoffs
and whereas just behind them we also saw
Arena crush and Alice Lee beginning
their playoffs Queen's Gambit accepted
in the game between
um Alice and Arena they're starting
their first game uh let's repeat that
their first game whereas Wesley and uh
Hikaru are on their second game uh
Hikaru were enjoying a one-point lead
exactly and it does age four yeah I know
I mean desperate times wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait Hikaru is
not the desperate one no but I hate the
man I'm talking about their opening yeah
well I understand the perk I understand
the perk
Wesley's playing the perk to to try to
get a game yeah but H4 is a way of
saying like I'm supposed to be playing
for the win because H4 usually you go
you you play H4 to play H5 and sacrifice
exchange H5 I've seen that on occasion
yeah when sacrificing The Exchange I get
it but Wesley will say okay well I'm
happy so there was a match I don't
remember exactly when but it was Wesley
uh sorry Hikaru versus Jeffrey Shaw and
Hikaru was in a mastermind situation
with the black pieces he chose the
mother right he lost okay very very
easily in fact lost and in his uh
post-mortem he said that yes everybody
knows how to defeat the mother nowadays
at the elite level
this is what I'm thinking perhaps he
studied it understood that this
situation could arise on the board and
maybe he knows exactly what he needs to
do with this move H4 followed by F3
potentially launching an attack on the
king side well I'm just saying no no not
the way you play for a draw or a score
is white you're giving me black in this
case a lot to play for I'm gonna play A6
first of all anytime you play H4 H5 go
ahead sacrifice your exchange make my
day
are you going to play G4 no you're not
going to go Bishop E3 okay Bishop E3 and
guess where you're putting your King
right yeah
then you go Queen D2 okay and I go
Knight D7 and now that you've got 97
doesn't it I go Knight H6 is three okay
yeah it's okay night uh no I can see
that my my theory is uh
well I I'm saying you as white you've
played the move H4 so it's only natural
that you tuck your king over on the
queen side but I'm going to be there
waiting for you with open arms I'm going
to be playing B4 and A5 and I'm gonna I
know your address yes at the moment you
don't know mine I may keep my king stuck
in the center I may go Queen side all
I'm saying is
for a must win is black hey I'll take
this position anytime wait one second
you kind of adopted like a modern
approach with A6 B5 right but Wesley uh
changed
completely he did because after F3 he
went into the center E5
that to me feels like
it's too totally solid yeah it's I I'm
sorry to say that I feel that uh this is
helpful for uh Hikaru because it gives
him the the opportunity to play very
standard uh Play Now Queen D2 castles
now H5 because I have to commit my king
to the king side now H5 makes perfect
sense uh and frankly I think that white
has a better position simply that
um
wow Jovi have you studied the black lion
because this looks like some sort of a
black lion right
yes my good friend Simon Williams
who is a really good author and I
studied his courses he recommends the
black light it's actually quite
dangerous
castles I haven't seen I haven't read
this course yet let me just check in on
the game of Alice Lee for a second as uh
we're we're well that's not the game
that I wanted excuse me
here it is uh it's a Queen's Gambit
accepted with these Early Trades of
Queens
and okay this is pretty tame I don't
think either player has anything that
they could really dream of Knight takes
E5 Bishop takes E5 maybe as simple as
Bishop A4 you know makes a lot of sense
yeah just Bishop C7 as well right yeah I
don't think that Arena will be on on the
only thing I do like your Bishop A4 move
because of course the the White Knight
was threatening to come forward to see
yeah
I couldn't you can interpret interpolate
interpose
okay it's getting late Bishop A4 or Rook
C8 I like either one of those and what
did she do well she she did go Bishop
Bishop A4 and Alice was unhappy she
played Rook B1 okay that feels a little
bit wrong
mindset yeah
it's impressive Rook C8 Rook C8 I'm sure
she's intending Knight C5 in that case
but hold on we could go let's take a
look shall we Rook C8 Knight C5 B6 just
to
check this out
Rook C1 and now Rook C1 again I just
want to exchange pieces yeah fair enough
fair enough I was wondering if Arena had
an opportunity or not
since we're in an elimination situation
we should definitely go back to it
exactly uh by the way no Knight C5 but
Bishop F1
by Alice Lee she's kind of inviting
these Rooks to
the second rank Rook C2 Rook D2 I don't
know
um but you're right the because uh
Wesley is facing elimination let's just
check in on
him
where are you Wesley yeah you'll be in
for a treat
I'm not getting uh my my uh yeah there
you are there you are thank you
yeah you can see that there's been a
queen trade which
of Simply ecstatic about but it's so
strange he took on E5 and he took back
with the d-pawn yeah situation take with
the Knight keep the quiz on the board I
mean you know Hikaru is going to trade
those Queens instantaneously
well that doesn't make a lot of sense I
don't know I'm I'm enthusiastic by
Wesley's Choice here frankly
um the night what have you just done
you've put your knight on G3 it's not
any great shakes over there even if you
were to get in the move H5 congratulate
yourself as much as you like Knight to
D4 Castle you know keep the pawn on C2
C5 let me reinforce my knight I do have
ideas a6b5
you want to go H5 you want to try to
kill me with H5 okay
I I this night on D4 versus this night
on G3
gun deal I like it yeah
and uh just to set the scene We There
are two players playing in the
championship brackets this is their
final and the winners of the
championship brackets will move on to
the Grand Final and this is the
situation in both the open and the
women's situation and anyone who loses
gets demoted down to the elimination
bracket where they'll be facing some
pre-ordained opponents uh ten thousand
dollar bonus for the winner of this
match five thousand dollar bonus for the
winner of the Arena versus Elvis Lee
match very good and we do have this
position after Knight G3 I'm expecting
94. with both hands possibly perhaps you
can't even H5 right H5 black things
on the H file also cement that weakness
that's the potential weakness on H4
exactly H4 is going to be attacked by
the bishop coming to F6 so
the only question that I have to answer
as black is where do I put the knight
from F6
I would say it depends on how the queen
side ends up if I got an id4 and C5 and
A6 and B5
if the pawn goes to B4 Knight D7 to C5
yes that that is perfectly right and by
the way why is Wesley spending so much
time in this position to his last four
minutes and 30 seconds while Hikaru is
just enjoying a three minute advantage
and if you don't play Knight D4 why did
we put our Knight on season well he's
gone for age five okay I like that same
move faster was better but I like that
move but yes we put our Knight on C6 for
for a purposeful reason right that is we
wanted to tuck our Knight into this
outpost on D4 so
[Laughter]
Bishop to G5 okay
but that pin is not going to last long
you can always go root to D7 too
get out of it right so well Rook to D7
May invite Bishop B5 and I I again let's
start with 94. 94 castles Rook D7 I'm
all for it let's go
Rook D6 actually what happens I what I
wanted to do was a night to be we see A6
played because I wanted to say Knight B5
yeah in this month yes but anyway this
is all a little bit hearsay because
hearsay wow yeah I'm misusing that word
uh okay A7 no 94 A7 A6 yeah Wesley I
sometimes you know the the players of
today with their computers they they
really love their prophylactic moves and
not committing themselves but sometimes
moves like Knight D4
are just really good and you should just
play them
um
Bishop D3 Bishop D3 I mean I have to say
I quite like the way that Wesley is
playing because you know it keeps asking
Hikaru the question like how are you
going to develop how are you going to
commit your pieces 66
um I must
not Francisco castle like isn't this too
little too late
that's what I'm afraid for Wesley no I
I'm still I'm still going with Wesley on
this one I mean again he is in a
must-win situation so I mean
he
he's getting uh I'm slightly getting
excited about some Knight F5 ideas but
their problem they probably don't work
and hopefully not
we do also kind of if you were playing
Hikaru like I say cast I quite like
castles but one idea that I had was you
playing Knight F1 Knight E3 yes get your
knight to D5 well I've been pounding the
table for quite some time of uh bringing
my knight to D4 so that I could get in
this kind of a queen side expansion with
B5 and C5 and get some action rolling
now in this particular case you could if
you like Play Bishop takes F6 and take
control over the D5 Square which is well
the timing of Rook D6 and so long Castle
in 97 on the board
I beg your pardon Castle in 97.
okay
he has castled long and Knight D7 on the
board yes
so that he can play Knight C5 and
well guys uh our our
um
audience 38 said they would make it to a
blitz 34 nope said nope it would be
determined
and uh right now the 34 percenters look
pretty
good
I was one of those 34 percent
don't say it so proudly I was one of the
34 that just doesn't I mean I wasn't
I wasn't one F1 did you see that coming
no I sure didn't see that coming Bishop
F1
almost well I guess he was worried about
this Knight C5 capturing the bishop and
he didn't want to put it on E2 where it
was touched by the other night and
finally
boy it sure took him a long while but he
did sink the Knight to D4 but uh
great strategy okay because let's take a
look at hikara's pieces not impressive
the Knight on G3 most especially I mean
versus the night on D4 the scales
between those two nights are decisively
in Black's favor this Knight is
amazing you had an idea of putting the
Knight on E3 and I like that by the way
Knight E2 all right let's go C5
absolutely C5 and if you go C3 I got a
check with cement that night on D4
agreed which I think he did he did I was
trying to see whether I could get Bishop
E7 to work but really it's a temp it's
just one hit one hit
well I would say very uncomfortable like
imagine something stupid like okay just
just bear with me for just a moment here
as you could start to imagine that my
Rooks are coming and I'm gonna play F6
and I'm going to play Bishop H6 and I'm
gonna ask your king some questions that
are going to make you feel uncomfortable
so I mean and look at these pieces
what's this what's this what's this
um by the way F7 F6 on the board sorry
let me just refresh my my my board for a
moment meanwhile it does look like the
game between Alice and every Arena
will be
heading towards a draw
okay let's just check in on that and see
uh how close they are to the draw oops I
keep
no I'm not sure I've got that position
in my that
no they're either thank you
good I mean
white is better there's no doubt about
that
yeah I was gonna
but on the other hand I do think it's in
it's definitely manageable for Irina to
draw this manageable yeah that's not for
one thing but better is better
oh for sure and that a pawn maybe goes
to A5 may be supported by the bishop
coming to C5 and then landing on B6 yeah
if anything I have to say that this is
looking pretty good for Alice she has
some very serious chances to take the
full point in this one yeah especially
since it felt like Irina psychologically
was not feeling like herself especially
towards the end when she was complaining
about some noises she wasn't happy
something happened there that kind of
put her off that can definitely live on
impact yeah she was aggravated and
allowing the C6 move was wrong and now
once you see Rook A7 you go hey
something is really kind of turned wrong
for her and now she's seriously on the
back foot
if she gets her if she gets out of this
okay she will be happy because yeah
a very very clear Advantage here what's
the what's the time well she's just
under just over one and a half minutes
and her night is looking
a bit lost out there and also the Rook
is under attack yeah it almost said to
suji on the night
domination it is domination but I still
think
with accurate play Arena can defend this
okay so we'll see what happens and we
have to remind everyone this is their
first right a playoff game whereas uh
Wesley is fighting for his life
if you will he's down a point and when
we left it we just left it here where we
saw the move C5 King B1 F6 by Wesley
Knight and yeah this is what I'm saying
sacrifice a piece just Bishop B3 Knight
to C4
so what if I take on D4
isn't D1 hey
take on C5
no D1 was hanging dude and take on C5
what I take 24 with the pawn you take
only one I take on C5 okay and isn't
that another piece
well the players are bashing out the
moves okay sorry sorry
I thought he had to move his Rook he did
move his Rook 90 E6 Rook E1 I mean no no
no no this has not gone well at all for
uh
for Hikaru he is now what's the
bishopone F1 doing what's the rule
for some time
the night is going to move itself to see
what
see what can be
pairing going on I think yeah you you
make the weakness so that you can repair
it and you know what you're doing got it
uh I I love that strategy Bishop
C4 or Knight to C4 1944
tickles this bishop can I see one and he
took a very nice Bishop by the way that
that Bishop on E3 was protecting
hikaru's King against Bishop H6 and Rook
takes E3 or Knight takes B3 if you take
on B3 do you defend that Knight only to
be there with this page six I do I do I
like defending it with Bishop H6 because
I like the Bishops of opposite colors
three
who's that maybe you have to take on B3
and just suffer the consequences of this
position
again I'm thinking B5 C4 Advantage black
yes yes
he carried down to his last minute and
30 seconds which page six immediately
played yep
and Advantage black as B5 C4 Rook d8
lots and lots of easy moves for Wesley
to play at this all right I I just
picked out the engine Yep this is minus
four and a half minus four and a half
makes sense completely devastating
position for
Hikaru Caro has misplayed it terribly
but this is great news for Wesley and
his fans because he's in a must win
situation with the black pieces truly
and Wesley is beginning to feel it he
may not know he's up for and that sounds
like a lot
but he's definitely thinking hey look I
know what I'm doing Rook Rook is coming
down oh my God sometimes
ugly is all you got but what what about
Rook to d8 is an easy easy move Bishop
E2 B5 Knight C5 let's get that guy in
I'm starting to look at Rook to D2 right
now Rook to D2 Knight F1 Rook takes E2
oh that's that's a beauty always Rook to
D2 I think you can almost do anything
why look a p feels paralyzed at this
moment B5
more potential you have but that clocks
yeah the clocks are Wesley has one and a
half minutes where is Hikaru just over
one minute but I just to kind of say
please if Wesley does win this means the
match is tied and it means we're going
to go on to some Blitz playoffs where
the players will play two games or three
minutes plus two seconds and you'll be
one of the 34 that was wrong correct
E2 just as you prescribe Knight takes F1
that's two pieces for a rook
yikes
all right and I take step one let's keep
going and
even played Rook takes like yeah rookies
not going anywhere f
you've got to get that night out before
Oh no question about it should we cut to
the corner again true plan tonight on D3
can we do that how do we do that oh
definitely do that 93 Knight C5 to D3
love it oh yes love it because if you
can go Knight C5 D3 at once then you can
go Knight G3 in the Rooks trapped
even better
Knight C5 to D3 that looks like a boss
Plan and there's just no way for The
Rook to activate at all I mean the only
thing that Hikaru can do is move his
work to E1 and to D1 well that's the
dream is to activate the Rook somehow
like there and he's found it Wesley is
what I have to say after this game
statistically the modern when you're in
a must win situation has to be played
Levon used it against Fabi we're seeing
it here as well oh by the way Knight D2
came 92 followed by Night B3 with uh
that's such an ugly position for for The
Rook
by the way uh I've been told that Arena
has managed to right the ship and it's
uh an even game no longer big Advantage
Alice and we just saw a pawn sacrifice
the Hikaru trying desperately to get
some
something going something something
king of seven I love that consolidating
move I just don't see it
okay that move basically says I'm gonna
play F4 I don't believe it myself B5
keep everything protected why not
brilliant
King to A3 doing his best
to make Wesley a bit uncomfortable hey
look at that Wesley is not uncomfortable
in this position exactly simply enjoying
everything I think he is I I really do I
think he's about ready to pounce with
night oh there's an E4 Pawn sighting
okay finally we see Hikaru desperately
tried to break out with F4 right but
it's really not going to help too much
after Pawn takes porn at least the room
gets somewhere close to I'm not sure
sometimes when you when you're trying to
hold these difficult positions any
breakouts you make actually end that one
as well yeah
okay Rook D7
on the agenda nope stop that Bishop F4
get rid of that night before Bishop G3
I see one check first he's rerouting
that Knight closer to the center Knight
to D3
makes a lot of sense I would have played
Bishop F4 hit that Knight and then like
you say Bishop G3 and take that pawn
Knight to D5 let's get the king in
Center no he decides to try to exchange
another pair of pieces I like that move
a lot Knight F4 actually
just you're threatening G2 and you're
kind of forcing the trade of the knights
frankly
no before night Hikaru understands that
he's got to do Desperate Measures now
and Rook C8 Bishop to E3 just keep that
Knight on C5 love that Knight on C5
six
game E5 a little bit
hesitant but yes King E5 was fine
Knight takes H4 is going to be three
connected past bonds Wesley's gonna even
up this match we're gonna be playing
Blitz his yes yes he is
one minute to roughly one minute there's
no trick whatsoever on the board so take
the pawn and we see the handshake Wesley
wins wow with the black pieces win
situation with black incredible stuff
against our number one seed let's jump
to uh the game between Arena and Alice
six
four seven seconds for Irena
oh 45 seconds for young Alice Lee well
that's the only thing keeping Alice in
the game but Rook to A2
Knight to B5 but now Rook to B8 is
coming sorry
well Rook B8 Rook A2
yeah get get rid of the ape on it's the
only thing that can hurt you
how easy is that four verses quite easy
actually I had it again against Ben
Larson and the pawns uh win very
comfortably against the bishop what is
that I realize that oh Arena didn't like
the fact that uh Alice pressed the clock
when the the piece was not on the Square
for a good reason yeah yeah you should
etiquette requires that you you put the
piece on the Square proper attic
by the way Rook there what's that you go
what's the G8 you go King F5 and ah she
wanted to support the G Pawn this way
King F5 G5
roll them roll them roll them the great
thing is that they just March up the
board light
didn't they have a similar end game
where Irina had Five Pawns Against The
Rook
yes
no no no no honestly Alice Lee Alice
Alice had the pawns yes yes and wanted
to play on
Five Points I think it was four four
against it was an inspiring by Alice he
wasn't letting Arena make a draw and go
home
that was really good okay G5 let's go G5
defend the pawn on F6 exactly
yeah this one is looking good for Irena
I don't know how the magic happened I
know it was a turnaround that was for
sure
Rook F4 H4
King G6 defend that pawn
King steps back and there you see arena
being accurate with the placement Arena
like as if to emphasize but everyone
doesn't actually need to go Rook F5 she
could adjust no H4 and Let It Go H4 H H4
G4 H3 and the bishop actually doesn't
even stop the pawns anymore
H4 yeah I think Alice is trying to go
Bishop f8 but not like G4 right I'm not
sure about uh
her technique exactly here H4 let's go
H4 keep pushing and look at four seconds
wow four seconds yep she's letting her
time drift too slowly she's overthinking
the position okay Rook F3 let's get
tricky
why there don't put the Rook on the dark
squares oops okay
H3
if the Rook were already on F3 you would
be able to
whoa not why not King she's okay
F5 F5 and Rook or Rook F3 immediately
now
five on the board okay
there's still this is just a question of
two it's the March it's all about the
clock that's the that's the thing that's
saving Alice at the moment or what she's
playing playing for and this is their
first playoff game so after this is over
they will do it again with the colors
switched over exactly now just simply
Rook the B3 followed by Rook to B5 to
defend the E Pawn and then
she's reaching for her Queen Rook to B5
you don't need to play check you don't
need to do anything yeah she's
she's being fancy right now right now
speaking of three not go edge
F3 get fancy come on don't get fancy
just got rookie five she has to go
wow why does she do that wait a minute
okay that's simple that G3 G3 now it's
over yeah and you're threatening the
queen he's gonna come to F3 Bishop C5 G2
followed by H1 and that's resignation
oh well Alice had a Grimace there I mean
because she knows that she had an
advantage and when we left it she had
four versus four and somehow
there was a magic oh she has missed
Knight F4 yeah and wow what a narrow
Escape for arena definitely but uh they
will have to do it all over again and
this time Alice will be in a must-win
situation with the black pieces yeah
yeah by the way help me out is this the
first time Arena has had a playoff yes I
do I believe so and in the open we're
now down to Blitz because the Rapids
were split 1-1 with black taking a
victory in both games yeah and this time
Hikaru will start with the white pieces
against Wesley so and the time control
is three minutes plus two seconds so
it's getting faster and faster and they
will play these two games and if the
match is still tied after these two
games then we're gonna see the crowd
favorite or the crowd divider you know I
can see lots of people love it or they
hate it but it's Armageddon well we had
it yesterday and it was a thrill
but boy I I mean the for the players I I
think that their their nerves were shot
but I have to say please this feels fair
right now because Wesley was so winning
in the first game he played such a
beautiful game and then it was just a
final moment Swindle by Hikaru true and
after that in the second game Wesley
once again played really good chess
outplayed Hikaru right with black pieces
in more or less an equal position right
I'm going to need some assistance on my
uh just refresh that just refresh yeah
and they're their players are ready
okay C5 okay yeah I I definitely blew
whatever it is that I needed to do
okay
yeah and the players are racing with the
pawns oh it's the same variation like uh
hikaru's Hikaru thought that he came out
of that first game in a good in good
shape and actually I didn't feel that
was the case with any repeats the same
line with Knight H5
again I I didn't somebody must have told
him that this is not wow right I guess
not I guess not knight uh Bishop E3 I
thought
Wesley had a a beautiful opening uh oh
this time by the way he did but okay
time is so short in between these games
that it truly there is no time to speak
with you anybody and also there is the
seconds are not allowed in the playing
Hall
well we have for obvious reasons
absolutely and King went to h8 he's
prepping F5
and the question is is that really even
any good do you really want to play F5
in these positions why not
you have to find not you have to do
something because you're weakening
everything reminds me of the F5 played
by Fabi in his first playoff match
against Levon right and the King just
got completely naked
yeah uh okay uh
previously A4 was played and the idea
was to open up the a file and create a
weakness on a Target on the B5 square is
that still uh no he's trying to stop
this uh
on the board
I mean it's a scary looking move I just
don't really like that that whole plan
with F5 I just think it's too
um
weakening
and the women haven't
is you know I think it's you know with
the three plus two
going on it's sort of like bang bang
bang bang I wouldn't mind if the Arbiter
said okay let them complete their game
before starting uh
I agree I think it's quite intense and
it's also very distracting truly you
have to listen to people's like slamming
and we see Hikaru take the pawn okay so
what do you think about it Queen takes
is what I would be angling for yeah
and for me these week squares on e4 and
F5 I would go Queen C2 and just uh Queen
D3 just keep an eye on all of those
light squares they're gonna go D5 now
can you go E4 now is the question E4
Knight takes E4 F5
oh sorry
say what no
why not no I thank you Carlos
spots something no oh okay um D5 E4 I
mean D5 is also a possibility Hikaru he
senses something in here even if he
starts using his time and D5 on the
board on the board so yeah you can't go
Bishop takes because it's somehow uh
Wesley has allowed uh Hikaru far more
uh play then he should have gotten now
Bishop G4 is really
he's misplayed this uh terribly I I want
to say uh has Wesley and nicaro has a
very powerful initiative at the moment
but he's still not showing it he seems
very calm
still playing moves fast still keeping
an edge on the clock and
talking about them well he's the
advantage there so Hikaru is allowing
Knight takes F3 it hasn't forced the
weakening of the well I think we did had
to do
Pawn text because Knight E5 was coming
so Knight takes F3 Knight E5 was the
concern yeah okay
so a trade the bishop got a very secure
Square on D5 but it's this King side
that I would be uh
very very fretful about Bishop thanks
before what whoa whoa whoa Bishop takes
B4 what is this blunder alert bundler
alert and he's done it snap right that's
that's a blunder
wow normally you don't see Wesley making
that kind of a blundery I mean rookie 8
set up pretty obvious
um
sorry somehow from his peace movement he
he just seemed too relaxed Wesley even
this move rooked to E1 it felt too
relaxed maybe he lost concentration for
a second there
trade of Bishops
thing
okay Queen C7
that's a healthy Pawn up for him okay uh
this bishop on H3 if I go Queen H4 it's
got to go but wait a minute C3 is
hanging too oof
uh not a pretty sight for Wesley can you
not just play A4
and uh I like A4 to trade trade some
pieces okay he did want to get rid of
this bishop but Queen takes C3
yep
mikaru says what's better than me that's
it and a handshake and Hikaru takes the
first game again Wesley collapsed it was
really remarkable I thought that
somewhere around here just it was a
normal position I didn't think either
player had anything that special
and then boom it was over in within 10
moves after this let's uh the ladies are
getting set up they're getting set up oh
they already started they already
started and
and we see that so Irina
with the black pieces
and to get the game
we want
and uh
well interesting
arena is very solid play I have to say
and I always I've always noticed that
she takes the you know any kind of
aggressive
actions usually in the middle game so
it's always a solid opening then
aggressive intentions if allowed and uh
there we see Queen F3 and the bad
structure is very stable well for a
Carlsbad Queens Gambit accepted but you
don't usually see this book we have
three uh that's off the Beaten Track I
would say uh Christian oh yes absolutely
it does feel like it
definitely feels like it's c66
nonetheless so we got to go Bishop to D3
arena is definitely trying to simplify
the position as much as possible oh so
you're expecting takes on D6 and queen
not three not yet not yet Bishop to D3
makes a lot of sense but at the right
moment I will take one F3 I will offer
the queen trade with Queen to G3 maybe
that was a missed opportunity to do that
well we were playing for an absolute Rod
that would have been a nice way of
forcing the queen trade yes why not but
Bishop D3 was her choice and uh
remind me again the uh ah of course
there it is gain 10 plus 5.
our wonderful Graphics right in the
middle of the screen
unmissable
okay and uh whilst this game is kind of
Brewing up okay we do see that the men
have sat down and they've become their
games
in a must-win situation and this time no
H4 which is ridiculous I was like the
most ridiculous way of beating the
modern uh
Bishop C4 that's great so Queen E2
oh yes oh yes
and
castles I'm expecting all the moves that
happen have been played like C
akes season 96 but okay remember Wesley
has to keep the game alive at all costs
because it does Castle right and what
will hikara do will he if that is the
standard is it's the standard E5
he played it yeah
95.
and H3 stopping Bishop to G Bishop G4 is
uh that's important right so Knight C6
Knight B6 lots of uh moves have been
tried in this position the idea though
is that white usually maintains it's
almost like a what do you call it alkyne
I wanted to see you say uh with a G6
and you can play moves like Knight A6
here as well as black if you want in
order to go Knight to C5 and to try to
take away that Bishop on B3
and Hikaru with a win or a draw will win
the championship bracket
the extra ten thousand dollars and he
has a nice that's Wesley right now is in
a must win situation if he wants to take
the whole match to Armageddon
quickly so in this position there
theoretically recommended move is Knight
to D4 in order to trade or well in this
case again Wesley has to play for the
win and so he's
as opposed to Knight D4 and let's move
fast
move housing group D1 actually
played this Knight C3 move right well
take the tempo while the tempo is on
after Rook to D1 would it would have hit
the queen now after a move for example
like Bishop E6 you're giving the queen a
choice uh as to where you might go
actually if I'm in black shoes I
probably would play C7 C6 in order to
give my queen the C7 square but uh
Bishop D7 was Wesley's Choice more do
you hide the queen with the C8 or queen
to C8 okay
it's not that he's threatening to play
Bishop takes H3 it's just the kind of
thing that you stop
and consider 55 rookie eight putting
some pressure on E7 that's quite
important
it's actually really difficult for
Wesley to come up with a good aggressive
plan I think at the minute he's just
simply improving his pieces and C5 on
the board
well C5 is one of those moves where you
say I I need to start fighting for some
squares fighting for space and making
moves like Bishop C6 as well as Queen C6
possible
keeping the pieces on the board Bishop
H6 Bishop h8
Wesley didn't want to see a trade of the
two Bishops
I'm sorry what if I go Knight to E4
whoa
did you hear that okay I like it uh wait
how do you defend the policy yeah C4
Rook C5 that's the problem
oops Hikaru he's filling it right I
think Wesley blundered that move frankly
so if we go swimming position and draw
odds oh he's played Bishop C6 I was
about to say C4 Rook C5 Bishop C6 he
played Bishop C6 right away and I don't
like that move
where you can throw the queen forward to
F5 that's what I wanted with C4 as well
yes uh oh this is getting really tough
now
yeah the light squared Bishop will not
fall off E6 is also on tap no uh this is
gone this is just a terrible position
for Wesley Wesley down to under a minute
42 seconds now he takes it yeah this was
not the same modern no it sure was not a
completely different story totally and
it might take C6 that's just so gross uh
like terrible Pawn structure
true maybe even Bishop G5 now Bishop G5
maybe get the bishop to F6 yep exchange
dot R square bishop or even go B4
whatever
I mean there's such an array of nice
moves including B4 Knight 97
okay so now we take on C6 with the
Knight and then go Rook A5 in the worst
case yeah just to keep the pawn on E5
but okay five or Rook C4 Rook H4 tried
the checkmate
I'm getting greedy well I love this
suggestion a moment ago of Bishop G5 and
Bishop F6 that would have been a real
wedge well talking about Bishop G5 you
can do it now and force The Rook Off The
d8 Square I like I love that move he's
very very much Bishop G5 actually and
then keep the Rook on the fifth try yep
yep no need to go for any amateur
Dramatics because the car isn't amateur
as he calls himself even though he's
like number five player in the world
yeah
yeah if Hikari is an amateur yeah I know
what does that make us
makes me a pizza there we go F4
just knocking out
a dark squared Bishop
yeah that kind of puts the kibosh on the
counter play right because once we go 94
96 is coming totally Total Domination
this is it down to his last 20 seconds
yeah this was not a a good a good outing
for Wesley D1 now
going to B7
that we get the knight in let's go 94
right no but there's no need because
he's got Knight D5
don't don't give um
hikara is like Queen C5 then I'm gonna
go naive before
95.
I must say uh I love Knight E4 last turn
and then you go Knight D5 I mean because
this bishop on H6 is just so strong
it defends F4 oh
interesting
H6 but is it F4 hanging it is
something to play for right now exactly
material equality is quite a success
considering how bad the position was
is
93 playable
it's on the board
because if you go Queen D4 I'll go Queen
B6 or maybe even oh yes Queen to B6
exactly guys this is not that easy
anymore no Queen B6 he's done it and
he's
well back in the game is strong but he's
kicking Knight D6 is on but okay maybe
he can go nighttime no he could have
gone Knight takes E5
oh gosh you missed the chance he's on
seconds that's the problem
whoa still still a three result game
still a three result game
B2 is hanging and Hikaru now down to his
last 10 seconds we're up to A7 you've
got to defend them and wait a minute
there's a knight on B8 this game
maybe material but the Knight is not
going anywhere oh Rook to C4 he's
trapped the night and he's blundered his
Knight oh
a knight takes B2 was fine Rook A7 Rook
F3 and I think just around these parts
it was time to play Rook to B8
and uh keep uh that night on B2 defended
I don't know these last two Blitz Games
it felt like Hikaru deserved
oh congratulations yes and yeah
definitely a worthy winner truly and uh
and there we can finally get the
Champions brackets and there we see that
Hikaru Nakamura is in the Grand Final
yes and he will now be awaiting the
victor of the match between Wesley so
and Levon aronian which will be played
tomorrow for the right to go up against
Hikaru in the Grand Final
[Music]
it looks like Irina is in full control I
mean but we have to say
um
situation so she's desperate right and
she wants a position she wants a messy
position where's this some double-edged
tactics and there is double urge tactics
because arena is attacking the king side
something is happening over on the queen
side
but the thing is
is an arena getting there first with the
most I like how Joey said something is
happening because it's not clear what is
happening there's not much of anything
I'm thinking H5 or even the desirable
Knight H5 and Knight F6 checks and
there's nothing actually happening on
the queen side isn't the ideas of going
Queen H5 you know a drawer sufficient
Queen H5 G6 Knight takes she sacrifice
everything sacrifice it all like yeah
there is a bishop F5 check so Knight
takes G6 F takes G6 Bishop takes G6
Bishop F5 check you don't get you you're
Perpetual but you probably are winning
Rook takes C6 in the end too right how
about we just keep a Checkmate come on
let's go H5 let's go true
G6 G6 Pawn storm I agree uh h5's got my
vote completely totally I'm I'm with you
Christian kick the door open kick the
door yeah H5
H6 Knight takes D5 and queen F6
and that just the roof caves in okay how
are you doing on time okay in terms of
time
um Arena has under five minutes whereas
Alice has just over four minutes right
so I mean I don't think there's much in
it there and Arena now thinking
and H5 is just so compelling I mean in
this when the kings are on opposite
flanks it's all about getting to the
other opponents King first and H5 sure
sure looks like you land there very very
quickly H5 Bishop H7 G6 H6 blows open
the king side I can't believe that black
would survive
his attacks but okay you have to
remember Irina is feeling the pressure
and she doesn't want to contain Black's
activities so she's like first that is
exactly what it is it's a safety first
type of move she she's
covering C3 even more than she already
was Knight E2 oh it does prep night here
and
the H5 is not going away H5 H6 is not
going away I I would have preferred H5
but I understand this one I mean again
you're playing the not not just the
position but you're playing the match
situation A draw is sufficient
and it basically says Alice come and get
me like like go crazy analysis fine I'll
do my best and then she's gonna put her
night on A3
H5 let's go
and is it on the board no that's just in
my no no it's on the board it is oh it's
on the board sorry I I made the move and
[Laughter]
and then
it was on the board
open your position H6 followed by Queen
F6 is resigned I'm okay you have to move
your Rook out of your face now I'm
taking on H7 and taking on F7 and that
is going to be curtains yeah maybe mate
or maybe but at least a perpet I'm
taking no risks in that peace sacrifice
so how do we do it H6 she gave a check I
think on A3 okay that's a that's that
that I can handle
one who's like F5
what's the plan here well the night time
the night isn't doing anything on C4 so
you can carry on with yasu's idea of
right F5 is basically Box by the way she
might have given a check on C3 I
apologize I don't think the the board
has updated yet okay let me just uh
maybe we can see the bird's eye view
into the the board updates
no no Alice was thinking
no no there's been some moves it's just
not updating oh I see there there's a
connection so we need a bird's eye view
then okay
oops that's not the bird's eye view
are you in Georgia
it is Knight C3 check and she did
capture uh with the Knight on A4
and she captured that pawn with Rook
take C3 so Irina is not looking at her h
six possibilities Bishop B4 H6 is
probably over
h6s's It's gotta win because you're
gonna go Bishop takes H7 check as a
response to Bishop takes C3 so I'm not
going to let you enjoy anything so H6 is
perhaps my only move to try to defend
this F5 yeah but then I get to go H
takes G7 F7 and try to survive like that
no this no no
she's not gonna miss that opportunity
that's just two compelling Alice has to
go F5 anything else suggest Checkmate in
three moves
yeah yeah you should see three you could
take on H7 you get you give a Checkmate
on Netflix with the queen right
it's she has to go F5 only chance young
lady
two minutes to find the move and three
minutes for Irina piling on the pressure
yep
by the way after F5
do you go G6
try to go well
it was really tempting to do what yasa
suggested you know open a line porn
takes Pawn
yeah get the king out
and then just switch to attack yeah I
agree I agree
you you've got ideas like G6 as well and
yeah no I'm playing hg7 and I'm just
gonna go quick and try even meet but I
was thinking about yeah Christians like
recap seven you know you do have ideas
of going G6 but what's the media sir
show me the mate yes sir show me the
mate
hc7 Rook Sorry Seven Rook F7 Rook F7
Rook C6
Bishop C6 Bishop F5
oh you're too aggressive
very aggressive impressive okay Rook
takes G7 how where's the Checkmate I
still don't see it maybe we should show
it okay so age six we're anticipating
um hg7 Rook F7 yeah
and I wanted it okay we're gonna see it
so Rook F7 don't touch that point
and I was going to sacrifice The Rook
with Rook takes C6 right
Bishop takes C6
Bishop takes F5 threatening both Bishop
takes H7 check and Bishop
and she's played Rook F7 now the money
move
for arena crushes which one is that Rook
takes C6 but then after Bishop takes F5
I take on G7
pardon me what Bishop what
Rook takes G7 Rook takes G7
just a second so check King h8 and shall
I make a Perpetual well no money move
actually on the board because she's just
played Roxy too
oh okay well it's a good it's a good
move right it's a good defending the
moving away I I think she has at least a
prepet is what I want to say yes yeah
after hd7 Rook F7 and Rook C2
I mean come on guys uh this Pawn is
crashed right into Black's camp
G6 is threatening The Rook takes G7
probably the only move if I might go
Rook at fate it's it's not that right
right that's why I'm thinking Knight G3
and Knight takes F5 let's do it yeah
yeah
and you don't have to defend that pawn
on G5 because once black takes the pawn
on G5 the G file opens that's gonna cost
she has played this takes G7 by the way
but if you do
it
yeah but Bishop C3
careful boys
Rook takes B3 check yes yes yes yes yes
that kind of took Arena backwards a
little bit she saw immediately Rook
takes B3 and she said why did I allow
that oh my goodness is it time to get on
our running shoes and
if you get in your running shoes so
there is Rook takes
guys this is not that easy anymore uh
this one is getting seriously
I like that move I think that was a very
very practical decision and after Queen
takes C3 she's played see you see that
Rook takes C6 move would uh would have
really just shut this game down no well
Knight H5 Knight F6 Queen E5 Queen D6 no
he takes F5 Knight takes F5 this is
still completely winning right yeah true
true but I like my age five well I Gotta
Give Alice some credit right I mean you
know she threw it out there Rick takes
B3 was on on the young lady's agenda
and uh talking about Alice she has now
33 seconds on the clock
and she is in a must-win situation if
she wants to take the match to Let's
playoffs and
Arena on the brink of winning the
Champions bracket which will net her an
extra five thousand dollar bonus we will
winner of the tournament yet that's
still to be determined because it's a
double elimination Rook F7
so Alice is really feeling both the
clock as well as the position and Knight
H5 Arena says you know what I've been
taught about this fantastic pattern with
the Knight and queen F4 right she didn't
go she went Knight F6 immediately I was
expecting Queen F4 and Alice is King he
said on who's running shoes and it's out
there in the center exactly the queen
queen F4 give me The Rook or give me
check
nope and whoever loses this match so in
this situation it does look likely that
it's going to be Alice will actually go
down to the elimination bracket where
they will play off tomorrow exactly and
uh Nazi pakiza is ready and waiting for
the runner-up and for the runner-up and
they will fight it out between them and
whoever wins that then goes up to the
Grand Final Queen E5 check you can't
play Bishop E6 Rook H6 would have been
terrifying King to d8 on the board Jason
G6 quite terrifying uh G6 is very very
strong uh that's a that that that's it
that's winds G6 the end and Irina 24
seconds but you know this is she will
find it yes she will
um that's her bread and butter again I
mean that move is so strong but it
should have been made like almost
instantly like
you take my queen I take your Rook
there's no stopping the pawn from
promoting Rook E7 you just take it
10 seconds for arena she mustn't
forget the clock
as she did in a previous game she played
the move with one second on her class
well she doesn't have much time now
she did that with three seconds to spare
uh where's her confidence she seems like
her confidence got shot somewhere
uh
A5 well
Knight takes D7 good enough
A4 A3 you're one move away from creating
a checkmating threat whoa whoa what was
that no no oh Knight C5 Discovery is
coming yeah okay wow
and you have to go for it but still
Knight C5 is coming A3 this is on board
game B6 Queen takes B7 followed by Queen
to A7 take the pawn on A3 take the pawn
oh
something is really upset at her she's
yes it did okay broke into a smile
because she won but something really put
her off her delicious
really quite a tough customer it hasn't
been easy for her you know we saw her
struggle to draw this little component
ending very complicated and then of
course she was on the back foot in the
uh the first tiebreak game right and
then here again a lot of emotions well
let's sum it up yeah five thousand
dollars extra yes absolutely and there
she is the winner of the Champions
bracket and she gets a place into the
Grand Final right and here we see that
Hikaru Nakamura is the winner of the
Champions bracket also gets ten thousand
dollar bonus and also a place in the
Grand Final as well
and we see the Champions bracket not
come over and Wesley so we'll play Lavon
tomorrow to determine uh who gets into
the Grand Final and of course Alice Lee
will play Naji uh as well to determine
gets into the Grand Final in the ladies
bracket sum it up
for us
a Christian
already here
well we're going to get some resolution
in uh the Elimination Brackets tomorrow
right that's the plan the rest day is
finally here for the Champions bracket
they get into basking The Laurels they
get their roses you know all the good
stuff and they're waiting for who's
going to come from the elimination
bracket for the grand finals and we're
going to be here to call all the action
it's fast and furious it's going to be
rapid and Bliss chest tomorrow so stay
tuned don't go anywhere we'll see you
tomorrow lovely thank you Christian and
Jovi it was really really fun thank you
for watching and joining uh the
conversation we'll see you all tomorrow
Time same place see you then
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited